Ich hab nicht ausgeschlafen, aber das macht nix.
Deswegen machen wir jetzt die Aufwachen stream.
Es ist warm?
Wirklich?
Geht so.
Deck.
Wetter checken.
12 Grad.
Kegweight.
Ist nicht warm.
Nochmal Home Assistant Kungen.
Wetter.
13 Grad.
Stopp.
Ist nicht warm.
Es ist nicht warm.
Omega Lul.
Ich finde meinen Chat nicht mehr.
Ach so, das ist warm.
Ach so, jetzt verstehe ich es.
Ach so.
Adam regnet.
Hier ist so gemischt, aber zum größten Teil Wolken.
Zum Glück war gestern noch mal gescheit Wetter.
Konnte ich wieder ein bisschen Wanderstells machen.
Leute, ihr werdet sich glauben, ich habe den Labelchamp gestern offstream weiterprogrammiert
und habe wahrscheinlich mehr hingekriegt als in drei Streams zusammen.
Wir haben jetzt, vielleicht machen wir am Mittag weiter.
Wir haben jetzt sogar Critlines, wo die ganzen Elemente zusammensnappen können und sowas.
Wenn ihr nicht dabei wart, wisst ihr wahrscheinlich nicht wovon ich rede, aber wer dabei war,
kann sich vielleicht vorstellen.
Also sowas hier, guckt mal.
Ich zeige euch das mal schnell, was ich meine.
Auch wenn es komplett keiner checkt, der sich den Stream nicht angeguckt hat, aber guckt
mal.
Sowas kann mein Programm...
Ich kann es euch jetzt nicht zeigen, weil ich habe den Sauskont nicht hier, aber können
wir uns mal mit nachher angucken.
Guckt mal, sowas kann der Labelchamp jetzt auch...
Wait a minute.
Warum snap...
Hä?
Moment, warum snappt das nicht zusammen?
Normalerweise kann das...
Können die das?
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen habe ich das Gesnapper ausgeschaltet.
Hä?
Can't wait?
Normalerweise snappen die Dinger zusammen.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine, oder?
Also...
Hä?
Habe ich das irgendwie ausgeschaltet, dass der Kram snappt?
Ah, Snapping.
Ja, guck mal, das kann mein Programm jetzt auch so Dinger hier snappen.
Snappen.
So wie hier.
Können wir uns mal mit nachher angucken.
Wie ist die Geschichte mit den Reifen ausgegangen?
Noch gar nicht.
Ich lasse das am Montag machen, ich brauche mein Auto ja eigentlich so gut wie nie.
Ich habe gedacht, bevor ich da jetzt noch in der Weltgeschichte rum fahre und, ähm...
Ja, irgendwie noch bei 5 Dingern Anruf oder so.
Also das mache ich jetzt einfach am Montag, gut ist.
Dienstag brauche ich es vielleicht, je nachdem, aber ich fahre wahrscheinlich Dienstag nach
Frankfurt mit dem Zug.
Aber die Sommerferien, äh, Osterferien sind rum, glaube ich, sind die Osterferien rum?
Nächste Woche, Leute, Hessen, Osterferien, die sind rum, bis Schulferien in Hessen,
vielleicht war.
Die sind rum.
Die sind schon rum nächste Woche, naja, ob ich dann, ja, ich fahre mit dem Zug, naja,
ist egal.
Ja, richtig, Bonka DB, da wäre das passende E-Mode für.
Soll ich euch mal was sagen, Chat?
Ich habe heute Morgen schon gleich wieder richtig Vogue gemacht, ich habe nämlich im
Bett, den Satz versteht auch außerhalb von Twitch keiner, also ich bin von so, ich bin
von so zu so gegangen ungefähr, weil ich habe heute Morgen ein Handy aufgemacht und
das erste YouTube Video, was ich empfohlen bekommen habe, ist neue Rungen in, und jetzt
haltet euch fest, C++23, da habe ich mir gedacht, nee, ich gucke mir jetzt kein 53-Minuten-Video
an, zu was für komische, wirre Sachen sie wieder gemacht haben und ich bin auf die ganz
schlechte Idee gekommen und habe mir folgende Seite angeguckt und danach habe ich mir wieder
gedacht, als ich hier drüber gescrollt habe, ist mir mal wieder aufgefallen, was für ein
absoluter Shit fest C++ ist, Chat, wer von euch, C++-Kenner, wer von euch kennt den Unterschied,
jetzt ohne Google, Google kann ich auch und ich weiß den Unterschied mittlerweile auch,
wer kennt den Unterschied zwischen Standard Basic String und Standard String, warum gibt
es da überhaupt verschiedene Sachen, na ich meine, den Unterschied zwischen Standard
Basic String und Standard Basic String View, den kann ich mir im Kopf ja noch zusammen
bauen, das eine ist quasi eine Art Pointer auf Teile vom String und das andere ist die
Zeichenkette selbst, aber warum gibt es Standard String und warum gibt es Standard Basic String,
ich kenne keine Programmiersprache außer C++, die sowas hat, ja, ich verstehe es nicht,
also doch ich verstehe es, soll ich euch erklären, soll ich euch sagen, was der Unterschied ist,
soll ich euch sagen, warum es Standard Basic String und Standard String braucht, also für
alle C++-Pros und die, die es werden wollen, Standard Basic String ist ein Template und
Standard String ist ein Standard Basic String für Character, also quasi das da ist quasi
das, was man als Alias oder Standard String findet, warum, ich weiß es nicht, also ich
weiß es schon, aber ich verstehe nicht, warum man das so macht, das ist, dass man eigene
Stringtypen definiert, aber was braucht man denn eigene String, mal ganz im Ernst, wozu
braucht man 20 verschiedene Stringtypen, eigene Stringtypen, das braucht man doch nur, weil
der in C++ eingebaute Standard String absolute Bullshit ist, was ist Unicodes in 2022 beziehungsweise
was ist UTF-8, genau, du brauchst das, du brauchst das und um verschiedene Encodings
abzubilden, aber das könnte man alles anders machen, das könnte man alles unter der Hood
in Standard String handeln, damit muss ich mich überhaupt nicht auseinandersetzen, wenn
man das ordentlich macht, aber C++ ist nicht ordentlich, das muss man sich abschminken,
weiß gar nicht warum ich mich darum kümmern soll, warum es mich überhaupt interessieren
soll als Entwickler, ich mein, wenn man das irgendwo in den Untiefen, in irgendwelchen
Interface Namespaces, was auch immer versteckt, dass es in irgendwelchen krassen Sonderfällen
geht, okay, aber trotzdem, ey, warte mal, dass in C++ jeder seinen komischen eigenen
Stringtyp hat, ganz, ganz eklig Leute, ganz eklig und ernsthaft, wenn ihr euch das hier
durchlässt und ich hab, ich mein, ich bin kein Profi C++ Programmierer, das will ich
auch nicht werden, weil dann dreh ich wahrscheinlich durch im Kopf, aber ich hab schon nicht gerade
so wenig C++ gemacht, gerade seitdem ich die letzten paar Jahre angefangen hab, Microcontroller
Zeug zu programmieren, also ich hab sicherlich schon einige, ja, hunderte Stunden mit C++
rumgemacht, trotzdem bin ich natürlich weit davon entfernt der krasse C++ Checker zu sein,
aber trotzdem so ein bisschen kenne ich mich da auch aus, ich würde sagen, ich kenne mich
sogar halbwegs brauchbar aus, ganz okay, ja, aber wenn ich mir das hier durchlese, dieses
Dokument zu neuen Features in C++, fällt mir auf, dass 90% der Features absolut nichts
sagt, wenn ich keine Ahnung hab, was die uns damit sagen wollen, ich mein, das verstehe
ich jetzt noch, ja, es gibt jetzt CYST quasi auch Sign und Anzeigen, alles in Ordnung,
es gibt Contains, by the way, String Contains gab es anscheinend noch nicht, Contains in
einem Standard String Typ, wir sind aber C++, das ist normal, du konntest ja in C++ lange
Zeit nicht mal String to Upper to Lower Case machen, eingebaut, in der String, da muss
ich mal überlegen, C++ hatte bis glaube ich, bis zur letzten Version, keinen offiziellen
String, String in Großbuchstaben und in Kleinen Buchstaben umwandeln, außer über Umwege
mit extra Schleife und sowas, muss man sich mal vorstellen, so, und die anderen Sachen
checkt kein Mensch mehr, hier, okay, Stag Trades, Stag Trades ist Scoped, Stag Trades ist
irgendwelche Compile Time Check Sachen, was auch immer, so, irgendwelche Iterator, wo
ich keine Mensch versteht, wie man Iterator in C++ implementiert, dann haben sie die Requirements
Relaxed to Time Point Glock, alles klar, Standard Visit, Standard Variant, was auch immer, das
ist übrigens mein Lieblingschange, Locks, Lock Lockables, wird to Upper Case to Lower
Case benötigt, ja, laufen, ich würde mal fast behaupten, to Upper Case to Lower Case
sind mit in den Top 5 meist benutzten String Methoden, ja, neben so Sachen wie Split und
Replace, wo ich mir gar nicht sicher bin, ob das C++ Standard Klasse überhaupt hat
für Strings aus dem Kopf, du brauchst zum Beispiel to Upper to Lower Case immer wenn
du Case Insensitive suchen willst, dann machst du beides, nämlich dein Suchwort und den String
zu Lower Case oder zu Upper Case und dann kannst du Case Insensitive suchen, also das ist aber
übrigens hier meine Lieblingsänderung, Locks, Lock Lockables, C++ 23 Standard, alles klar,
jetzt willst du mal Bescheid, müssen sich Programmiersprünge überhaupt noch, ja, müssen
sie, ja gut, wenn es danach geht, könnten wir auch alles in Fortran programmieren, müssen
sie schon, es ergeben sich immer wieder neue Sachen, beispielsweise so die letzten paar
Jahre ist der Trend oder geht der Trend finde ich gerade dahin, dass so die Oldschool Programmiersprachen
gerade die noch aus der Zeit kommen, wo Objektorientierung ist das Beste überhaupt, also gerade wenn
man sich mal C Sharp anguckt, dass das immer mehr Einschläge von Funktionalen Sachen bekommt,
guckt ihr beispielsweise mal irgendwelche neue Patternmatch oder guckt ihr mal generell
Go an, Go ist viel Funktionaler als das beispielsweise Java oder C Sharp ist, obwohl es neuer ist,
das ist so ein Mischmasch, also ja ich finde schon, Go hat letztens Generics bekommen,
ich meine, wie konnte man das überhaupt ohne Leben, also natürlich muss ich das weiter
entwickeln, ich muss aber sagen, dass Microsoft finde ich ziemlich gute Balance findet bei
C Sharp, was Neuerungen angeht, die sind meistens sinnvoll, nicht alle, manche dann bräuchte
ich nicht, aber die meisten sind sinnvoll, so wir scrollen nochmal kurz drüber, dass
ihr euch den Wahnsinn mal angucken könnt, also neuer C++ 23 Standard, Locks, Lockables,
alles klar, wir gucken uns mal schnell wie das aussieht, passt mal auf, so sieht das
aus, Moment, Beispiel, Lock Guard, Mutex Type, Adopt Lock T, was, gibt es da ein Beispiel
für, ne, ich meine sogar dieser Standard ist abfuckmäßig, dass du nicht verstehst,
was er will, was zum, alles klar, ok, Lock, Lock, Lockables, sowieso, müssen wir mal,
Conditional Borrow Ranges, ok, To Underlying, was auch immer, so, es gibt noch mehr, und
ab jetzt wird es richtig abgedreht, const eval if, if const eval, alles klar, das ist
irgendwelche Compile Time Checker, das Bool sich automatisch konvertiert, Standard Span,
gibt es jetzt ein String Based Span Stream, ich hab das Gefühl, die führen random immer
neue Sachen in die Standard Library ein, hier in C++ Standard und es dauert 15 Jahre,
das ist die ganze Compiler, das eben, ach ja, wir haben jetzt übrigens Standard Out Pointer
und Standard In Pointer, als wäre Standard Pointer, Unique Pointer, Shared Pointer,
Left Reference, Right Reference, L Type, Right Type, was auch immer, nur nicht kompliziert
genug, eigentlich ist sie scharp für Anfänger, ja, da ich ziemlich gut einsteige als Sprache,
dann kannst du ja was weiß ich, Compile Zeit Checken noch für Optional Variant und für
Standard Type Info Operator gleich, gleich, alles klar, so du kannst jetzt den neuen Konstruktor
für den Standard Stack, Standard Queue, Range Changes, das mag ja durchaus ok sein, man
darf jetzt aus einem Null Pointer keinen Basic String mehr machen, muss man sich vorstellen,
das war vorher möglich, ja, Standard Format, das ist das einzig gute, was es in C++ gibt,
ohne Scheiß Leute, dass die Format Library, die noch fast kein Compiler komplett implementiert
hat, weil es C++ ist, ist das einzig gute oder eines der wenig guten Sachen an C++ und
wisst ihr auch warum das gut ist, weil sie es komplett aus Python geklaut haben, das
sagt der Typ, das sagt der Autor dieser Library sogar, was aber auch ok ist, weil das wie
du vorher Strings formatiert hast in C++ war ja absolut abfuck, ich mein, die haben, guck
mal, man muss sich mal überlegen, man hat jahrelang in C++, so hat man Strings formatiert,
ja, muss man sich mal vorstellen, 2022, Alter, also Standard Format ist wirklich ganz gut,
es hört übrigens auch nicht auf, das lese ich euch jetzt nicht vor, weil spätestens
das checkt keiner mehr, es checkt niemand mehr, decay copy in language auto mit geschweifen
klammert nix, auto in ekisch, was, keine Ahnung, du kannst den multidimensional subscript operator
kannst du overloaden, alles klar, wollte ich schon immer mal machen, ja, du kannst alias
declaration init statements machen, init statements ist der Kram, weil man sich gedacht hat Constructor
sind zu dumm, also das da, das da ist ein init statement und das ist, wenn man den Construct,
also mit auto nicht, aber wenn ich eine Klasse so anlege, dann ist es der Constructor und
wenn ich das so anlege, ist es der init, ist es der init, was auch immer, ja, man kann
jetzt, mehr Präprozessor hat die Welt auch gebraucht und dann hat man solche schönen
Dinge, ich mein, alleine schon, dass man sowas reinschreiben muss in seine Dokumentation,
weiß man doch, da ist irgendwas nicht richtig, oder, Standard Basic Stack, Standard PMR Polymorphic
Allocator, was, warum steht das da überhaupt drin, the range library, das lasse ich mir
noch gefallen, Standard Move Only, Monadic Operations to Standard Optional, Standard Basic
String Resize and Override, aber jetzt kann man Volatile Pointer printen, Byte Swap, heterogenes
löschen von Overloads, alles klar, Standard Span, es ist jetzt, ok Leute, Standard Span
und Standard Basic Swing, wir sind jetzt einfach zu kopieren, Trivial Copyable, Standard Exchange,
was auch immer, Standard Expected, Const Exprifots, alles klar, Leute, also, das ist schon teilweise
sinnig, gerade die Sachen für Ranges und Format, aber der Rest ist einfach noch mehr
verwirrenden Kram auf noch mehr verwirrenden Kram, in der Hoffnung, man macht es weniger
verwirrend, was aber nicht passiert, was verdient so ein Informatiker Studium oder Ausbildung
netto so Mitte 30 in der freien Wirtschaft, wenn man durch den, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh,
Alter, aber ist eigentlich mit dem Hals wieder besser, ja ich wurde heute Quasi aus dem Schlaf
gerissen, weil ich ein Video empfohlen bekomme, weil ich schonOps auf Youtube geguckt habe,
zum ersten Mal, also, zum ersten mal ein Video zu C++23, ja dazu, Heiser hat Gehaltsumfragen
und das kann man pauschal nicht beantworten, weil, du kannst dir auch ein Video dazu angucken
oder die Videos dazu angucken, das hängt ganz entscheidend davon ab, in welcher Branche
du bist, was du für Erfahrungen hast in welchem Bereich und vor allem halt auch in welcher
Stadt und in welcher Region und beim Arbeiten, das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Durchschnittsmäßig sind die Gehaltsreports bei Heise nicht schlecht, es gibt aber auch
noch mehr.
Ist eine Karriere nach dem Bachelorstudium in Informatik bei dir?
Aber ich hab keine Ahnung, wo soll ich das wissen, ich war nie bei der Bundeswehr.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wenn die aber bezahlen, wie die meisten Ämter, dann ist das erstmal
nicht so geil, aber, das hab ich letztens bei Algorithmen verstehen in einem Video gelernt,
wenn man eine Weile dabei bleibt und dann irgendwie, also wenn man höhere Gehaltsstufen
und höhere Erfahrungsstufen hat, äh ne, ja doch, ne, wenn man höhere Gehaltsstufen
und höhere Betriebs- oder Amtszugehörigkeitsstufen hat, dann wird das ganz in Ordnung, ich mein,
du wirst wahrscheinlich dort nie so viel verdienen, wie, äh, wenn du einen richtig, richtig guten
Job hast, der auch richtig gut bezahlt wird in der freien Wirtschaft, aber es ist durchaus
in Ordnung und der große Vorteil anscheinend ist, wenn du durchschnittlich ambitioniert
bist, wie es gerade jemand geschrieben hat, ähm, dann ist es wahrscheinlich bei einem
Amt gar nicht so schlecht, deswegen treffen sich und tummeln sich da wahrscheinlich auch
viele durchschnittlich motivierte oder ambitionierte, also wäre eigentlich genau das Richtige für
mich, weil du kriegst quasi mehr Geld durch nichts machen, einfach nur da sein, was auch
nicht verkehrt ist, ansonsten bei der Bundeswehr keine Ahnung, aber ich würde aus Prinzip
nicht zur Bundeswehr, weiß nicht, ich kann, stell mir das irgendwie nicht so als, ähm,
gerade, also gerade in der IT, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, da hat für
mich nie zur Diskussion gestanden, selbst ob ich zur Bundeswehr gehe oder nicht, ne, mach
ich nicht, und wo wir gerade dabei sind, investieren Leute, die China-Chinesen haben zugeschlagen,
guckt euch das mal an, letzte Woche, meine, meine Stonks, erinnert ihr euch noch, wo
ich gesagt habe, ich bin Skalierungsfehler, ne, ne, ist kein Skalierungsfehler, und wahrscheinlich
geht das montags gleich so weiter, Stonks gehen gleich ab, not, not Stonks, was ist passiert,
die China-Chinesen lassen keine Schiffe mehr nach Shanghai rein, musstest du noch Grundwehrdienst
machen, ja, hätte ich machen müssen, sag ich gleich was tu, Hafen-Shanghai, guck, da
gibt's doch dieses, ja, das ist, das ist übrigens nicht, nicht die Battlefield 2042
Map, da gibt's doch hier das da, guck mal, da sieht man, wie die Schiffe sich stauen,
das ist richtig heftig, da sind alle Schiffe.
So, was, wo musstest du dich durchbeißen, ja, meine Motivation, als wäre meine Motivation
als ultrakrass hoch, das ist normal, was hat er denn geschrieben, um, um was ging's denn
bei euch hier, ach so, ah, Motivation, ja, also ganz ehrlich, meine Motivation hält
sich teilweise auch in Grenzen, vor allem immer dann, wenn meine Woche zu 70% aus irgendwelchem
Gemiete besteht, Leute, ich lese euch, ich lese euch das mal kurz vor, ich mach mal kurz
mein, mein Kalender auf, ich muss es aber leider ein bisschen, ein bisschen, äh, anonymisieren,
so, letzte, letzte Woche, letzte Woche, war mal, letzte Woche, ging's eigentlich,
letzte Woche, Dienstag, ja, Dokumentationsmeeting, Change, Changeboard, äh, Teambesprechung,
täglicher Austausch, so, und das alles Vormittag, das heißt, ich hab Vormittag im Prinzip bis
13.30 Uhr nix gemacht, so, äh, Rücksprache-Meeting, Daily-Meeting, täglicher Austausch, äh,
noch weitere, weitere Gruppenrunde, ähm, Server-Config-Meeting, Stand-Up, ähm, oh,
das hab ich vergessen, da war ich nicht, doch, da war ich, da war ich, da hab ich mich anscheißen,
das hab ich anscheißen gekriegt auf dem Meeting, stimmt, ich weiß es noch, Stand-Up, das muss
man sich mal vorstellen, ne, ich, ich, ich bin in, ich, ich steh in diesem Stand-Up-Meeting,
ich stehe nicht, ich sitze, weil ich daheim im Homeoffice bin, ähm, ich bin da, und da
meint der Chef, der dieses, oder der Typ, der dieses, das, das Meeting, Meeting führt,
meinte so zu mir, ähm, ja, Max, dann fang mal an, und da hab ich gesagt, ja, also, wie's,
wie's schon im Protokoll steht, gibt nix, gibt nix Interessantes, ja, und da hab ich
erst mal einen Anschiss gekriegt, warum ich das nicht richtig im Protokoll eingetragen
hab, dass es nix gibt, ich mein, ich mein doch, ja, da steht ja nix im Protokoll drin,
ja, ne, aber das ist falsch, man muss die Standardpunkte löschen und reinschreiben,
keine neuen Punkte, über solche Sachen regen wir uns da auf, ja, also, das ist halt Business,
Business Enterprise, das ist aber nicht wild, ja, also, das, ich, äh, mich nervt das nicht
persönlich oder so, das sind halt so Probleme, die man nur in der Business-Storms-Enterprise-Welt
hat, ja, ja, also, meine Motivation ist auch nicht sonderlich hoch, wenn ich Anschüsse
kriege und, und, wenn ich, ähm, so viel mieten muss, die ganze Zeit, das find ich auch nicht
so geil, oder, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was mich auch unglaublich demotiviert, wohin fragt
ihr eure Punkte, Confluence, ähm, was wollt ich jetzt sagen, wisst ihr, ich wollt, ich
hab angefangen, wisst ihr, was mich auch immer ultra demotiviert, achso, ja, ich weiß es
wieder, wisst ihr, was mich auch ultra demotiviert, wenn die Leute vergessen, oder wenn, sag mal,
das Unternehmen, wo ich arbeite, vergisst, was für eine Position ich eigentlich hab,
also, als was ich eingestellt bin, wie ich das meine ist, naja, ich bin ja da als, nennen
wir es mal so ganz grob, die Kategorie, ich bin ja da als Techniker, ich bin da nicht
als Management oder Organisator, ich bin weder dafür verantwortlich, irgendwelche Abläufe
zu planen, noch bin ich irgendwie dafür verantwortlich, irgendwelche Projekte, Sachen zu koordinieren
oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen einzuteilen, dafür haben wir Leute, aber, ähm, man vergisst
das immer öfters, dass man dafür Leute hat, hab ich den Eindruck, weil die letzten Jahre
über kommt das schon immer so, dass die total oft irgendwelchen Technikern zusätzlich noch
massig organisatorische Sachen aufs Auge drücken wollen, ja, und zum Beispiel, wir
hatten letztens Probleme mit Zertifikaten, lag nicht an uns, wir, also ganz grob, abstrakt,
dass ich nicht so viele Namen verrate, wir haben ein Zertifikat ausgewechselt, auf einem
Load-Palencer, was abgelaufen wäre in 14 Tagen, also, da denkt man sich jetzt so, ja, eigentlich
ja nichts Schlimmes, oder, weil der Kram läuft eh in 14 Tagen ab, also würde man, oder
Chet, also, du würdest jetzt eigentlich nichts Böses bei denken, ja, also es war vorher
ein gültiges Zertifikat und es war danach auch ein gültiges Zertifikat, gar kein
Problem, haben wir ausgetauscht und auf einmal morgens regt sich einer von unseren Mobile-Entwicklern
wahnsinnig auf, wie wir einfach nachts das Zertifikat austauschen können, wir haben
das nicht einfach ausgetauscht, wir haben das auf unserer Change-Runde angekündigt, wir
haben das in unserem Change-Log drinsteht, außerdem läuft das Zertifikat in 14 Tagen
ab, was sollen wir denn machen, das laufen lassen bis es abläuft, oder, was ist das
Problem, und dann meint er, ja, seine Mobile-App geht jetzt nicht mehr, warst du denn auch
im Cup, ja, wir haben auch ein Change-Advisory-Board, was sollen wir denn machen, soll das ablaufen
lassen bis es komplett, bis alles abkackt, weil das Zertifikat, sondern hat sich rausgestellt,
seine App ist kacke programmiert, die haben in ihrer App nämlich, warum auch immer, fragt
mich nicht, warum das so ist, die checken in ihrer App nämlich, nicht etwa, ist das Zertifikat
gültig, ist das Ablaufdatum richtig und sowas, nein, die checken in ihrer App, ist der Aussteller
des Zertifikats explizit diese Zertifizierungsstelle und unsere neuen Zertifikate kommen von Let's
Encrypt mittlerweile, die kommen nicht mehr von der alten Zertifizierungsstelle, die wir
vor 5 Jahren viel Geld in Bobbes geschoben haben, die kommen mittlerweile von Let's Encrypt
und seine App ist abgekackt, weil das Zertifikat jetzt von Let's Encrypt kommt, nicht weil
es nicht gültig war oder so, so, und dann haben die einen riesen Aufriss gemacht, dann
haben die einen riesen Aufriss gemacht, dass ihre App angeblich durch den Zertifikatstausch
kaputt gegangen wäre und da musste ich auf, oder ich sag mal ich, ich weiß, also ich persönlich
war gar nicht da bei diesem einen Meeting jetzt, aber ich weiß es, weil ich vorher
bei allen dabei war und ich mich danach erkundigte, was bei diesem einen rausgekommen ist, zudem
wollte ich auch nicht und dann haben sie zig Retrospektiven gemacht und auf dem einen,
wo ich nicht dabei war, wurde dann behauptet, so nach dem Motto, wir sollen uns jetzt um
die weitere Koordination kümmern, weil wir hätten es ja auch kaputt gemacht und da hat
dann glücklicherweise der Kollege plus noch zwei andere, die da waren, das klargestellt,
dass was es kaputt gemacht hat, die bescheuerte Programmierung der App war und nicht unser
Zertifikatstausch, weil der Zertifikatstausch hätte stattfinden müssen, in 14 Tagen läuft
er. Und dann haben die allen Ernstes richtig, richtig rum genervt, dass wir, also diejenigen,
die die Technik gemacht haben, das Lautbalanzen, das Konfigurierens im Endeffekt, dass wir
jetzt koordinieren, wann sie ihre Tests der App machen sollen, wann jetzt neue Zertifikate
ausgestellt werden, wann jetzt irgendwo, nein, das machen wir nicht, dafür haben wir Leute,
die sind dafür da, das zu koordinieren, die wollten da drauf bestehen, deswegen, leider
war ich dann nicht direkt dabei, aber ich habe dann die Nachwählen mitbekommen und das
ist so krass, warum, was wollen die von uns eigentlich alle? So haben wir aber nicht gemacht,
haben wir nicht gemacht, glücklicherweise war dann irgendein Change-Koordinator dabei,
der das übernommen hat, aber allein schon, dass man diese Diskussionen führen muss, fuckt
mich immer richtig ab. Ja, und was ich auch wieder gelernt habe, ist, es gibt kaum Leute
auf der Welt, die ein bisschen checken, wofür Zertifikate da sind. Das habe ich nämlich
auch gemerkt, da hat ein Entwickler, ich würde sogar mal behaupten, das ist der Chef von
der Mobile-Entwicklung, bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ich glaube, das ist der Chef
von der Mobile-Entwicklung, pass mal auf, wisst ihr was der zu mir gesagt hat? Der hat
mir das erklärt, dass das nicht stimmt, der hat mir erklärt, dass es nicht stimmt, also
ich habe ihm gesagt, wir müssen das Zertifikat tauschen, in 14 Tagen läuft das Zertifikat
ab, wenn das Zertifikat abläuft, da geht viel mehr nicht mehr als nur unsere App, dann
ist total komplett alles kaputt, fällt das auch unter Zertifikat-Pinning, ja das ist
sowas in der Richtung, genau, also da geht sehr viel kaputt, wenn das in 14 Tagen abläuft
und da hat er zu mir gesagt, ja wie jetzt, das läuft doch gar nicht in 14 Tagen ab, natürlich
läuft, ich tausche das Zertifikat halt aus Just For Fun, das läuft in 14 Tagen ab, und
ich meinte, nein, er hat eben gerade reingeguckt, das Zertifikat läuft 2050 ab.
Hat er beim Rute, korrekt, da hat sich das Rute Zertifikat von der CA angeguckt, das
läuft 2050 ab, die haben keine Ahnung, die haben kein Plan was sie machen, ich weiß
gar nicht, wie man überhaupt eine lauffähige App mit solchen Leuten auf die Reihe kriegt,
keine Ahnung, unglaublich, also, und da sich dann auch hinzustellen und das so zu verkaufen
als hat man voll den Durchblick, das regt mich unglaublich auf, so, dann haben sie mich
aber ab, ich wollte ja eigentlich sagen, nein, das ist ein anderes Zertifikat, haben sie
mich, so, zumindest, der Hit kam dann, die haben sich dann auf diesem Emergency Meeting,
ne, der hat sich nicht dumm gestellt, der meint das ernst, da bin ich mir ziemlich
sicher, so, auf diesem Emergency Meeting haben sie gesagt, ja, dann tauschen wir jetzt, pass
mal auf, wisst ihr was die Problemlösung war, da haben sie gesagt, wir tauschen jetzt
das Zertifikat wieder zurück, weil das läuft ja noch 14 Tage, und ich kenn unseren Laden,
wenn wir jetzt das Zertifikat zurücktauschen, dann ist das Problem behoben und niemand,
jeder kümmert sich freiwillig darum, dass das Zertifikat ausgetauscht wird in den nächsten
14 Tagen und wir laufen direkt auf, es geht kaputt zu, deswegen haben wir uns auch so
dagegen gewehrt, dass wir das irgendwie koordinieren, und als sie das gesagt haben, da war dann
der Abteilungsleiter, war dann dabei, hat gemeint, ja, wir tauschen es jetzt zurück, da hab
ich dann gesagt, dem Meeting nochmal, also, ich will jetzt nochmal darauf hinweisen, wenn
wir das zurücktauschen, in 14 Tagen geht alles kaputt, wenn das Zertifikat, aber ich will
das bloß mal gesagt haben, da hab ich in dem Meeting einen Anschluss bekommen, dass wir
doch jetzt Probleme haben, und nicht in 14 Tagen, und dann hab ich mir gesagt, wisst
ihr was, ihr könnt mich mal, macht was ihr wollt, das hab ich nicht wörtwörtlich gesagt,
ja, aber ich hab gesagt, macht was ihr wollt, tauscht aus, ist mir egal, solange wir das
nicht koordinieren, ich koordinier hier gar nichts, macht ihr mal, tja angeblich wird
am Montag jetzt das Zertifikat ausgetauscht, ich bin mal gespannt, also, wir tauschen,
jetzt passt mal auf, haltet euch mal fest, die wollen am Montag das Zertifikat austauschen,
und am Dienstag läuft das Zertifikat ab, das heißt, wenn das nicht funktioniert, aus
irgendwelchen Gründen, wenn das nicht funktioniert, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, ist am 26. komplett
im Arsch, also wenn ihr lest am 26., dass es bei irgendeiner Bank, bei irgendeiner Frankfurter
Bank, eh, großflächige Zertifikatsmeldungen gibt, dann sind wir bei Heise wahrscheinlich,
ja, dann bin ich mal gespannt, dann, also, wisst ihr was ich dann sag, dann sag ich wirklich,
ich hab's euch gesagt, also, ich hab das nicht nur, pass mal, ich hab das nicht nur
in diesem Ursprungsmeeting gesagt, ich hab das an zig Dailys gesagt, ich hab das in
der Retrospektive, in das Protokoll von der Retrospektive, also, ich hab dem Typ, der
das Protokoll für die Retrospektive erstellt, hat das geschrieben, dem Typ, der die Retrospektive
durchgeführt hat, geschrieben, und am Ende reingeguckt, da steht es auch, also, steht
überall drin, mal gespannt, ja, solche Sachen, also, es ist wirklich der absolute Wahnsinn,
ich bin eh begeistert, wie viele Leute so krass unfähig sind, in dem Beruf quasi, wo sie
eigentlich Geld für bekommen, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, ja, Montag hab ich frei, das
ist nicht schlimm, Montag wird das Zertifikat getauscht, das passiert noch nicht, Dienstags
passiert was, aber Dienstags abends erst, das Zertifikat läuft, glaub ich, Dienstag
um 18.30 Uhr oder so ab, oder 18 Uhr, oder so, ich schick den, wenn das passiert, schick
ich den in ein Rickroll-Video in Teams Chat, ja, dann sag ich dann hier, poste ich da einen
Link bei uns im Teams, hier, das müsst ihr machen, dass es wieder funktioniert, und dann,
das gar nicht, aber das, ja, genau, ich poste einfach in Teams Chat einen Link, hier, das
müsst ihr machen, damit es wieder funktioniert.
Okay, denn da schmeißen sie mich wahrscheinlich raus, egal, ich sage, wie auf jeden Fall, ich
hab's euch gesagt, wenn das in die Hose geht, auf der anderen Seite sollen sie machen, so,
du bekommst eine IT-Zulage bei Behörden, einschickt ihr eine Hürde, ja, da kannst du dich nicht
beschweren, vor allem, weil du ja anscheinend auch weniger Steuern bezahlen musst, wenn
du bei irgendeinem Bundes- oder Länder- oder sonst was Laden bist, ja, das ist tatsächlich
dann ganz okay, aber ich würde es zum Beispiel nie kriegen, weil ich hab hier irgendwann
mal vor 15 an Fachinformatiker gelernt und nicht studiert, das kannst du knicken, aber
das ist natürlich in Ordnung, ja, da kannst du dich nicht beschweren, ja, das ist normal,
dass die meisten Meetings, die man mietet, eigentlich am Ende ähnlich sind zu, man hat
nicht gemietet, ist auch normal, ja, bei Heise gab es einen Artikel zu viel Meetings, ja,
hab ich gelesen, bei Golem war das, glaub ich, oder, hab ich gelesen, ist ja auch so, es
wird deutlich zu viel gemietet, Toaster, danke für den Sub, ja, siehste, verstehe ich auch
nicht, die Leute müssen doch mal gucken, wie kommt es denn dazu, ich verstehe den Sinn
nicht, warum nimmt man denn, wenn man explizit Projektmanager-Manager-Positionen und sowas
hat, warum lässt man denn dann nicht die Leute, die dafür da sind, den Kram planen,
dafür hat man noch Projektmanager, ich bin Techniker geworden, weil ich keine Projekte
planen will, dass man da dran beteiligt ist, ja, oder auch mal sein Senf zu irgendeiner
Planung oder irgendeinem Ablauf gibt, oder vielleicht auch mal sagt, ja, am besten passt
es, wenn wir Samstag, die Wartung, irgendwie sowas, da sag ich ja gar nichts gegen, ja,
das ist ja normal, aber übergreifende Koordinierungs-Sachen, gar nicht, das ist überhaupt, das sag ich
mittlerweile auch, ich sehte das jetzt nicht ein, sich zu koordinieren, wir haben Architekten
dafür, wir haben Projektmanager dafür, wir haben Teamleiter, Abteilungsleiter, sonstige
Sachen für, die sind genau dafür da, ich sehs nicht ein, dass man im Endeffekt alles
machen muss und im Endeffekt dann auch alles irgendwie Anschluss kriegt, ja, man muss,
man muss direkt sagen, nö gibts nicht, weil ansonsten laden sie immer mehr bei einem
App, glaub mir, damit kann ich mich, damit kann ich mich durchaus, Zinglor, ich screenshotte
dich mal kurz, diese Chat-Nachrichten muss ich am Montag mal unserem Zertifikatsmanagement
schicken, weil die haben im Endeffekt einfach nur zur Beruhigung, dass die wissen, das ist
nicht nur bei uns so, dabei wisst ihr, was ich nicht verstehe, warum gibts bei Zertifikaten
so viele Probleme, normalerweise ist es doch so, rein theoretisch jetzt mal gesehen, wenn
ich, wenn ich ein Zertifikat ausstelle, dann weiß ich, oder wenn ich ein Zertifikat beantrage,
dann weiß ich, zum Zeitpunkt, wenn ich dieses Zertifikat bekomme, schon wann es abläuft,
also eigentlich ist das mitbekommen, wann ein Zertifikat abläuft, müsste total easy
sein, ich weiß nicht, warum wir uns das so schwer tun und ich weiß auch nicht, warum
sich Gott und die Welt damit so schwer tut und ich weiß auch nicht, warum sich monitorigen
Sachen damit so schwer tun, ich versteh das nicht und wir haben explizit ein komplettes
Team, es sind nur 3 Leute oder so, die sich um Zertifikatshandling kümmern sollen und
trotzdem fällt das teilweise 2 Wochen vorher auf, wenn überhaupt, wenn überhaupt, manchmal
auch nur gar nicht oder am gleichen Tag oder so, ja wir haben jetzt glücklicherweise zum
größten Teil Let's Encrypt, ja, also naja zum größten Teil ist übertrieben, wir haben
jetzt zu einem, sagen wir nicht unerheblichen Teil Let's Encrypt, zum größten Teil würde
ich nicht sagen, ich hab jetzt intern zum ersten Mal bei uns, also wir haben ja für
unsere Cloud-Resource und sowas haben wir schon jede Menge Let's Encrypt, aber ich
hab jetzt zum ersten Mal die letzten 2 Wochen intern Let's Encrypt verwendet bei uns für
einen Legacy-Dienst, der nicht SSL-fähig ist, wollt ihr mal raten, was das ist, Chet, was
meint ihr, was könnte das sein, ein Legacy-Dienst, der nicht SSL, der selbst nicht SSL bzw.
HTTLS, HTTPS-fähig ist, was könnte das sein, Online-Banking, Samba-Server, Mail, Drucker,
Nodes, Nodes ist gar nichts, na, wobei, nein, nein, es ist auch keine AS400, ja, also, Ampelschrunk,
nein, ihr könnt es eigentlich nicht wissen, aber ihr hättet eine Sache vermuten können,
wo ich dann gesagt hätte, ist es richtig, ja, es ist eine uralt Java-Anwendung, wo der
Typ, und das ist jetzt kein Scherz, der Typ, der das programmiert hat, ist in Rente schon,
der ist nicht mehr da, und wisst ihr, was ich mitbekommen hab, auch kein Witz jetzt,
die haben bei einer Störung mit diesem Service tatsächlich den Typ in Rente angerufen, das
hat ihn auch nicht gestört, ich wär wahrscheinlich übelst abgefuckt, ich würd jemand in der
Rente anrufen, das hat ihn auch gar nicht gestört, der hat das denen dann alles erklärt,
ja, zumindest das Ding ist so Ultra-Legacy, das ist schon Fossil, das kann man nicht Legacy
nennen, ja, so, zumindest unsere Programmierer-Dudes, hat er sich sicher bezahlen lassen, wahrscheinlich,
wobei, ganz ehrlich, vielleicht auch nicht, weil, vielleicht kennt ihr das von den Unternehmen,
wo ihr arbeitet, aber jedes Unternehmen erzählt, sie sind die geilsten und die besten und führend
und sonst was, das macht wahrscheinlich das Unternehmen, wo ihr seid, auch, aber gerade
im Finanzdienstleistungssektor ist das nochmal ausgeprägter, also die huldigen sich 24-7
selbst, dass sie die geilsten überhaupt sind und viele bei uns, hab ich zumindest den Eindruck,
die fallen da drauf rein, also, die glauben das dann irgendwann selbst und dementsprechend
kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es Leute gibt, die Sachen freiwillig umsonst machen,
weil das ja der guten Sache irgendwie hilft, ja, die denken wirklich, wir sind die guten,
ja, also es ist natürlich unglaublich wichtig, dass man irgendeine Oma noch eine Lebensversicherung
verkauft oder so, ja, das muss unbedingt sein, oder sonst was macht, keine Ahnung, was die
genau treiben, ich weiß nicht, ich bezweifle immer, dass wir wirklich die guten sind, letztendlich
ist es mir aber auch egal, weil solange die mein Gehalt pünktlich überweisen, juckt
mich nicht, aber lustig, also, naja, naja, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wo ich stehen geblieben
bin, ist auch egal, ja, achso, Let's Encrypt, genau, und da haben wir ein uralt, Alter, was
habe ich wieder am Hals, äh, ein uralt, ähm, Legacy-Java-Dienst gehabt, der jetzt, haltet
es euch fest, aus der Cloud heraus angesprochen werden soll und er kann kein HTTPS bzw. er
kann kein TLS, was habe ich gemacht, ich habe ein Cuddy-Server genommen, da, den haben wir
ja auch schon ein paar Mal im Stream verwendet, hab mir von den DNS-Leuten API-Zugang für
den Azure-DNS geben lassen, das ist übrigens, Azure-DNS ist auch Paint-in-DS, wir haben
ja Cloudflare schon mal benutzt im Stream, das heißt, habt ihr ja vielleicht, wenn ihr
dabei wart, gesehen, Cloudflare ist super easy, Cloudflare, trägst du dein API-Key ein, stellst
noch ein, wer was ändern darf und gut ist, in Azure brauchst du fünf verschiedene Credentials,
Secrets-ID, Secrets, Tenant-ID, Project-ID, was auch immer, du brauchst tausend Sachen,
dass es in Azure überhaupt funktioniert, ähm, zumindest kann der jetzt Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate
abrufen und er proxied im Endeffekt auf diesen Legacy-Java-Service und das ist der erste
richtig automatisierte Let's Encrypt, nennen wir es mal, äh, ja, Proxy, den wir intern
bei uns überhaupt haben und ich hoffe, dadurch, dass ich das jetzt gemacht hab und dadurch,
dass wir jetzt auch Zugangsdaten und alles haben, dadurch, dass jetzt, ich seh' jetzt
mal, das Eis gebrochen ist, ja, sowas intern zu machen, wir hatten ja ein Zertifikate-Team-Leute,
die immer noch erzählen, dass, ähm, echte Zertifikate vertrauenswürdiger sind, wenn
man da Geld für bezahlt, also interessiert das irgendjemand, der draußen die Webseiten
verwendet, ob wir da für Geld bezahlt haben oder nicht, dem geht's drum, dass in seinem
Browser ein Häkchen ist, alles andere ist hier noch voll, also, seriously, meint ihr
irgendjemand ernsthaft guckt sich das an von irgendwelchen Endkunden im Leben nicht, das
ist dem, das geht ihnen, die wissen nicht mehr, dass das existiert, ja gut, das war
wahrscheinlich, die wollten wahrscheinlich ihre eigene Arbeit irgendwie da schützen
oder sowas, keine Ahnung, ähm, zumindest, ich hoffe, dadurch, dass wir jetzt intern
Let's Encrypt haben an dieser Einstelle, dass wir nicht nur bei uns im Cloud-Service, sondern
auch intern immer mehr Let's Encrypt einsetzen können.
So, hab ich irgendwas vergessen?
Hänge mit dran, schreibt Ed Wupplos dabei, wenn ihr was, wenn ich was übersehe, dass
ich seh, äh, ja, gibt es, es gibt ein, oh, wie heißt das, was rausgekommen ist, also
wir haben eine Retrospektive, eine Root Cause Analyse, Leute, jetzt weiß eine Root Cause,
wir haben eine Root Cause Analyse, es gibt ein Dokument, eine Root Cause Analyse, da
steht das drinnen, da steht auch drin, was ich gesagt hab, mit Ausfall, Root Cause Analyse,
das ist bestimmt auch irgendwie sowas, da gibt es jetzt bestimmt auch sowas, ja, ja,
das ist auch so irgendein Management Speak, gibt, also gibt's, ja, Wurzelursache Analyse,
genau, quasi die Art Wurzel Behandlung, eigentlich die Wurzelbehandlung, ja, wenn man das so will,
also, naja, Wurzelbehandlung trifft sich so genau, aber ich fände eigentlich cool, wenn
man das mit Wurzelbehandlung übersetzt, das muss ich mal versuchen, irgendwie zu etablieren,
sowas geht ja relativ gut, wenn man öfters bei solchen Sachen dabei ist und sagt immer
mal ab und zu so, naja, willkommen hier alle, Wurzelbehandlung, das ist glaube ich was,
das finden die Leute auch witzig, vielleicht kriege ich das irgendwie etabliert, dass das
so unter, äh, quasi so, so, so spaßeshalber unter Wurzelbehandlung läuft, das ist finde
ich eigentlich ganz gut, ist das Zertifikat von der Startseite, ja, das ist nicht nur
das Zertifikat von der Startseite, das ist, äh, quasi das Zertifikat für sehr viele
externe Services, also es ist nicht nur die Startseite, es wird, also, wie gesagt, sollte
das mit dem Zertifikat nicht funktionieren, dann wisst ihr wahrscheinlich am, also wenn,
auf heise irgendwann so Dienstag 18 Uhr eine Meldung kommt, dass eine große, äh, deutschsprachige
oder Frankfurter Bank, dass die weit, äh, Ausfälle im großen Stil hat, oder zumindest
Zertifikatswarnung, dann wisst ihr was Sache ist.
Genau, das schicke ich Ihnen dann.
Achso, ich dachte du bezahlst auch weniger Steuern.
Nee, aber das ist natürlich in Ordnung, da kannst du nichts sagen, wobei man natürlich
sagen muss, äh, wenn das immer im Monat, ist natürlich die Frage, mal 12, mal 13, mal 14,
aber trotzdem, ist auch, auch mal 12, mal 12 in Ordnung, da sind ja dann, das kriegst
in dem Jahr, 40.000 Euro quasi, äh, überwiesen, das ist schon, das ist schon okay, man, mehr,
mehr darf's immer sein, ne, es wird keiner sagen, Leute, wenn der Chef heute zu euch
kommt und sagt, hier, ihr bekommt mehr Geld, wird ja kaum einer sagen, ach nee, das brauche
ich eigentlich nicht, gebt das mal jemand, gebt das mal lieber jemand anderem, wobei
es ja meistens dann nicht jemand anderem gegeben wird, sondern einfach nichts passiert.
Jasper, danke für den Sub, Artzi und Mr.
Bangle, huge subscriptions hier, Interview mit dem, das hab ich heute Morgen geguckt, das
fand ich nicht gut, fand ich irgendwie langweilig.
Das hab ich auch schon gesehen, wobei ich das tatsächlich freiwillig mache, also ich
hab schon öfters mal, aber nur mit Leuten, mit denen ich mich gut verstehe, ich hab schon
öfters mal, während wir Teams, Teams-Besprechungen gemacht haben, hab ich schon gesagt, hier
soll ich mal Desktop sharen oder manche Leute, im Prinzip sind es eigentlich nur drei Leute,
mit denen ich das öfters mach, ja, weil ich mich mit denen ziemlich gut verstehe, auf
der Arbeit mit den, mit irgendwelchen Random-Dudes-Budgets auch nicht mal, da kommt es öfters vor, dass
wir in irgendwelchen Team-Calls sitzen und dann entweder ich oder der andere sagt, Rickroll
kommt jetzt, ja ja, ist mir schon klar, und der andere sagt, ich share mal kurz, ich share
mal kurz Desktop, lass mal zusammen gucken, das kommt öfters vor, ja, aber wie gesagt,
nur mit zwei, drei Leuten, mit denen ich, mit drei, eigentlich sind es ziemlich genau
drei Leute, mit denen ich mich gut verstehe, den Felix kennt ihr, Felix mach ich sowas
auch, den Felix hab ich schon mal irgendwann im Gamescom-Video aufgenommen, vor Jahren,
mit dem war ich da zusammen auf der Gamescom, aber ansonsten, mit den meisten nicht, die
meisten Leute gehen wir eh auf den Keks, die meisten Radiosignale sagt, die meisten Planer,
die ich kenne, sind total verplant, das macht ja nichts, solange sie sich nicht verplanen
bei irgendwelchen Projekten, aber viele Planer von uns haben halt, haben es halt richtig krass
drauf, irgendwelche tollen Sprüche zu bringen und dann klappt es nicht, wobei wir einen
haben, da muss man echt sagen, da kann man sich auch darüber streiten, ob das immer
toll ist, was da rauskommt, aber, warte mal Leute, ich muss was trinken, ja, also wir
haben einen Planer, bei uns, der, finde ich, der macht das nicht schlecht, der hat zwar
auch die krassesten Sprüche drauf überhaupt, der hat zum Beispiel mal eine Präsentation
gehalten, als wir, ich glaube, als irgendwelche Standorte verlagert wurden, als man, genau,
das war als sie umgezogen, das ist schon Jahre her, als von einem Rechenzentrum, also eines
der Rechenzentren in ein anderes Rechenzentrum umgezogen wurde und da hat er gesagt, also
was ja in Deutschland immer beliebt ist, sind Fußball und Autovergleiche und da hat er
in einem, und da hat er es tatsächlich nicht schlecht geplant, muss man sagen, aber da
hat immer richtig krasse Sprüche drauf, der Typ, der hat da eine Präsentation gehalten
und hat dann so ein, eine Auto, keine Ahnung, Konstruktions, Fließband gezeigt, ihr wisst
ja, diese Präsentation haben wir mit der eigentlichen Sache, die gemacht wird, relativ
wenig zu tun und dann hat er gesagt, wir haben mehrere Produktionsstraßen aufgebaut, damit
wir Systeme parallel zur Verfügung stellen können und da habe ich gesagt, das klingt
super krass, im Endeffekt, wurde da ganz normal Server eingebaut, Linux installiert, Zeug
drauf kopiert und sonst was, aber er hat halt gesagt, wir haben mehrere Produktionsstraßen
erstellt oder sowas und da haben sich alle gedacht, boah, Alter, sind die krass, was
die alles gemacht haben, dabei war eigentlich gar nichts, aber das hat er gut verkauft,
mehrere Produktionsstraßen, da erinnere ich mich heute noch dran und ich bin gedacht,
was zum Teufel ist los, aber da hat es nicht schlecht geplant, muss man sagen, der labert
nicht nur, der kann das auch, einer der wenigen, die wir haben, die auch planen können.
Ja, das ist auch immer geil, das ist auch immer geil, wenn die Leute, die irgendwann
mal das Meeting einberufen haben, selber nicht mehr zu den Meetings kommen, sowas haben
wir auch, kennt ihr das Leute, irgendein Typ hat mal vor einem Jahr oder so einen Weekly
Meeting anberaumt und dann war er irgendwie drei, viermal da und seitdem sagt er entweder
immer, ich habe leider einen Paralleltermin und kann nicht oder kommt einfach gar nicht
mehr, das ist immer geil, aber da gehe ich dann einfach nicht mehr hin, sinnlose Meetings,
wenn die absehbar, dass sie sinnlos sind, gehe ich da mittlerweile gar nicht mehr hin.
Nice, Blue Falcon, so muss das sein, hast du die Ausbildung schon fertig oder hast du
angefangen?
Die Leute checken nicht, wie Zertifikate funktionieren, das ist richtig und ich bin der Meinung,
man muss ja gar nicht mal im Detail checken, ja, also ganz genau, was weiß ich, es muss
keiner wissen, was es für verschiedene Typen gibt, auf was ich jetzt 1.024, 2.048, 4.096
Bit bezieht, ein bisschen den Unterschied zwischen Private und Public Key, ok, sollte
man wissen und man sollte halt die Basics wissen, man sollte zum Beispiel wissen, ok,
Zertifikat, Gültigkeitsdatum, man sollte wissen, ok, Trust Store beziehungsweise CA
und mehr oder weniger reicht das eigentlich schon, so krasse Kenner, also man muss jetzt
nicht RSA selbst programmieren können oder so, aber das fehlt trotzdem bei vielen, du
bist im August mit dem ersten Jahr fertig, nice, ja, ist echt so, damit kann man, ich
weiß, wie gesagt, es scheitert nicht daran, dass es keine Tools gibt, das zu machen, also
an den Tools scheitert es bei größeren Unternehmen selten, wer nutzt denn noch Nodes, Boomer,
wir haben immer noch ein Nodeserver, wisst ihr auch warum wir noch ein Nodeserver haben,
übrigens, zu geil, das muss ich euch jetzt noch erzählen, bevor wir anfangen Videos
zu gucken, Nodeserver, wir haben ja die Umstellung auf Exchange und Outlook, so wie ziemlich
99% aller anderen Firmen, mittlerweile ja auch haben, die ist bei uns noch gar nicht
so lange her, haben wir mal 4-5 Jahre oder so, davor war das Nodes und ich habe mich
ja immer bei Videos früher auch öfters über Nodes aufgeregt, und in der Umstellungsphase,
vor noch gar nicht allzu langer Zeit, lief das so, wenn ein neuer Mitarbeiter angefangen
hat, der hat eigentlich kein Nodes-Account mehr gebraucht, aber einfach einen Outlook-Account
anlegen konnte man nicht, also, ich weiß das noch, das war nämlich jemand der mich
ein bisschen vertreten sollte, der angefangen hat und ich habe mich auch die ersten paar
Wochen dann darum gekümmert, dass der halt alles bekommt, und dann hat mir allen Ernstes
einer von unseren In-Dienst Active Directory Leuten gezeigt wie das funktioniert, also
wenn du einen neuen Benutzer angelegt hast, dann musstest du ihn nicht nur am Active Directory
anlegen, du musstest ihn, also Ziel war, der neue Benutzer soll per Outlook Mails bekommen
können, also was musste man machen zu diesem Zeitpunkt, man musste den neuen Benutzer nicht
etwa ein Outlook anlegen und gut wäre, nein nein das hat nicht funktioniert, man musste
den neuen Benutzer in Nodes anlegen und anschließend das Nodes-Account nach Outlook migrieren,
nur so hat es funktioniert, nur so, das ging nicht anders, da habe ich echt den Glauben
an die Business Enterprise Software weiter verloren, das ging nicht anders, du musstest
ihn anlegen in Nodes und musstest ihn dann migrieren auf Outlook, anders hat es nicht
funktioniert, oh man, ist schon geil, die Business Enterprise Welt ist halt so ganz
anders als das, was man von daheim bzw. aus kleineren Unternehmen, die Business Enterprise
Welt ist kompliziert und wir, ja, CaptainPeng, Dankeschön für den Sub, Cute Chat, ja eindeutig
weeps in hier, danke für den Sub, nö ist doch nicht, ist es nicht, es ist überhaupt
nicht ungewöhnlich, aber dass wir jetzt endlich intern einen haben, der letztes Encrypt verwendet
ist gut, das haben wir nämlich vorher nicht, ja, Caelor, ich hab's gesehen, ja, Felix hat
mir erzählt, dass 2010 oder so, das ist schon ganz lange her, da war er noch, da war er
glaube ich noch Azubi damals, dass er mal bei einem Meeting dabei war, also wir waren ja
beide Azubis beim Provider und da hat er erzählt, dass er mal bei einem Meeting dabei war, eines
Kunden des Providers von damals und da muss wirklich allen Ernstes irgendein deillusionierter
Manager Typ gesagt haben, als es darum ging irgendwie Suche oder sonst was, haben die
wohl allen Ernstes behauptet, dann kaufen wir halt Google, ich mein hey, 2010 war Google
sicherlich nicht so viel wert wie heute, aber dass irgendein 0815 Frankfurter Klitsche Google
hätte kaufen können, da hab ich so meine Zweifel und da denk ich mir auch immer, was
für Leute sitzen da, ich mein, ich bin kein bisschen Stonksmanager, aber sind euch die
größten Verhältnisse nicht klar, so nach dem Motto Google furzt und der Laden ist weg,
das ist nicht umgedreht und gerade weil du das sagst, ja, ich kenn das, ich hab das an
vielen Stellen schon gesehen, dass die Leute oder das Unternehmen, oder wie soll man sagen,
denken ja nicht, also das quasi die, wie heißt das, das und das, wie heißt das nicht, Mindset,
wie nennt man das denn, so quasi die, so dieses Selbstsicht der Unternehmen und das auch so
quasi das, was intern als Selbstsicht verkauft wird, Corporate, Strategy, Ident, was auch
immer, ja, Lightbuild, sowas in der Richtung, genau, was da verkauft wird, dass das oftmals
nicht so viel mit der Realität zu tun hat. Ich kanns aber insofern verstehen, weil man
darf nicht vergessen, viele Leute sind dafür glaube ich anfällig und die machen tatsächlich
dann auch Sachen umsonst oder gehen Samstags arbeiten, was auch immer, weil das ja der
guten Sache hilft, also, guckt mal, es ist doch egal wo, jetzt mal ganz groß den Bogen
zu spannen, dass man sieht, dass das auf allen Skalen so ist, wo Kriege angefangen wurden
die letzten Jahre über, es ist egal ob die Russen, es ist egal ob die Amis im Nahen Osten,
guckt euch mal den Namen dieser Operationen an, das hieß immer irgendwas mit Freedom
und das funktioniert, warum heißt das Scheiß irgendwas mit Freedom, ich mein ich wüsste
nicht, dass irgendwie wir schießen mit Panzer die Häuser kaputt, die Häuser kaputten die
Leute ab, dass das was mit Freedom zu tun hat, ich glaube auch nicht, dass irgendwie
besonders viele Panzer schon mal Freedom gebracht haben, aber das heißt alles was mit Freedom,
warum heißt das so, das lässt sich einfach besser verkaufen, wenn der Scheiß Freedom
heißt und so ist das auch, wenn man in Unternehmen verkauft, man selbst ist die guten und wir
selbst sind die besten und der Marktführer und was es nicht noch alles gibt, das ist
da auch so, die Leute die haben es irgendwann verinnerlicht und stehen dann mehr dahinter,
weil sie denken oder sich einreden können, ja für die gute Sache hier, was ja Blödsinn
ist, letztendlich geht es darum entweder um den Aktienkurs oder sei es nur, weil der
Chef neuerdings in Welt anfliegen will oder sonst was, das ist natürlich auch geil, die
Rentner auf 450 Euro Basis, haben wir uns die Battlefield Spielerzahlen angesehen, nee
die sind aber besser geworden mittlerweile, schaut mal, seit dem letzten Patch spielen
wir kurz, also es haben jetzt die letzte Woche haben tatsächlich wieder ein paar mehr gespielt,
die letzte Woche, guck mal, seit dem Patch hier, der all ganz groß angekündigt wurde
4.0 ist es ein bisschen hochgegangen, aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass ich es nur
Tempo gehe, mal ganz einfach abgesehen ist es halt immer noch lächerlich wenig.
Ja das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil umso konservativer bzw. umso traditioneller könnte
man das ganze ja auch nennen, eine Branche ist, umso weniger Bock haben wirklich kreative
Leute oder agile, kreative Leute haben ja selten Bock darauf, sich bürokratischen Hindernissen
zu stellen, deswegen hast du ja auch, deswegen hast du nur abgedrehte und gestörte Leute,
umso schwieriger es ist, vermute ich zumindest, das ist ein Rickroll Video 100 pro, ja irgendwie
so war klar.
Also dass man mehr Geld bekommen kann, dass man steuerlich weniger rausbekommt, halte
ich für ein Gerücht, es muss halt schon wirklich ganz doofe Breakpoints treffen, es ist ja
nicht so, dass du jetzt, keine Ahnung, 30% Steuern bezahlst und bekommst einen Euro mehr
und bezahlst halt 40% Steuern, das ist ja, das ist ja gestaffelt, ja, also das geht dann
auch teilweise nur um halbe Prozent und sonst was, also das musst du erstmal hinkriegen.
Ich bezweifle nicht, dass es möglich ist, aber es ist doch recht, da muss schon echt
das blöd treffen, da müsstest du dann irgendwie nur 10 Euro mehr bekommen und genau über
irgendwie diesen halben Prozentpunkt Breakpoint drüber kommen oder so, normalerweise bekommst
du ja, wenn du mehr bekommst, ein bisschen mehr als 5 Euro, das heißt du sollst am Ende
immer mehr raus haben.
Ist das bei euch auch so, dass ihr immer noch nach Scrum arbeiten durchgehend im Sprint
seid?
Bei uns ist das anders, gut, ich meine ich bin jetzt ja auch in keinem Entwicklerteam
in dem Sinn, also ich bin ja nicht in der Softwareentwicklung, ich weiß gar nicht wie
meine Abteilung heißt, wenn ich ehrlich bin, ich glaube irgendwas mit Infrastruktur, keine
Ahnung, ich glaube Infrastruktur und Services oder irgendwie so heißen wir, ach keine Ahnung,
was auch immer, bei uns ist das nicht so, aber ich weiß das von manchen Entwicklerteams,
bei uns ist das noch schlimmer, die sagen sie arbeiten nach Scrum, machen sie aber gar
nicht, das einzige was die an Scrum machen ist, die stehen einmal täglich im Kreis mit
10 Leuten und labern ein bisschen und sagen wir haben ein krasses Daily Standup gemacht,
der Rest davon machen die gar nicht, ach so, also wer das erwartet ist eh komplett realitätsfern,
du kannst nichts 8 Stunden am Tag konzentriert machen, du kannst, um es jetzt mal übertrieben
zu sagen, du kannst noch nicht mal 8 Stunden am Tag konzentriert kacken, ohne dass dir
der Bob es weh tut, also du kannst fast nichts, egal was es ist, 8 Stunden am Stück effizient
machen, egal, du kannst nicht 8 Stunden effizient sitzen mal alleine, du kannst nichts, du kannst
noch nicht mal 8 Stunden am Stück effizient schlafen, du kannst fast nichts 8 Stunden wirklich
am Stück effizient machen, das geht nicht, so und natürlich Sachen wo man sein Hirn
dazu braucht, erst recht nicht und selbst 4 bis 5 Stunden ist glaube ich sogar schon
ein bisschen hoch angesetzt, also ich persönlich würde mal drauf tippen, Sachen wo man wirklich
mal angenommen, angenommen die Voraussetzungen sind da, also man hat seine Ruhe, man ist
nicht in einem Großraumbüro, geh mal von aus und selbst spielen 8 Stunden am Stück
kannst du nicht effizient, selbst wenn die Voraussetzungen da sind und du auch ein Problem
hast was ein bisschen dein Hirn fordert, 2-3 Stunden am Tag höchstens, danach kommt qualitativ
nichts mehr so gutes raus wie am Anfang, das dauert aber eine halbe Stunde bis du dich
ungefähr eingedingst hast, aber danach 2 Stunden fokussiert am Stück dann hast du schon
viel gemacht, du machst diese 2 Stunden fokussiert wahrscheinlich mehr als die nächsten 3 Stunden
selbst wenn du 3 sitzen bleibst, tja das ist eine gute Frage, wahrscheinlich weil die meisten
Leute ganz froh sind wenn sie sagen können ich habe heute gemietet keine Ahnung, der
Chuck danke für den Sub, kann ich mir vorstellen, oh ja WLAN Zugang, MonkaS, so ich glaube wir
haben den Chat fast durch, ja kann jeder machen wie er will, ich finde das ist eigentlich
auch die beste Regel ganz ehrlich, ich finde mehr deutsche Unternehmen gerade auch im IT
Sektor sollten da hingehen, du musst, wenn du das erledigt hast was du erledigen sollst
ist ok, scheiß drauf ob du 8 Stunden Präsenz fakest oder nicht, also was ich gerne habe
ist mal so 1-2 kurze Dailies am Tag, das sind die besten Tage, hast du zwischendurch kannst
du was Foto angehen, hast du morgens mal irgendeinen Daily, mittags mal irgendeinen Daily das
ist ok und du kannst im Zweifelsfall dich immer noch rausgehen mit ah Leute ich muss
gleich zum Daily aber ansonsten will ich meine Ruhe, mach dein Job dir eigentlich Bock und
willst du das genauso einfach weitermachen, also das muss man trennen voneinander, mach
dir dein Job eigentlich Bock ja aber es hat zunehmend Elemente die ich denke die gar
nicht wirklich zu meinem Job gehören bzw. auch gehören sollten, die ganzen Sachen von
Organisationen sind die ich heute auch im Laufe des Streams schon angesprochen habe,
die mir keinen Bock machen und die mir auch auf den Keks gehen und wo wir uns denke ich
dort wo ich bin auch nicht in die richtige Richtung bewegen, willst du es genauso weitermachen
da kann ich sagen ja weil ich arbeite nur vier Tage die Woche und ich habe weniger eine
soll ich sagen persönliche Bindung zu meinem Arbeitgeber als ich Bindung habe zu den Leuten
mit denen ich zusammen arbeite also wenn mich am Samstag jemand anruft und sagt Max Hilfe
XY ist kaputt kannst du mal gucken, dann gucke ich nicht weil ich denke oh ja wir sind das
geilste Unternehmen auf der Welt ich muss dafür sorgen dass es weiter funktioniert
sondern ich denke mir ok der Kollege der da gerade vor Ort sitzt hat Probleme dem helfe
ich also mir ist quasi die Auswirkungen vor dem Unternehmen sind mir eigentlich fast egal
mir geht es darum dass ich demjenigen helfe den ich kenne und persönlich mich mit dem
gut verstehe falls man versteht was ich meine also so und allein schon aus dem Grund weil
ich nur vier tage die woche arbeite man sich insgesamt jetzt auch nicht sagen das das ist
jetzt nicht vergleichbar mit ich mache jetzt acht stunden müllabfuhr also das ist körperlich
auch nicht so super super belastung so und nachdem ich bei vier tagen die woche noch
genug zeit hat mein eigenes zeug zu machen plus bezahlung auch ganz ok ist mein mehr
geht natürlich immer würde ich auch so weitermachen weil ich habe aktuell finde ich eigentlich
eine ganz gute mischung aus geld verdienen plus die meiste zeit freizeit technisch dass
ich machen kann was ich will es ist vielleicht nicht ganz 50 50 aber es ist aber mal so 60
40 also ich kann ich kann 40 prozent meiner zeit machen was ich will das ist doch also
ich rede das nicht von der arbeitszeit sondern von meiner zeit insgesamt das ist doch in
ordnung ja also es gibt es gibt eine sache die instant dazu führen könnte dass ich das
nicht mehr mache das ist wenn jetzt einer auf der arbeit sagt hier max vier tage die
woche wieder nach frankfurt fahren dann bin ich weg das mache ich nicht also wenn man
sich da nicht irgendwie anders ein des mal das mache ich nicht ich werde nicht mehr vier
tage die woche nach frankfurt fahren definitiv nicht dann so ich mir eine home office stelle
oder irgendwas anderes das mache ich auf gar keinen fall das aber auch das einzige was
mir was mir so einfallen würde jetzt ansonsten wenn ich ok was ist das ist riesen thema da
können wir das können wir jetzt nicht aufmachen das fass so fertig wir haben es geschafft
leute jetzt gucken wir uns jetzt gucken wir uns ein paar videos an ich habe jetzt genug
geschwätzt ich habe jetzt eine stunde 15 durchgehend gelabert über irgendwelches zeug
müssen wir jetzt mal etwas angucken was haben wir hier battlefield 2 ok wir lassen uns eine
runde leute wir lassen uns eine runde level capture bane du wohnst auch in frankfurt naja
nicht wirklich ich wohne daneben aber nicht weit weg also ich brauche ungefähr von bahnhof
zur bahnhof viertel stunde 20 minuten und ich mache es ja mittlerweile so ich fahre nur
noch zum südbahnhof und laufe dann vom südbahnhof morgens in die frankfurter innerstadt da bist
du noch mal so 20 25 minuten und 25 minuten ja unterwegs einfach dass man sich morgen
ein bisschen bewegt hat aber ansonsten also wenn ich wirklich drauf anlege bin ich in
einer halben stunde also da muss der zug extrem pünktlich sein ich muss mich auch sputen
sowohl zum bahnsteig hier als auch zum bahnsteig vom bahnsteig dort also wenn ich mich wirklich
beeile und der zug und so alles pünktlich ist brauche ich eine halbe stunde von hoftor
zu sitz auf der arbeit zu sitz zu ich sitze auf dem stuhl auf der arbeit und ich gehe
aus dem hof daraus und ich finde halbe stunde ist durchaus in ordnung was mit meinem auto
das kriegt mit am montag gefixt also was haben wir hier zu bieten specialist classes data
mein who cares und das leute das muss ich zu machen wenn ich da wenn ich das wenn ich
da zufällig reinguck fange ich jeden stream wieder an mich da drüber aufzuregen muss
weg warum ist prime video so schlecht hätten wir zu bieten ok ist ubuntu 22 best 30 minuten
das gucke ich mir nicht an was ist das eigentlich schon wieder für den titel ubuntu 22 04 ist
wahrscheinlich das gleiche wie ubuntu 21 10 plus mit ein paar geupdaten paketen großartig
wird sich da nichts geändert haben wobei wir uns ja alle einig sind dass man das nicht
ubuntu ausspricht sondern so ist das ok was kommen lasst uns eine kunde level cap jibayn
ubuntu hat noch mehr snap integrieren ok ob das das so viel besser macht habe ich jetzt
so meine zweifel aber eher nicht oder so lassen wir uns bei einer runde level cap jibayn ich
muss jetzt erstmal schnell noch mal sound einstellen die best patch ever und es ist
immer noch kacke yeah was haben die sich eigentlich bei warzone gedacht dass da jetzt irgendwelche
monster am start sind ich finde das passt so überhaupt nicht rein warzone war ja immer
also gerade gerade verdansk das war ja immer noch halbwegs realistisch angehaucht alles
mittlerweile ist das jetzt fantasy oder was ich dachte dass es in zombies ist fantasy na
gut gab es nicht sogar gab es nicht sogar irgendeine nee das war ein black ops in diesem
black ops battle royale gab es irgendeine zombie stadt naja also level cap jibayn uns
ist ja dass das der planke hohen ist dass dieses update 4.0 heißt das würde ja bedeuten
das battlefield irgendwann mal bei 1.0 war das ist die sind jetzt vielleicht bei 0.7
oder so 4.0 wie sich das anhört 100 bug fixes and several quality of life improvements
these include voice chat for your squad ja wohl voice chat jetzt wo keiner mehr da ist
mit dem du spielen kannst ja party an end of round scoreboard end of round scoreboard klapper
klapper updated roster of weapon attachments each behaving differently from before and
over 60 other improvements were also exclude ich dachte ich dachte ich dachte das schlecht
ist braucht das game sicherlich dringend aber das game braucht noch deutlich mehr dringend
und es ist trotzdem nicht mehr zu retten covered some of the highlights include improved destruction
and debris physics the settings in game are now more readable with an updated on and off
switch performances slightly better on pc and consoles a new takedown animation has been
added to the portal mode man sieht doch allein schon daran dass er selbst kein bock auf dieses
game hat dass er quasi trailer footage verwendet obwohl das spiel halbes jahr aus ist der screen
flashes blue when your armor is destroyed doch doch das scoreboard kennt man das achso end
of round scoreboard das habe ich nicht gesehen end of round scoreboard das normales scoreboard
kenne ich ja
tornadoes feature more debris the list of changes goes on die wetter effekte sind das
unsinnigste ever and is constantly being added to as players discover more all of the improvements
come together to make the experience better the core gameplay designer and dice replied
to this list on reddit stating that a lot more is on the way details on the next patch
for 2042 are already surfacing the bolt will be moved to the attack vehicle category while
the mav will move to the transport category aim assist and controller input on the console
is targeted to be redefined and improved but most notably the controversial voice line
the specialist at the end of the each round will be toned down this was confirmed by
one of the battlefield community managers on the bombs they stated that we should angel
does it again come does it expect changes to the style and tone of the voice lines in
a future update now atop all of this prominent data miner temporary i'll shared on twitter
that an additional eight week missions have been added to the game the weekly missions
run until june 16th some fans speculate that season one of the live service may drop around
this time as ea and dice did assure fans that content will arrive in early summer temporary
i'll noted that more specific details might be shared once the may update goes live not
only that but temporary i'll also found references to a major rework of the specialist system
he discovered mentions of the class selection progress and class level the term combat
medics was also used in a new in-game description we know dice plans to rework the specialist
in the future so maybe this is the first sign of that ah amy hennig the game director behind
jack and daxter and the uncharted series has announced that her studio side dance new media
is co-developing a new star wars game with lucasfilm it's billed as a richly cinematic
action adventure game which features an entirely original story you may remember that hennig
worked with visceral games on a single-player star wars game code name that project was
scrapped along with the visceral game studio back in 2016 it's unclear whether or not
this new star wars game may pick up development where the ragtag game left hat eigentlich george
lucas noch irgendwas mit lucas films zu tun ne oder der typ ist weg das hat er verkauft
an disney und und schuss hack division confirmed the rumors that godzilla and king kong will
be coming to call of duty warzone in a cinematic trailer the duo was shown charging at each
other on the caldera map an official playstation blog post accompanied the trailer and it shared
plenty of details about the new content caldera will receive several maps in zombies
hette das gepasst ja aber ich weiß ich meine fortnight hat irgendwie das halbe marvel universe
ist
Hidden Weapons Lab mit close-quarter combat. Season 3, featuring all of this content, launches
on April 27th, while the King Kong vs. Godzilla event won't start until May 11th.
Halo Infinite Season 2 Content goes live on May 3rd. The developers at 343 Industries
have shared a first look at the new Battle Royale-like mode called Last Spartan Standing.
In this new game mode, the entire objective is to survive until the end of the round.
12 Players spawn onto different large-scale maps with a limited loadout.
5 Respawns. Players will have the option to upgrade their weapons with each kill. You win the round by being the last Spartan alive.
Development on a fully fleshed-out Halo Battle Royale is also rumored. Codenamed Tatanka is being co-developed with the Certain Affinity Studio.
This studio primarily consists of...
...Spartan alive. Development on a fully fleshed-out Halo Battle Royale is also rumored. Codenamed Tatanka is being co-developed with the Certain Affinity Studio.
Development on a fully fleshed-out Halo Battle Royale is also rumored. Codenamed Tatanka is being co-developed with the Certain Affinity Studio.
Development on a fully fleshed-out Halo Battle Royale is also rumored.
This studio primarily consists of ex-Bungie developers who worked on previous Halo and Call of Duty content.
Destiny 2's former design director at Bungie, Christopher Barrett, has moved on to the studio's next game.
On Twitter this week, Barrett was asked if any hints towards the new game were hidden as Easter Eggs in Destiny 2.
He replied with yes. Barrett added to the speculation by replying with the word maybe and a moon-shaped smiley face.
A subtle hint to some players that maybe the Easter Egg is hidden on one of Destiny 2's moons.
The players are continuing to frantically search for this Easter Egg about Bungie's mysterious next game.
Sony is reportedly considering a system that would allow game developers to run ads in their games. This would enable them to monetize their titles on PlayStation consoles further.
The procedure would be similar to putting up billboard advertisements featuring real-life ads. The report from Business Insider implies Sony won't...
...enforce the system, but that it would be encouraged for free-to-play games.
The report also shares how players may be rewarding for interacting with these advertisements.
One example is rewarding players with unique items in-game if they watch an entire ad. How ads are depicted would depend on the individual developer.
Strangely, something similar was actually done in Battlefield 2042. An advertisement for Logitech can be found on an...
...in-game website.
In-game billboard on the hourglass map.
Significant updates for the Extraction Royale Hunt Showdown don't come often. In this next patch has players incredibly excited.
Update 1.8.1 will introduce new armed diversions...
...that will come in two variants wielding either a rusted pistol or a lantern. Both variants will be relatively easy to kill, but will create a lot more noise than usual.
Noise can be easily heard by other hunters in the game. Update 1.8.1 will also introduce a new daily quest system. These will be a series of challenges that reward players with blood bonds, money or weapons.
Once unlocked, three quests can be tracked at once.
The new content should be available on the public test version of the game next week.
The customization is incredibly in-depth. Players will have the freedom to unlock dozens of options with in-game cash.
Clothing options vary from firefighter uniforms to fluffy bunny slippers. Players can even adjust the color and material of each clothing item.
In-depth physics changes can be made to the characters as well. You can adjust their muscles, scars and glossiness of their skin.
There will also be in-depth customization options for vehicles, weapons and even your gang basic. The same for a reboot is scheduled to launch on August 23rd.
The Polish studio Megapixel has announced a remake of the 1997 classic title The House of the Dead. This on-rails survival shooter amassed a massive cult following over the years.
The remake will launch on PC, Google, Stadia, Playstation and Xbox on April 28th. It includes new features like two-player co-op, local multiplayer, photo mode and multiple endings.
The game's publisher Forever Entertainment is currently working on a deal to remaster the second House of the Dead game as well.
Before we get to our final story this week, let us know what you thought about Battlefield 2042's latest update 4.0. Has it improved your overall experience? Are you waiting for new content? Let us know in the comments.
Also wenn überhaupt, wenn ich überhaupt mal in Battlefield 2042 wieder reingucken sollte, da muss noch mehr passieren als noch ein neuer Specialist oder noch eine neue Map.
Aber warum?
Games using the D-Pad A and B buttons and the hand crank. In some instances turning the hand crank moves the character on screen.
There are supposedly more games coming in the future through seasonal content drops, but there's very little known about them yet.
Players can pre-order the device.
The price for $179, though it probably won't ship until 2023.
And that wraps it up for today's episode of This Week in Gaming.
As always guys, thank you so much for watching and I'll catch you next time.
But Amazon, I was on Amazon last Saturday and they suggested that I should watch Homeland.
That's a series from 2012 or something.
And I watched the first season.
That's really not bad.
That's one of the most unpredictable series I've watched in the last few years.
But I thought it was bad.
It's also clever how they wrote it.
Sometimes you think, what is it, what isn't, and it's not bad.
That's a really good series until season 5.
I still have four seasons to watch.
After that they'll probably come up with the ideas.
Eight seasons, no idea.
I watched the first season.
The first one was really not bad.
That's from 2012 or something.
It's one of the few things where I thought, hey, the people who thought about the story really thought about it.
Because you also learn things that come back later and where it can't be seen miles ahead.
I think it's good.
I really liked the first season.
Season 8 solid again.
Season 8 is apparently the last one.
I don't know, I watch it until it sucks.
Maybe it's a little lame, but really well done.
What I always like is that you're already used to watching movies or watching series.
And you think, aha, you didn't think about that.
Season 8, the motto, you contradicted yourself, aha, here, look, clear logic.
Back then they said that, now they're doing that.
It has me in the meantime on all corners, because you think, the shit is not really thought out.
But I think they did it really well in Homeland.
I had a few times, I don't spoil now, I had a few times I thought, aha.
Two episodes ago you told that and now you hope we forgot it.
Or that's something else now.
Two episodes after that came the motto, fuck, they didn't forget it.
So I thought it was cool.
I have to say, not bad.
Okay.
Where did we stop?
Where are we at the topic, guys?
Where are we going with this?
That's wonderful, isn't it?
Do you know that?
Can we even watch that on Twitch?
That's Amazon.
Honestly, before I watch the video.
I think Prime, I wanted to say Prime Gaming, luckily we don't have that at the start.
Prime Video, also das, wo Prime Video meiner Meinung nach am allermeisten krank ist.
Wie sage ich das jetzt am besten?
Prime Video ist kein...
Ich muss mal kurz überlegen, wie sage ich das am besten?
Also in Prime Video ist es halt so, wenn du auf Prime Video bist, du findest irgendwie nichts.
Also du musst eigentlich schon vorher wissen, was du gucken willst, dass du was findest.
Das ist quasi ein bisschen, als hätte man Amazon reskinned.
Und hätte dann quasi gesagt, man nimmt den Amazon Shop.
Und anstatt dass man da jetzt Klopapier und Werkzeuge anzeigt, zeigt man Videos an.
Also bei Amazon ist es ja auch so, du gehst auf Amazon und suchst nach was, was du brauchst.
Oder aber du hast Glück und der Amazon Algorithmus weiß schon, was du haben willst.
Also das ist eigentlich das größte Problem an Prime Video.
Das ist auch bei allen anderen Amazon Services so.
Bei Audible ist es mittlerweile ein bisschen besser.
Aber bei dem, wie heißt das andere, diesem Kindle, Kindle-Krempel, diese Kindle-Bibliothek oder was auch immer.
Da ist das auch so, du denkst, das ist alles irgendwie so half-assed Amazon reskinned.
Das trifft es, glaube ich, ganz gut.
Wusstet ihr übrigens, dass Amazon selbst Livestreams hat?
Wusstet ihr, dass Amazon selbst nicht live lebt?
Amazon hat Livestreams, nicht Prime Video.
Amazon live gibt, nein nicht Prime.
Hier, das da.
Amazon hat seriously Livestreams.
Da haben sie irgendwelche mehr oder weniger bekannten Influencer-Leute.
Das ist quasi Teleshopping, wenn du es so willst.
Nur ohne Tele.
Das ist quasi Dauerwerbesendung für Amazon.
Ich wusste gar nicht, da gibt es auch einen Chat dafür und so.
Das habe ich letztens gefunden, zufällig, weil irgendein Channel,
der mich folge, der Smart-Home-Gedöns macht,
der hat gesagt, er streamt jetzt gleich auf Amazon live.
Und dann haben die Leute in die Kommentare geschrieben, was?
Amazon, was, wie? Das gibt es.
Und dann bin ich da mal draufgegangen, das gibt es wirklich.
Na gut, jetzt gucken wir uns mal an, warum Amazon Prime Video so schlecht ist.
Ich weiß nicht, was du gucken willst und suchst verzweifelt auf Netflix.
Aber auch, wenn es doch eigentlich so viele Geheimtipps auf der Plattform gibt.
Also ich muss sagen, Homeland war die erste Empfehlung von Amazon,
wahrscheinlich, weil es random war,
war die einzige Empfehlung bei Amazon bisher,
was sie mir empfohlen haben, was mir gefallen hat.
Ansonsten kriege ich bei Amazon Prime immer irgendwelche B-Movies
oder irgendwie Ultra-Trash-Empfohlen, den ich überhaupt nicht gucken will.
Sobald du anfängst, rumzuscrollen und rumzuklicken,
besteht Netflix nur noch aus Weihnachtsfilmen
und den räudigsten Romkoms unter der Sonne.
Und irgendwann kommt dann der Punkt, an dem du denkst,
okay, okay, dann gucke ich halt auf Prime Video.
Oh Gott, no. Oh Gott, no. Oh Gott, no. No!
No!
Und hier beginnt ein Alptraum ohnegleichen.
Apropos Romkommer, was gibt es denn da so auf Prime?
Komm schon, komm schon.
Das Problem habe ich auch.
Ja, also die Bedienung dieser Seite ist wirklich kompletter Abfuck.
Und wisst ihr, was mich auch mega nervt,
ist, wenn man das auf dem Fernseher anguckt, also Android TV,
jedes Mal, kennt ihr wahrscheinlich auch, jedes Mal, wenn man diese App startet,
muss man auswählen, wer guckt, ob ich gucke oder ob Kinder gucken.
Warum muss ich bei jedem Start der App sagen, ich gucke, es gucken keine Kinder?
Warum gibt es kein Default-Settings zu sagen, hey, es gucken keine Kinder?
Und wenn Kinder gucken, kann ich immer noch einen Button hinmachen.
Das ist so bescheuert.
Yes, okay, klick auf die Kategorie Romantik und, ach so, geil.
Doch, so viele.
Und das war's.
Kennt ihr schon den Martial-Arts-Film, brave Mädchen tun das nicht?
Okay, suche ich mal nach The Office.
Danke für die ganzen Filter, besonders Erscheinungsdatum,
letzter Monat oder letzte zwei Monate.
Ja, Amazon-Filter sind auch, das liegt daran, weil die im Shop auch so kacke sind.
Das ist das, was ich meine, dass das alles, dass diese ganzen Prime-Services
irgendwie ein Amazon Reskin sind, der nicht zu der eigentlichen Anwendung mehr passt.
Die Filter, die Filter bei Amazon sind auch meistens ziemlich sinnlos, ja.
Zum Beispiel habt ihr mal versucht, bei Amazon nach so was Publichem zu sortieren,
wie Lieferdatum?
Gehen wir mal bei Amazon und suchen da jetzt zum Beispiel USB-Stick.
So.
USB-Stick.
Ich möchte sortieren nach ist lieferbar und wann?
Warum geht das nicht?
Nicht, ich will nicht out of stock,
ich will sortieren können nach Lieferdatum.
Warum geht das nicht?
Wenn du eingeloggt bist und Prime-Kunde bist, kannst du wenigstens noch hier oben
Prime auswählen und Prime bedeutet meistens schnellstmögliche Lieferung.
Jetzt ist nicht alles morgen da, das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Es gibt gerade, wenn du Donnerstagsabends oder Freitagsabends Sachen bestellen willst,
dann gibt es die Variante erst nächste Woche oder noch bis Samstag.
Und viele Sachen sind halt erst bis nächste Woche da,
aber manche gibt es auch bis Samstag.
Und du kriegst es nicht gescheit hin, das zu filtern,
außer dass du drüber scrollst und halt guckst, wo steht Prime,
wo steht lieferbar bis Samstag.
Manchmal machst du dann auch Samstag hier direkt, Saturday direkt mit über die Suche.
Ja, es ist beschissen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man, ich meine Amazon macht das nicht just for fun.
Das muss man sehen, weil Amazon gibt sehr viel Geld dafür aus,
zu analysieren, an welcher Stelle des Bestellprozesses
Leute aus dem Bestellvorgang aussteigen.
Also wenn ich jetzt das reinklicke, ja,
und Amazon trackt bestimmt, wie lange brauche ich auf Checkout.
Scroll ich erst die Seite runter, ja.
So nach dem Motto, wenn ich erst die Seite ganz runter scroll,
das heißt, ich weiß nicht, dass der Checkout-Button oben ist.
Dann ist das alles komplett.
Aber irgendwie kriegen sie das nicht gebacken.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht haben sie auch intern festgestellt.
Es ist besser, man zeigt nicht an, wann das Datum da ist,
weil die Leute sonst vielleicht nicht bestellen oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber es ist eklig.
Jeder 0815-Shop kann das.
Amazon kann das nicht?
Da weiß es nach Staffel 1 und 2 ist die logische Konsequenz 4 und dann 7. Chris frage, wie komme ich jetzt zurück zu Prime Video?
Ja, das liegt daran, weil die Suche die normale Amazon-Suche ist und keine Prime Video-Suche, die explizit auf Videometadaten oder so zurückgreift.
Das wird die gleiche Suche sein, die man auch ganz normal über Amazon verwendet und da ist halt random.
Das ist nicht dafür, das ist gemacht, um USB-Sticks zu suchen oder Klopapier zu suchen, aber halt nicht eine Serie in der richtigen Reihenfolge.
Das ist halt affisch, dass das auf Prime Video nicht geht.
Übrigens jetzt mal, Chet, unpopuläre Meinung, ja?
Oder weiß ich nicht, wie ihr das seht, aber die Office-Memes sind ja ganz lustig.
Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich finde die Serie nicht lustig.
Ich habe mir die erste Staffel angekauft, ich habe mir die erste Staffel echt nur, also vor einer Weile gekauft.
Ich, ich weiß nicht, ich, obwohl ich eigentlich in so einem Business-Stonks-Enterprise-Umfeld arbeite,
die US-Serie, nicht die UK-Serie.
Ich weiß nicht, ich fand das jetzt nicht sonderlich gut oder nicht sonderlich lustig.
Fühlt sich wie Stromberg an, naja gut, das liegt halt daran, weil das die deutsche Variante davon ist, aber Stromberg fand ich auch nicht witzig.
Keine Ahnung, ich müsste eigentlich genau die richtige Zielgruppe sein von The Office, aber ich, keine Ahnung, ich finde es ziemlich lustig.
Ja gut, Moment, Moment, man muss ja mal die Prioritäten, man muss ja mal die Prioritäten sehen.
Die Prioritäten sind nicht Prime Video gut zu machen, die Prioritäten sind ins Weltall zu fliegen.
Gehört, operiert eine der größten Streaming-Plattformen überhaupt. Warum ist die Prime Video Benutzeroberfläche so schlecht und was sagt das über das Unternehmen dahinter aus?
Fleabag, Marvelous Ms. Maisel, The Boys, Invincible, et cetera, et cetera, Prime Video hat richtig, richtig gute preisgekrönte Inhalte.
Der Katalog der Streaming-Plattform ist riesig. Amazon gibt jedes Jahr zig Milliarden für...
Geht es dir auch so, dass du Hacker-Filme und Serien nicht anschauen kannst?
Ja, es gibt ja glücklicherweise nicht so viele, es gibt halt immer Sachen, die halt so eingebaut sind, ja.
Das ist eigentlich ein anderer Film, aber da ist halt irgendwie so ein Hacker-Dude dabei, das finde ich halt auch immer ziemlich cringe.
Ich muss sagen, ich fand die erste Staffel, die erste Hälfte, die erste Hälfte der ersten Staffel Mr. Robot ganz gut.
Das war natürlich auch teilweise, wo du dir gedacht hast, okay, die Leute haben sich Mühe gegeben, aber haben es trotzdem nicht so genau verstanden, weil...
Moment, das muss ich euch zeigen. Das ist kein Spoiler, das geht überhaupt nicht um die Story.
Mr. Robot KDE Gnome. Ja, das hier, das hier.
Ich finde es cool, es ist realitätsnäher als 99% des anderen Technikjargons, was da in Filme und Serien verwendet wird, aber es ist schon irgendwie an der Realität ziemlich vorbei.
Weil da hört sich so an, als ist jetzt irgendwie Gnome neuer als KDE oder KDE neuer, also die richtigen Hacker-Mans.
Wenn da eigentlich hätte Elliot sagen müssen nach dem Motto I3WM oder sowas.
Richtig Hacker oder Text Interface Only oder irgendwie sowas, ja.
Aber ich fand die erste Hälfte von Mr. Robot, also die erste Hälfte der ersten Staffel Mr. Robot, fand ich ziemlich gut.
Danach fand ich es nicht mehr so tolle, weil sich im Prinzip nur noch drum gedreht hat, welche Störungen und Drogenabhängigkeiten der Hauptcharakter hat und das Ende fand ich kacke von der ersten Staffel.
Ich fand es so kacke, dass ich nie weiter geguckt habe.
So ist es.
Achja, ich hör nix, Schnapper.
Oh Gott.
Leute, ich trau mich gar nicht mit dem Kram anzugucken, falls es dann rauskommt.
Ich hab da ganz kurze Bedenken, dass das was wird.
Ja, vor der wir übrigens panische Angst haben, diese CI-Matsche, warum sind das alles... Egal, hat rund 426 Millionen Euro gekostet.
Damit ist sie mit Abstand die teuerste...
Ich predikte mal was zu dieser Herr der Ringe Serie.
Und eigentlich ist es mir auch wurscht, ob die dunkelhäutige Zwergenprinzessin oder sowas drinne haben.
Da hat sich ja Twitter wahnsinnig für und gegen und sonst was. Was mir eigentlich wichtig wäre, weil Herr der Ringe ist mein mit Abstand Lieblings-Fantasy-Universum,
dass man versucht zumindest eine Story im Geiste der ursprünglichen Idee zu erzählen.
Also, dass man nicht zwangsläufig aus der Welt was macht, was sie nicht ist. Soll das nach dem Filmspiel nicht davor.
Das spielt lustigerweise zu einer Zeit, wo man relativ viele Freiheiten hat.
Und es ist nicht so, als gäbe es nicht genug Stories, die man ausschmücken könnte ein bisschen.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass man bekannte Charaktere rein aus dem Wiedererkennungszweck einbaut, die wahrscheinlich mit den Vorlagen nicht mehr so viel zu tun haben.
Und dass man aus der Welt was machen wird, was wahrscheinlich nicht im Geiste des Originals ist.
Und deswegen habe ich wirklich Bedenken, was da rauskommt am Ende. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, das wird nichts.
So Wizard, Dankeschön für den Zapp. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, das wird nichts.
Damit ist sie mit Abstand die teuerste Serie aller Zeiten.
Game of Thrones war zum traurigen Schlusspunkt der Serie gerade einmal rund drei Jahre.
Ich glaube, ich habe auch nur die ersten drei Staffeln oder so geguckt.
Ich habe lustigerweise Game of Thrones aufgehört zu gucken. Ich kenne die Bücher nicht, muss ich dazu sagen.
Weder als Heubuch war er noch sonst, weil ich kenne die Vorlage nicht.
Ich habe aufgehört zu gucken, wo sie sich und das habe ich im Nachhinein rausbekommen, weil ich das Wiki gelesen habe dazu.
Ich habe aufgehört zu gucken, wo sie angefangen haben, sich eigene Storys auszudenken.
Es kann sein, dass ich entweder bis Ende Staffel drei oder bis Mitte Staffel vier oder irgendwie so was geguckt habe.
Ich meine, Game of Thrones ist eh schon ultra schleppend in vielen, auch die ersten zwei, drei Staffeln in vielen Bereichen.
Das schleppt sich teilweise wirklich hin.
Auf der anderen Seite ist das das Coole daran, du hast eine gewisse Bindung zu den Charakters in Game of Thrones,
einfach weil du eben nicht von einer Szene zur nächsten kommst.
Das ist auch notwendig, weil es gibt halt auch mega viele.
Allein schon die erste Staffel, Game of Thrones, haben sie 140 Leute oder so am Start gehabt.
So und ich habe genau bis dahin geguckt, wo sie angefangen haben, sich eigenes Zeug auszudenken.
Und ich wusste das zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt nicht.
Ich habe das aber nachher im Wiki gelesen, weil ich dachte, jetzt irgendwie ist das noch schleppend und noch.
Dann hast du irgendwelche komischen Subplots, die nichts mit dem Rest zu tun haben und so was.
Und ja, ich habe dann im Nachhinein rausgekriegt, ja, das ist quasi so Staffel 4 rum, ist das, wo sie angefangen haben,
quasi wo die Geschichte aus den Büchern für manche Charaktere zu Ende war, sich Zusatzdinger auszudenken.
Und das hat man gemerkt und ab da hat es mir auch nicht mehr gefallen.
Und das war eh schon schleppend zwischendurch.
Aber auf der anderen Seite war es wirklich gut gemacht.
Und du hast gemerkt, dass da halt jemand, eine sinnvolle, konsistente, und das ist ja immer das Wichtige,
dass es nicht mehr heute so ist, morgen so, konsistente Welt- und Hintergrundgeschichte hat.
Das war das Gute daran. Und dass sie sich auch wirklich halbwegs genau daran gehalten haben.
Also, aber ich habe nicht weiter geguckt, glaube ich, nach Staffel 3.
Ich glaube, 3,5 Staffel habe ich geguckt. Und dann hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
80 Millionen Euro teuer.
And are you happy with how things ended?
Das ist eh das geilste Interview. Best season ever!
Amazon hat also richtig Geld in die Hand für Prime Video.
Warum ist die Benutzeroberfläche dann so unfassbar schlecht?
Kategorien funktionieren einfach nicht. Harry Potter...
Von der Witcher-Serie müssen wir nicht anfangen.
Ich finde, dass die erste Staffel durchaus, also die Witcher-Serie hatte in der ersten Staffel durchaus ihre Momente.
Ich fand das nicht alles kacke.
Aber...
Ich mein...
Warum macht man... Das ist das, was ich nicht so genau verstehe.
Warum macht man eine Witcher-Serie?
Und...
Das Einzige, was das mit den Vorlagen gemeint hat, ist...
Dass es ein paar Hauptcharaktere gibt, die den gleichen Namen tragen.
Die erste Staffel war okay, ja.
Aber man hat ganz viel Zeug anders gemacht, umgewurstet, weggelassen...
Wo ich mir denke, wieso, ja?
Außerdem war das sehr inkonsistent an vielen Stellen.
Gerade, was sie sich da mit ihrem Rumgezauberer überlegt haben, mal geht das so, mal geht das so, jetzt kann man das nicht, jetzt geht das auf einmal wieder...
Es hat wenig Sinn.
Und ich bin jemand, wenn ich irgendwelche Serien oder Filme gucke...
Wie gesagt, deswegen ist wahrscheinlich Herr der Ringe auch eines meiner Lieblings-Fantasy-Universen.
Ich interessiere mich bei Online-Games beispielsweise null für die Lore oder so.
Aber trotzdem, ich achte irgendwie darauf, dass das irgendwie halbwegs schlüssig in sich ist.
Ich behaupte gar nicht, dass man sich wahnsinnig krass an die Buchvorlage halten muss.
Bei Herr der Ringe haben die auch so viel Zeug weggelassen.
Aber es muss irgendwie schlüssig sein ineinander.
Und das schafft die Witcher-Serie in der ersten Serie nicht.
Ansonsten hat man halt auch vieles weggelassen.
Zweite Staffel habe ich mir nicht mehr angeguckt. Hat mich nicht überzeugt.
Aber ich bin eh nicht der ultrakrasse Serien-Grinder, sodass ich quasi wöchentlich Nachschub brauche.
Also das ist nicht so wild, dass mir das nicht gefallen hat und ich das jetzt nicht weiter gucke.
Also eines der Sachen, die mir im Hinterkopf geblieben sind.
Ich weiß, es gibt ja viele Leute, die fühlen sich wahnsinnig schlau.
Die sagen, ah Max, die Leute verstehen bloß die Zeitsprünge in Season 1 nicht und sowas.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen, okay, es ist nicht der Job, irgendwelcher Wikis zu erklären, wie der Zusammenhang ist.
Sondern sollte der Zuschauer eigentlich sich von sich aus erschließen können.
Aber das ist gar nicht mal das Problem.
Also eines der Sachen, die mir sehr unsinnig aufgestoßen sind, ist, wie random und zur Situation passen so die Magie in der Witcher-Serie funktioniert.
Mal kannst du easy Teleports machen. Easy. Du kannst alleine teleportieren.
Du kannst Teleports machen mit Leuten zusammen, die nicht teleportieren können.
Mal geht das aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht.
Mal geht das nur kurz. Mal geht das lang Strecke. Man weiß es nicht.
Mal dauert das eine Weile. Mal ist das instant.
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ein Beispiel, um nicht so viel zu spoilern und keinen Namen zu nennen.
Es gibt einen Zauberer.
Eigentlich ist es ja kein Zauberer. Egal.
In der ersten Folge sterben Leute.
Das ist glaube ich nicht so viel gespoilert.
Und der ist dabei. Er macht nichts.
Später ist er mit Geralt am Start.
Sie geraten auch in eine gefährliche Situation.
Und er teleportiert sich mit Geralt weg.
Wo man sich fragt, warum hat er denn bitte schön in Folge 1 nicht die wichtigen Leute wegteleportiert, wenn er doch easy teleportieren kann.
Ich bin mir sicher, es gibt irgendwelche Leute, die dann in irgendwelchen Wikis irgendwelche Theorien konstruiert haben, warum das doch so ist.
Aber das kann es nicht sein.
Und das sind so Sachen, wo ich mir denke, das muss euch doch auffallen, wenn ihr sowas zusammen...
Mana Leer, genau. Hey, ich hätte kein Problem damit. Ohne Scheiß.
Ich hätte kein Problem, wenn die sagen, es wird ein Mana Leer.
Wenn sie Mana als Magieressource etabliert hätten in der Welt.
Vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ja. Und das sind halt so Inkonsistenzen, wo ich sage, ja...
Ja, der Hex sagt, genau, ich bin out of Mana, Digga.
Einer sagen muss, das hätte ich gefeiert, hätte er das gesagt.
Mana Leer, Alter. Das ist egal. Das ist nur, weil das woanders auch...
Herr der Ringe ist, glaube ich, das schlechteste Beispiel für irgendwelche Magie-Magic Sachen. Die sind ja da alle ultra vage.
Es gibt ja in Herr der Ringe wenig, wenig wirklich, wie soll man sagen, wenig rumgezauberer, ja.
Und es ergibt aber auch rein aus Charactersicht keinen Sinn.
Warum teleportiert er sich mit jemand, zwei Stunden später, aber davor, wo es quasi um das Vernichten einer ganzen Stadt geht, schafft er es nicht, die Anführer rauszuteleportieren und sowas.
Das ergibt keinen Sinn, es ist egal, ob man das jetzt sagt, Mana, nicht Mana, was auch immer.
Die Erklärung ist eigentlich nicht so sehr, wie die Magie sagt, sondern warum macht er das nicht, wenn er es doch kann.
Und ja, doch, ich weiß, warum er das macht, weil es einfach super convenient ist, dass Geralt jetzt an der einen Stelle auftaucht, wo er auftauchen soll.
Also, keine Ahnung. Dafür hatte die erste Witcher-Serie durchaus ihre guten Momente, ja.
Aber keine Ahnung, ist auch egal. Gucken wir mal weiter.
Wenn wir das Video mal irgendwann durchkriegen, wir müssen mal wissen, warum Prime Video so schlecht ist.
Der Stein der Weisen wird als Drama eingeordnet. Auch auf der Startseite herrscht pures Chaos.
Hier wird mir einfach Random Sherlock Staffel 4 vorgeschlagen.
Wollte ich auch schon immer mal Random mit Staffel 4 anfangen.
All das ist seit jeher einfach Standard auf der Plattform, auf allen Geräten.
Manche Serien gehen beim Weiterschauen auch einfach...
Expanse auch so ein Ding. Ich fand die erste Staffel richtig nice. Ich hab die zweite Staffel bis zur Hälfte geguckt.
Oder was, die dritte Staffel? Ich bin mir gar nicht ganz sicher, ob es die zweite Staffel drin war.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, hä? Was gibt denn das jetzt, wenn es fertig ist? Da hatte ich auch keinen Bock mehr weiter zu gucken.
Auch einfach irgendwo weiter bei The Expanse wurden wir einmal einfach in die fünfte Staffel teleportiert.
Danke, wir haben einen Tech-Raider-Artikel gefunden, der genau dieses Phänomen beschreibt. Vor fast zwei Jahren.
Ja, das ist ja auch nicht neu.
Es gibt verschiedene Erklärungsansätze für dieses Drama. Vorweg, hier beginnt die Spielspiel-
Wie gesagt, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass die ganzen Prime-Services einfach ein Reskin von Amazon sind.
Und das unter der Haube ist das die Amazonsuche.
Suche
Das ist das, was er vorhin erklärt hat. Ich meine es macht es nicht wirklich besser
Aber das wird es unterm Strich sein
Zunächst wurde Prime Video sehr eindeutig als Ableger der Amazon Hauptseite angelegt. Genau das ist es immer noch. Das Streaming Angebot war ursprünglich eher ein zusätzlicher Pluspunkt
um Leute dazu zu...
Alter was ist mit dem seinem Kopf los? Sekunde Leute was
Was geht mit dem seinem Kopf ab?
3Head Alter was ist da los?
3Head Alter was ist da los? Was ist mit dem Dude seinem Kopf?
Das Bild ist nicht richtig oder?
Die haben, die haben das Bild falsch zusammengesetzt. Das ist aber auch ziemlich mies
Ach hier auch
Aber hier nicht doch hier auch
Okay, der hatte, der hat beim scrollen, der hat beim scrollen wahrscheinlich wirklich Screen Tearing gehabt
Ne wobei, ne hat er nicht. Das movet mit, das movet mit. Die Bilder sind einfach kaputt bei Amazon
Ja gut kleine Startup kann sowas schon mal passieren
Was sagst du zum Fall Julien Bam? Da wurde ja gehackt. Was soll ich zu sagen? Wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Keylogger oder so eingefangen
Die Prime-Mitgliedschaft zu holen und so sind die beiden Websites weder visuell noch strukturell sauber getrennt
Richtig das ist genau meine Vermutung. Ja genau
Ne, nicht nach DVDs, nach Klopapier, USB-Sticks, Kaffeemaschinen. Dafür ist die Suche gedacht
Kusswart, die echt? Und wie? Wie wurde dein YouTube-Account-Hackerman?
Das würde mich jetzt interessieren. Was war bei dir ein Einfallstor?
Ja es muss ja kein Keylogger im klassischen Sinn sein. Wahrscheinlich ist das irgendein Root-Kit auf dem Rechner
Dass sie im Endeffekt sowohl Tastendrücke mitschneiden können, aber auch Browser-Sessions oder ja Browser-Sessions zum Beispiel
Ja Browser-Sessions ist was. Oder im Endeffekt gar nicht den Rechner fernsteuern können, weil er ist garantiert noch eingeloggt
Wahrscheinlich Session, ja irgendwie sowas. Was ich nicht glaube ist, dass die Google-Authentifizierung, Anmeldung irgendwie Probleme hat
Session-Cookie, ja das könnte ich mir auch vorstellen. Aber du klaust ja nicht einfach mal den Kram, also da musst du dir auf dem Rechner irgendwas eingefangen haben
Du warst selber schuld, hatte kein 2F angerichtet, meine sekundäre E-Mail wurde geacknet. Achso, ok, ja dann ist es bei dir was anderes
Der M-Core wurde übrigens ja auch von solchen Leuten gehackermähen, von irgendwelchen Krypto-Scamern. Das ist wahrscheinlich alles der gleiche Kram
Deswegen einfach Linux verwenden, mit Linux wäre das nicht passiert, wisst ihr doch
Ich weiß, die sind sogar, wie heißt der Channel jetzt von ihm, achja genau, die Videos die habe ich geguckt, nicht alle, das habe ich teilweise geguckt, das dann, das nicht mehr
Das ist aber schön, da siehst du mal wieder, sowas, sowas zieht, guck mal, sowas, sowas zieht, jetzt können wir uns theoretisch nachher angucken
Sowas zieht, einfach mal BÄM, diese Überschrift, 30K Views, sonst 8,5, das ist, nice
Wäre das mit Linux wirklich nicht passiert? Wahrscheinlich nicht, nee, wahrscheinlich nicht, eben potentiell könnte das unter Linux wahrscheinlich nicht passieren
Wenn du irgendwelchen Campbell runterlädst, anklickst, installierst, was auch immer, das passiert dir unter Windows auf jeden Fall einfacher
Und ja, unter Mac OS wäre das wahrscheinlich auch nicht passiert
Ja, 3FA bringt dir halt nichts, wenn du in einem Browser eingeloggt bist und du keine Ahnung, zwei Wochen gültige Session hast
Penguin, Dankeschön für den Sub
Deswegen sage ich ja auch, unter Windows ist es halt einfacher, aber wenn es jemand gezielt auf jemand absieht, das ist nicht ausgeschlossen, dass das unter Mac oder Linux auch passiert
Aber unter Windows bist du da halt deutlich Anverleger für
Was soll es denn da für großartige andere Möglichkeiten geben? Also mir fällt jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht viel ein
Ich weiß ja nicht, was er für 3FA gemacht hat, man könnte zum Beispiel noch irgendwie gucken, ob man die 2FA-SMS hijackt oder so
Ist es leicht ein Session-Cookie zu klauen? Wenn du ein Root-Kit auf deinem Rechner hast, natürlich
Wenn du ein Root-Kit auf deinem Rechner hast, kann im Zweifelsfall jetzt mal billig gesagt jemand dein Rechner einfach fernsteuern, da musst du überhaupt kein Session-Cookie klauen
Da machst du einfach den Original-Browser auf und gehst auf die Seite
Mit dem Original-Browser, mit seiner Original-IP, mit seiner Original-Cache, Browser-Cache, Session-Cookies und alles
Ja, also wenn du irgendeinen Mist, irgendeinen Trojaner eingefallen hast, natürlich
Naja, das ist jetzt ja mal sehr allgemein gesagt, also wenn du, geh mal von außen an, wirklich 3-Faktor-Authentifizierung
Da musst du einen erstmal Social-Engineeren, dass du an 3-Faktoren drankommst, ja
Also, das ist so, wie wenn du sagst, nichts ist sicher, deswegen muss ich nichts verschlüsseln, so nach dem Motto
Ja, jede Verschlüsselung kann geknackt werden, theoretisch, praktisch sieht das aber ganz anders aus
Wenn du irgendwas hast, AES-Verschlüsseltes, mit einem 20-stelligen Passwort
Das kannst du selbstverständlich theoretisch knacken
Da brauchst du ein paar Millionen Jahre Zeit, dass das funktioniert
Trotzdem ist es sinnvoll, das zu verschlüsseln
Lieblings-Haustour-Abfall
Na, ich hatte mal in einem MMO, ähm, hatte ich ein Passwort
Katze, 1, 2, 3, Katze, ne, nicht in einem MMO, Schwachsinn
In einem alten E-Mail-Account, über den dann gesagt wurde, ich hab Spam verschickt
Hatt ich mal ein Passwort Katze, 1, 2, 3, Katze, 1, 2, 3
Und es ist mir erst später aufgefallen, dass das keine gute Idee war
Wobei das Passwort von der Länge her an sich gar nicht
Ne, ich glaube ich hatte nur Katze, 1, 2, 3, nicht Katze, 1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, das sind natürlich viel zu wenig
Also erstens nur 8 Buchstaben und dann sowas
Das Ding ist wahrscheinlich in jeder Passwort-Datenbank drinne
Hatt ich mal bei einer E-Mail-Adresse früher, Katze, 1, 2, 3
Früher, früher ist wirklich früher gemeint, ja
2004 oder so
Kann man einen Trojaner komplett loswerden, wenn man Windows neu aufsetzt oder reicht das nicht aus?
Also ich würde sagen, wenn du Windows neu installierst, bist du in der Regel erstmal auf der sicheren Seite
Es gibt natürlich Mittel und Wege
Es gab ja auch schon Berichte über Sachen, die sich irgendwie einrichten
In, hab ich nicht, in irgendwelchen anderen Speichern Sachen
Von damals BIOS bis vielleicht in irgendwelchen ungenutzten Sektoren auf der Festplatte
Und dann ist da wieder die Frage, wie wird es da wieder aktiv
Dann hast du vielleicht
Dateien, die quasi verseucht sind, die du beim nächsten Öffnen installiert sich wieder
Weil du sie halt auf dem Netzlaufwerk liegen hattest
Und das hatte, also 100% sicher bist du natürlich nicht
Damit, aber die allermeisten Sachen
Solltest du loswerden mit
Also Festplatte formatieren, Windows neu installieren
So
Aber wir haben das Video immer noch nicht durch
Keck wait, alter
Ja, genau
Sie sollen lieber auf der Startseite hängen bleiben, sich dort Dinge kaufen
Oder von Anfang an nach einem ganz präzisen, hoffentlich kostenpflichtigen Inhalt suchen
Aber irgendwie hinkt diese Theorie ein wenig
Prime könnte ja dennoch ähnlich wie Netflix ein sauber funktionierendes Such- und Entdecksystem haben
Dort könnte man ja trotzdem schön viele Bezahlinhalte untermischen
Es kann einfach kaum im Interesse von Amazon sein
Ich glaube irgendwie, Amazon scheißt einfach drauf
Oder aber, oder aber, wir müssen uns mal die Games von Amazon angucken
Oder aber, sie sind einfach, sie können es nicht besser
Vielleicht können sie es einfach nicht besser
Guckt euch die Games von Amazon an
Es ist nicht so, dass jetzt irgendwie New World an Geld, also an Manpower
Oder darf man eigentlich noch Manpower sagen
An Peoplepower gescheitert wäre
Oder an Geld
Das ist nicht das Problem
Also
Vielleicht können sie es auch einfach nicht
Vielleicht ja
Aber das ergibt, der Chat hat schon recht, es ergibt eigentlich auch keinen Sinn
Es ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn, dass es Amazon egal ist
Das ist schon richtig
Aber man sollte sagen, eigentlich sollte es Amazon auch nicht egal sein, dass New World kacke ist
Vielleicht, vielleicht können sie es einfach nicht besser
Und das liegt wahrscheinlich dann auch noch nicht mal daran, dass sie individuell betrachtet unfähige Leute hätten
Sondern das ist wahrscheinlich das Zusammenspiel in diesem, im Amazon Enterprise
Vielleicht sind die, vielleicht sind da auch viele Sachen zu starr
So nach dem Motto, du musst das verwenden, obwohl das nicht dafür geeignet ist
Zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung
Gehen wir jetzt mal von aus, Amazon hat ein eigenes JavaScript, Frontend, Class Library, Gedöns für ihren Shop
Und die sagen, du musst das verwenden, wenn du einen offiziellen Amazonservice programmierst
Und dann sagen sie, ja aber für ein Videoportal eignet sich das überhaupt nicht, so wie das gebaut ist
Das ist egal, du musst das verwenden, das ist Firmenpolicy, du kommst nicht drum vorbei, du musst unser Amazon Framework verwenden
So war es in der Richtung wahrscheinlich eher
Die sind nicht quasi, wie soll man sagen, die sind nicht agil genug, ja
Dann wäre Twitch auch so scheiße, nee Twitch war ja schon vor Amazon da
Und Prime Video ist von Amazon für Amazon entstanden
Ich denke mal, dass es sowas in der Richtung ist
Trotz der Benutzeroberfläche mit viel Abstand platzt zwei aller Streaming-Services
Gleichzeitig gibt Amazon zwar aber Milliarden für Inhalte aus, aber trotzdem viel weniger als die Wettbewerber
Und Amazon ist ja auch eine der größten Streaming-Services in der Welt
Aber trotzdem viel weniger als die Wettbewerber
Auch heute sei die Plattform für den Konzern laut einigen Analysen deshalb eher ein Teil des Prime-Angebotes und kein echtes eigenständiges Business
Das gesamte Geschäft von Netflix ist Netflix
Alle Abo-Services von Amazon zusammengenommen haben letztes Jahr zwar knapp 30 Milliarden Euro eingespielt
Was macht eigentlich Magenta TV so?
Das sind trotzdem gerade einmal knapp 7% des 431 Milliarden Euro Gesamtumsatzes des Konzerns
Zum Vergleich, fast die Hälfte dieser Summe stammt aus Verkäufen in Online-Stores, vor allem natürlich über die Hauptseite
Vielleicht läuft Prime Video auch so gut genug für seine Zwecke?
Am Ende ist es ja nur ein Bonus für die Prime-Mitgliedschaft, die wiederum vor allem ein Werkzeug ist, um den riesigen Online-Shop attraktiver zu machen
Wenn man so gewaltig und dominant ist, wird man vielleicht auch behäbig
Vielleicht werden interne Prozesse so kompliziert, dass sich am Ende nur noch sehr wenig vorwärts bewegt
Aber wie schwierig wäre es am Ende, diese Website einfach besser aufzubauen und Inhalte vernünftig zu kategorisieren?
Amazon ist ein riesengroßes Unternehmen
Daran siehst du auch, dass es wahrscheinlich wirklich was dran ist, was wir gerade vermutet haben
Das ist so ein typisches Ding, wo man als Außenstehender denkt, das kann doch nicht so schwer sein
Und die Frontend-Leute und Backend-Leute, die an Prime Video arbeiten, die wären dazu technisch wahrscheinlich auch ohne Probleme in der Lage
Aber wahrscheinlich gibt es irgendwelche unsinnigen Konzernen oder Enterprise-Vorgaben, dass sie Technologien verwenden müssen dafür, die dafür nicht gedacht sind
Das beste Beispiel ist doch Amazon Games, die die ganze Zeit ihren komischen CryEngine-Fork verwendet haben
Obwohl die Entwickler gesagt haben, so ein Bullshit-Alter, den Kram will keiner verwenden
Also wer es nicht weiß, Amazon Games hat die CryEngine geforkt und da was eigenes rausgebracht
Ich hab vergessen, wie hieß denn der Kram? Wood? Woodland? Nee
Forest? Forestland? Oder wie hieß denn der Kram von? Wie hieß man? Lumberyard, genau
Ihr müsst sagen, ich war mit Woodland und so gar nicht so weit von, Lumberyard war es, Lumberyard, genau
Das ist ein CryEngine-Fork oder kein... Nee, die CryEngine ist nicht open source, aber Amazon hat sich die Rechte irgendwie da dran gekauft
Das verwenden zu dürfen, also CryEngine-Fork, also man hat sich dafür entschieden, wohl die Engine mit einer der schlechtesten Dokumentationen ever
Zu benutzen, zu forken und für ihre eigenen Projekte zu verwenden, naja
Wenn auch einfach Unreal oder Unity verwenden können, wo man einfacher Leute für findet und ne, was auch immer
Also das war auch lange Zeit bei Amazon so ein Ding, wo sie gesagt haben, nein, nein, wir verwenden unseren komischen CryEngine-Fork
Und die Entwickler haben gesagt, Alter, so ein Kack, das wollen wir nicht, das ist Müll
Und ich gehe davon aus, dass das bei Prime Video ähnlich ist
Die müssen dort Technologien verwenden, weil es eben quasi Business Enterprise Stonks Vorgabe ist, obwohl es sich nicht eignet für eine Videoplattform
Wahrscheinlich gibt es eine zentrale Content DB bei Amazon
Und wenn du da suchen willst, die ist nicht dafür ausgelegt, Serien zu suchen
Die ist dafür ausgelegt, aber was DynamoDB, ist das das, keine Ahnung, ob die DynamoDB verwenden
Hab ich noch nie benutzt, aber das könnt ich mir vorstellen
Stellen wir mal, denken wir uns mal, die haben irgendeine Suchfunktion für ihre Datenbank
Und die ist halt nicht in der Lage, anhand der Daten wirklich, anhand von Serienmetadaten eine sinnvolle Suche durchzuführen
Sondern vielleicht nur anhand von einem Titel
Und dann hast du halt so ein Ding, dass in Prime Video Suche eben Staffel 3 vor Staffel 1 steht und sowas
Die Benutzeroberfläche von Prime Video ist in vielerlei Hinsicht ein Enigma
Immerhin wisst ihr jetzt, wenn eure Serie mal wieder in irgendeiner zufälligen Folge, in einer zufälligen Staffel weitergeht
Ihr seid nicht allein
Cheers
Hey, hoffentlich hat euch dieses Video gefallen
Schreibt uns unbedingt in die Kommentare, was ihr über Prime Video denkt
Auf der Endcard findet ihr ein Video von
Das ist ein bisschen so, wie Battlefield 2042 DICE auch Riesenprobleme hatte
Mit Frostbite
Und sie mussten Frostbite verwenden
Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass bei DICE einige gesagt haben, Alter, warum verwenden wir nicht was anderes
Ich hab gesagt, nein, ihr verwendet Frostbite
Tja, kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen
Was es da ähnlich ist
Darf man eigentlich auf so Videos reacten
Ich meine, das ist YouTube, da weiß man nie, was man darf und was man nicht darf
So, Ubuntu muss jetzt hier angucken
React for the haters
BFStats
Ach so, Spielzahlen
Spielzahlen sind immer noch schlecht, aber ein bisschen besser geworden seit dem Patch
React for the haters
Schauen wir doch mal
Ich will nicht wissen, wie viele das jetzt glauben
Ich weiß nicht
Ich weiß nicht, wer React erfunden hatte
Aber ich garantiere euch, es war nicht der Zug
Schauen wir doch mal
React, was heißt denn Erfinder
Inventor
Nee, nicht Founder, Founder ist Gründer
Hier, der, der sieht nicht aus wie Zuckerberg, oder?
John Wock, Wocky, keine Ahnung, wie man den ausspricht
Der hat React erfunden
Ich wusste, dass das Fake ist
Garantiert hat nicht der Zug React erfunden
Warum sagt das das Video dann, weil das, weil das Chebat ist
React ist einfach, es ist nur JavaScript Bro und deswegen gibt es dir viele seltsame Probleme
Funktionale und klassebasierte Komponenten, Hooks, Forward-Ref, höhere Wörterkomponenten, Mixins
Das Emote hat gut reingepasst, oder?
Ich hab's aus Versehen gedrückt
Renderproffs, Suspense und so weiter
Es wurde als erstes Ui-Library gekredet, obwohl es die meisten Ideen von AngularJS nahm
Wohlgemerkt Angular 1 und nicht das, was heute Angular ist
Sag mal Leute, React-Kenner, ich hab keine Ahnung von React
Kann man mittlerweile sein HTML eigentlich als HTML schreiben oder muss man das immer noch JSX-Inline schreiben?
Und wenn ja, warum haben die nicht irgendwie was wie Single File Components mittlerweile gemacht in React
Wo du dein CSS, HTML und JavaScript in einer Datei schreiben kannst, aber HTML in HTML und nicht HTML in JavaScript
Warum ist das so, oder ist das noch so?
Wer denn nicht auf Bl Quantico schauen will, ist checklist-trainer.ch
sie vor einigen Jahren, als sie in der Schule gingen, um eine echte Sprache wie C zu lernen.
Um zu beginnen, baut man eine neue React-App, dann öffnet man Google,
zum Glück nicht C++, da hatten wir sie heute schon von.
... um die Gäste des Tutorials Hell zu entdecken.
Siehst du, wie wir starten? In Strict-Mode.
Das ist verwendet, um die Vergangenheit von vorherigen Versionen des Framewares,
ich meine, des Libraries.
Nun, in dem Code, wir betrachten, dass wir funktionale Programming machen,
indem wir unsere Komponenten als Funktionen schreiben.
Klassen sind auch möglich, aber sie sind eigentlich der Teufel.
Stattdessen verwenden wir diese Haken überall, die die selben scheiß Klassen
in einer mehr magischen, hipsterischen Art machen.
Templating ist handelt in JSX. Es ist eine nonstandardige Art, HTML zu schreiben,
die die UI komplett in...
Ja, deswegen musst du...
Deswegen musst du ja auch in React anstatt Class, Class-Namen schreiben und solche...
ekligen Dinger.
Warum? Weil Class in JavaScript ein Keyword ist, was Reserved ist.
... an Portable Callback-Help.
Nun, wir können uns alle zu Css-Haten begreifen,
aber React wird dich noch mehr verbreiten, wenn du etwas auf deiner eigenen Stilstelle versuchst.
Glücklicherweise arbeiten hunderts von Css- und JS-Libraries auf diesem Problem,
als wir sprechen.
Die Extra-Komplexität ist aber wert, weil React sehr schnell ist,
wenn du alle seltenen Tricks verabschieden.
Leben geht um Schmerz.
Es soll nicht wie Svelte oder fast wie solid sein,
oder lieb wie Angular, oder alles, was vorhanden ist, wie View.
Das einzige, was wichtig ist, ist, dass React die Popularste ist.
Und das macht es unvergesslich das Beste.
So wie Microsoft das beste Operierungssystem macht,
und McDonalds das beste Essen macht.
Das hat mich in den letzten 100 Sekunden mit React-Kommunität zerstört.
React ist in der letzten Siedlung der frühen Web-Development der meisten Influential-Library.
Das stimmt wohl, ja.
Aber es ist heute so, weil es viele Dinge richtig macht.
Und dafür hat es unseren Respekt.
Danke fürs Zuschauen.
And I will see you in the next one.
War gerade in den Chat Intel Nuke mit Celeron, Pentium oder i3.
Kommt doch an, was du drauf machen willst.
Also ich meine, ich denke, ein i3 ist wahrscheinlich die bessere Variante.
Musste mal gucken, was Stromverbrauch ist,
unterschiedlich Geld, wahrscheinlich ist der i3 die sinnvollere Variante.
Der wird nicht so viel mehr kosten und der wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht
so viel mehr Strom verbrauchen, aber mit eine ganze Ecke mehr Wumms haben.
Jetzt zum Glück, und was hältst du von Windows 11?
Ich mache ja immer noch Bogen drum und ich werde auch nur
updaten, wenn ich wirklich updaten muss.
Ohne Scheiß, das, was mich bei Windows 11 mit Abstand am meisten abfuckt,
ist, dass ich meine Tastleiste nicht mehr so haben kann wie hier,
weil er automatisch groopet und so ein Rotz.
Wer will sowas?
Wer will automatisches Crooping haben, man?
Ich habe nicht umsonst einen Widescreen-Monitor,
dass ich Widescreen machen kann.
Also das Gegenteil von Pepo White Happy, was die machen mit Windows 11.
Der Account-Zwang ist auch richtig dumm.
Ich weiß nicht, wenn das schon Power-User ist,
wenn man einfach seine Sachen sehen will.
Ach, Microsoft Shit, die machen auf der einen Seite viele sinnvolle Sachen.
Also was sie mit.NET machen ist nice, Visual Studio Code ist nice,
was sie mit GitHub und auch in Azure ist vieles, wenn auch ein bisschen umständlich nice.
Aber Windows ist komplett ein Shinshorn, was sie treiben.
Warum ist für Rechtsklick ein weiterer Klick nötig?
Hä?
Also ich muss nur rechts einmal klicken, oder was?
Hä, wie?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Oder meinst du, warum du Rechtsklick nicht mit Linksklick machen kannst?
Was, wie?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Zimmerboard sagt mir nichts, keine Ahnung.
Was?
Windows 11?
Hä, man muss in Windows 11 doppelt rechts klicken?
Moment, das war nicht nur in der Beta so, das ist jetzt in der Live-Version immer noch so.
Ich dachte, das war ein Überbleibsel aus der Beta-Version, die wir uns angeguckt haben.
Ihr meint diese Geschichte hier, dass wenn du hier klickst,
dass du dann nicht dieses Menü klickst, sondern auf Legacy-Menü aufmachen gehen musst.
Das ist wirklich im Live-Version ernsthaft?
Die haben den Arsch offen, oder?
Aber, aber komplett bei Microsoft.
Das ist doch unfassbar, so schlecht.
Weil kann das wenig, ja gut.
Gut, dass die Zeit der Registry-Hacks und 25 Tipps, die nicht mal Microsoft kennt,
nie aufhören wird durch diesen Shit.
Ja, warum verstehe ich auch nicht.
Wenn das möglich ist, ist es bestimmt keine schlechte Idee, aber wenn ihr normale 0.8.15
Desktop-Anwender habt, die kriegen Abfahrt unter Linux, nicht so sehr, weil es nicht
gehen würde, gerade wenn du Software verwendest, die es auch unter Linux gibt oder eh hauptsächlich
im Browser läuft, sondern weil die kleinste Umstellung Abfahrt ist für den normalen Anwender.
So, was kommt man sonst noch angucken, Leute?
Gibt es irgendwelche, haben wir hier vielleicht noch ein paar Videos offen, die wir gucken?
Was haben wir hier eigentlich alles auf?
Mario-Musik?
Äh, ein CCC-Talk, den wir uns jetzt nicht angucken, weil er eine Stunde lang geht und
auch mehr Musik.
Aber wir können das Video angucken von How to be a Linux-User, was ist das für ein Thumbnail,
was ist das für ein Thumbnail, was ist das für ein Thumbnail, was ist das für ein Thumbnail,
was ist das für ein Thumbnail, was ist das für ein Thumbnail, das ist die Findbarkeit
Jede Gruppe, jede Truppe der Menschen hat ihre eigenen Kostüme in Bezug auf Dresden und Körperdecorationen.
Sobald Tattoos eine wichtige Teil der kulturerischen Beiden der Ärzte sind, ist das für die Linux-Kommunikation.
Grüß sie lang und trägt sie mit Prüffung.
Die zweite Sache, die du tun kannst, ist...
Nicht zu verwechseln mit dem Hipster-Bard, der aktuell auch sehr angesagt ist.
Wir verwenden wirklich alte Denkpads. Du wirst nie einen Street-Cred in der Linux-Kommunikation...
Da ist was dran, da ist was dran. Das liegt aber daran, weil die IBM-Thinkpads unter Linux immer super supported waren.
Beziehungsweise da Hardware drin ist, die super supported war.
Und leistungstechnisch ist meistens ausreichend. Ja, da ist aber schon was dran.
Denkpads werden von vielen Linux-Usern immer noch sehr hochgehalten.
Übrigens, ich hab jetzt so oft Linux gesagt, Leute. Wo ist dann eigentlich das...
Allow me to intercept for a moment, meme jetzt.
Hast du einen neuen Laptop bekommen und funktioniert eigentlich alles?
Ja, ich denke auch nicht, dass es irgendwie großartige Probleme gibt, dass was nicht funktionieren wird.
Also unter Windows 11 funktioniert der ganze Kram wahrscheinlich genauso unter 10.
Aber mich nervt das Gegängele einfach.
Von Accountzwang bis zu, ich muss jetzt, obwohl ich einen Widescreen-Monitor hab,
ich muss jetzt die Sache gegroupt haben, obwohl ich sie nicht gegroupt haben will.
Solche Geschichten. Ich verstehe nicht, warum neue Releases heutzutage quasi mehr Gängelungen bedeuten bei allen möglichen Zeichen.
Gerade diese Funktionen, die sie jetzt testen mit, du kannst Windows noch nicht mal ohne Microsoft-Account mehr installieren.
Das kann zwar echt nicht sein, das geht mir mega auf den Keks.
Leute, ich hab sogar einen MongoDB-Aufkleber auf meinem Notebook. Ich weiß nicht, was mich da geritten hat.
Ich hab normalerweise mit NoSQL-Datenbanken überhaupt nichts am Hut. Aber ich hab einen MongoDB-Aufkleber.
Ja, so ist es. Ja, so ist es. Er ist halt so.
Ich mein, guck mal. Warum soll ich rausgehen, wenn ich mir auf YouTube einfach ein Video von draußen angucken kann?
Da geh ich zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, weil er eben im Chat war, da geh ich zu Reload Jack beispielsweise auf dem Channel und guck mir irgendwie Lost Places an.
Ist genug draußen. Genug in freier Wildbahn reicht doch schon. Warum soll ich raus, Alter?
Ich gebe zu meinen Twitter-Posts widersprechender Sache. Ich habe in letzter Zeit viele Fotos von draußen gepostet.
Aber in Wirklichkeit ist das ja eigentlich nur, weil ich fake... also ich tue ja auch nur so, als würde ich rausgehen.
Deepfaked. Oh Gott, dieses Foto, please.
Sagt mal, außer auf Stock-Fotos, niemand sieht so aus, wenn er eine VR-Brille auf hat, oder?
Also niemand spielt so mit einer VR-Brille und niemand guckt so mit einer VR-Brille. Das ist doch einzigartig für irgendwelche Stock-Fotos.
Aber nur, wenn sie online sind. Und der 6. Weg, wie du, der neue Linux-User, wie ein langsamer Linux-User werden kannst, ist,
Tell everyone that you use Vim. Longtime Linux-Users constantly brag how... Ja, du kannst, vielleicht Emacs, vielleicht auch noch Emacs. Wie ist das eigentlich, wenn man heutzutage noch Supply-Text verwendet, Chat? Ist das... wird das noch gerne gesehen oder ist das eher schon... also darf man das noch sagen, ja?
Also ich verwende keinen Supply-Text mehr. Ich habe lange Zeit gerne Supply-Text verwendet. Ich sehe mich heute ehrlich gesagt erstaunlich oft in Visual Studio Code und irgendwelchen fetten JetBrains-IDs.
Wenn du es einmal geschafft hast wieder rauszukommen, ist alles gut.
Ne, Nano ist... Ohne Scheiß. Nano verwende ich nie. Never. Nano. Vim auf der Kommandozeile oder eben JetBrains-IDs oder Visual Studio Code, wenn es um Anwendung geht. Auf der Kommandozeile Vim only, Leute. Nano, Alter. Du kannst Nano nicht mal gescheit längere Textfiles editieren mit der Tastatur.
Nano ist ein normaler Texteditor, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass du die Maus nicht drin verwenden kannst. Wobei es wahrscheinlich irgendwie sogar funktioniert.
Vim, das erste was... also glücklicherweise ist Vim mehr oder weniger auf 99,9% Default. Aber, also drauf. Aber wenn nicht, das erste was ich installiere ist Vim Full.
Ob jetzt die Linux-Crowd so krasse Anime-Fans sind, weiß ich noch nicht mal. Aber, aber, ja doch, da gibt's bestimmt große, große Überschneidungen, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ach, ja, ja!
Okay. Aber für die meisten anderen Sachen. Vim beste. Wenn es einfach nur auf Kommandozeile um Texteditieren geht.
Denn das Gute an Nano ist ja, dass er vorinstalliert ist. Genauso wie Vim bei den meisten. Weil zumindest bei Demian ist. Bei Demian hat eigentlich Nano noch Default.
Oh, danke für den Sub.
Geht's bei euch um Emacs? Also ich weiß nicht ob Emacs Lisp wirklich ein Vorteil ist. Also alles was ich von diesem Emacs Lisp gesehen hab bisher ist... Ach du meinst Language Server Protocol, nicht Lisp.
Okay, dann alles klar. Ja, okay. Ja, aber ob Vim oder Neo Vim ist jetzt ja erstmal wurscht. Die meisten Leute kommen wahrscheinlich nie in den Genuss quasi zu sagen,
Hey, ich benutze jetzt Funktionen die nur Neo Vim hat und Vim nicht. Das sind dann Leute die 5 Seiten Vimrc haben. Und ich spreche da aus Erfahrung.
Ich hatte früher auch die mega Vimrc und mindestens 30 verschiedene Plugins und so. Und ich konnte meinen Vim gar nicht mehr aktualisieren.
Weil es dann irgendwie geprägt ist. Wenn ich meine Plugins aktualisiert habe, haben sich 30 Plugins aktualisiert und es ging irgendwas nicht mehr.
Alles mögliche drin. Also mein Vim war overengineert als Fuck früher. Heute habe ich eine Vimrc mit keine Ahnung 30 Zeilen, Standard Zeug und gut ist.
Und glaubt nur nicht mal großartig viele Plugins. Moin Michael5, spiel die an. So, haben wir noch irgendwas was von uns angucken können?
Ne, Ubuntu 29 spielen und gucke ich mir jetzt bestimmt nicht an. Home Network Server Rack, ja da gucke ich ja immer gerne was andere Leute so treiben.
Wo geht es denn los? Erst mal Skippen zur Technik. Gut, easy. Erst mal übersprungen, so muss das sein. Was bauen sich denn andere Leute?
Okay, der hat wirklich einen Full-Sized Rack. Wobei ist es nach hinten wirklich voll? Ja, wahrscheinlich. Leute, was hat denn so ein Standard Rack für eine Höhe? 48 HE?
Ne, ist ein bisschen viel oder? Was hat denn so ein Standard? 42? 48? Okay, er hat einfach mal ein Monitor drin stehen, so kann man seinen Platz im Rack auch füllen.
32 HE, 42 HE, ja irgendwie so. Wow. Alter, was haben die da immer drin? Für daheim. Okay, irgendeine Storage Kiste, eins, zwei, drei, vier Dell Kisten, noch mehr Stott. Was machen die denn da immer daheim damit?
Ja gut, das ist nicht verkehrt.
Ja, die Stromkosten sind bald teurer als die Anschaffungskosten. Das da ist sein Unraid-Server. Oder was war es dann?
Ja. Ja gut, da hat er... 400! Das stimmt doch nicht, was da vorne drauf steht, oder? Das sind einfach nur die Wechselrahmen und da sind andere HDDs drin.
Also ich mein, seriously, 600G, 400G, das kann nicht sein. Das wäre mega useless. Unsinnig. Da fährst du ja besser. Ach, SSDs vielleicht. Okay, wenn das SSDs sind, habe ich nichts gesagt.
SSDs wären okay. Da steht ja auch SSD drunter, oder? Nee, 15K? Nee, nur das hier sind SSDs. Das hier sind SSDs und das sind Platten irgendwie.
Die 400er sind SSDs und das andere... Ja, aber hier nicht. Hier steht 15K. Das sind, das sind Disks, das sind Disks und das sind SSDs. Aber trotzdem zu klein.
Weile Server-Namen sagt das denen? Ich weiß nicht. Das sind auf jeden Fall schlechte Filme. Mag leiste Server-Namen sein, aber...
Ach, da. Was sonst? Ja, stell dir mal vor, der hat einen Space-Inserver-Namen. Cringe, Alter.
Warum haben die... Warum hast du ein ESX-Cluster daheim?
Okay, weiter. Jetzt war klar, dass es ein Cluster ist. Ich meine, wenn man das zum Üben macht, vollkommen in Ordnung, aber als produktives, ich nenne es mal produktives System, daheim ist das doch ein bisschen overkill.
Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen, dass alles, was du zusätzlich hast zu der Funktion, die du brauchst oder halt auch nur quasi Infrastruktursachen, damit du deine Sachen laufen lassen, da musst du dich alles drum kümmern.
Und wir haben doch mal ein Video geguckt von einem, der irgendwie zig Kubernetes-Cluster daheim hat, wo ich mir gedacht habe, der Kellner macht ja Vollzeit nichts anderes als sich um seinen Rack daheim zu kümmern.
Das kann doch nicht so ein Zweck der Sache sein. Technotim, genau, ja.
Warum hat er Plex nicht virtualisiert? Er hat ein ESX-Cluster. Warum brauchst du ein extra Plex-Server, wenn er ein ESX-Cluster hat?
Das stimmt, alles günstig auf Ebay geschossen, was anderes kann ich mir nicht erklären.
Warum ist der im Rack? Warum hat er den Drucker und den Monitor eigentlich im Rack stehen?
Das ist ein ESV oder so.
13.000, ach nee, also 1300, okay, das war das andere.
Das ist für Backup. Ah, der druckt sich den Storage-Spiel näher aus, klar, klar, verstehe.
Ich glaube, das ist genug von vorne. Schauen wir dir den Backup an.
Schauen wir dir den Backup an.
Ich meine, immerhin, immerhin RGB-Trenner, ja. Wobei, das ist gar kein RGB-Trenner, das ist irgendein Mainboard-LED, die halt einfach blau leuchtet.
Was war das eigentlich von vorne da oben? Was sehen wir denn eigentlich hier von?
Wir sind bei 314. Was sehen wir denn eigentlich gerade von hinten?
Was genau sehen wir da von hinten?
Ja, aber die Switches müsste ich doch von vorne auch sehen. Wo sind die?
Wo sind die? Vielleicht hier drinnen? Hinter dem Monitor? Nee, da passt nichts hin.
Meint ihr, die sind so kurz, dass die hinter dem Monitor passen?
Ja, hier ist der Monitor. Ach, die sind so kurz, das passt. Okay, die sind hinter dem Monitor, alles klar.
Flix.
Hat er da zwei Raspberry-Pies drinne?
Ja, guck mal, das hat er. Sowas wollte ich mir auch mal ausdrucken, war mir dann aber zu umständlich. So ein Raspberry-Pie-Rack-Mount-Ding, kann man sich auch fertig holen.
Dauert zu lang, den Gramm selbst zu drucken. Zwei Raspberry-Pies. Und was hat er da? Vielleicht irgendeinen KVM-Switch oder so?
Ja gut, so sehen die Dell-Dinger halt aus von hinten. Ah, jetzt kriegen wir es auch erklärt.
Ich muss jetzt auch mal was Unpopuläre sagen, ich mag UniFi-Sachen nicht. Ich habe selbst UniFi-Access-Points, vier Stück.
Und, warte mal, vier Stück. Erdgeschoss. Keller, erster Stock, anderer Stock. Ja, vier Stück. Und einen UniFi-Controller auf dem Raspberry-Pie.
Die Dinger funktionieren. Also es ist schon okay. Aber ich mag es nicht wirklich.
Erstens, was mir nicht gefällt, ist, dass man überhaupt sowas wie einen Controller braucht.
Okay, verstehe ich irgendwie die Vorteile von einem Controller, in dem Fall, dass du das da einstellst und das automatisch deployt auf alle Access-Points oder so.
Okay, ja in großer Installation, wenn man da vielleicht hunderte hat, in Ordnung. Bei vier denke ich, ist es noch denkbar, das ohne zu machen.
Ich weiß, du brauchst nicht wirklich einen Controller, das geht auch mit der Smartphone-App, aber das macht ja keiner.
Ja, und dass es halt so undurchsichtig ist, was was ist. Also, du hast bei diesem UniFi-Zeug sehr viel Magic.
Du hast dann zum Beispiel Hekchen, Auto-Optimierung, da hast du keine Ahnung, was der im Hintergrund macht.
Viele Sachen sind so, du weißt einfach nicht genau, was es treibt und es ist dann anders benannt.
Und wenn halt was nicht funktioniert, dann weißt du nicht, was du machen sollst.
Funktioniert beispielsweise die Autodiscovery nicht richtig, hast du keine Ahnung, was du machen sollst.
Ich habe zum Beispiel ein Wireless-Uplink auf der anderen Seite vom Stockwerk, weil ich da kein Kabel habe.
Und der hat ums Verrecken nicht Autodiscovered.
Ich habe da ewig gebraucht für, bis ich es gecheckt habe und solche Dinge.
Also es ist mir auf der einen Seite zu viel. UniFi weiß ich nicht, an was ich das richten soll.
Auf der einen Seite denkt man sich, ja, das richtet sich daran, die richtig große Installationen machen wollen.
Auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir, es richtet sich an irgendwelche Home-Noobs, die eigentlich überfordert sind von Settings, die ordentlich heißen, aber das kann ja nicht sein.
Entweder richtest du dich an große Installationen, dann sind das Profis, oder du richtest dich an Home-Noobs.
Dann machst du es so wie die Fritzbox zum Beispiel.
Aber UniFi ist so ein halb gares Ding.
Das Einzige, was UniFi Access Points bei mir rettet, ist, dass die Access Points an sich halt ganz okay sind.
Ansonsten denkt der ganze Kram drumherum, keine Ahnung, so geil ist es nicht.
Und deswegen würde ich mir auch nie im Leben als zentraler Firewall-Router-Lösung eine UniFi-Kiste hinstellen, im Leben nicht.
Es ist fantastisch, man hat nie Probleme damit, es läuft immer.
Das Einzige, was UniFi zu tun hat, ist, dass es bei den kleinen MikroTik-Routern, auch bei den kleinen MikroTik-Routern,
für um die 450 Euro und so was, da kannst du nichts sagen.
Auch die kleineren, auch die MikroTik-Router, für 50-60 Euro sind top.
Und auch die Einsteiger-Switches mit 24 Gigabits, 2x10 Gigabit, sind wirklich preis-leistungstechnisch unschlagbar.
Das einzige Problem bei MikroTik ist, dass eben Router OS, tja...
Häkchen, kannst aber viele Sachen gar nicht einstellen.
Bei Router OS heißen die Dinger irgendwie noch korrekt, sind aber nicht, sind nicht angeordnet und viel zu viele.
Also das ist das komplette Gegenteil.
Also ich weiß nicht, wer schonmal die Ehre hatte, VLANs einzurichten unter Router OS,
das ist sehr, sehr unintuitiv.
Die MikroTik-Boards, das sind quasi die Boards, die in ihren fertigen Routern mit drin sind.
Ich weiß nicht, warum man das machen sollte.
Wisst ihr, was ich bei diesem UniFi Zeug auch glaube?
Es haben ja so viele Leute UniFi im Einsatz daheim.
Und das ist ja nicht billig und ich glaube, viele Leute fallen da wieder in diese Denkmuster rein.
Ich habe jetzt quasi mir für 1000 Euro Netzwerk WLAN-Equipment gekauft
und selbst wenn es irgendwie nicht funktioniert, kann ich es nicht schlecht finden,
weil damit müsste ich mir eingestehen, ich habe vielleicht doch nicht für das Geilste der Welt 1000 Euro ausgegeben.
Wie gesagt, ich habe das UniFi Zeug, aber ich feier es nicht so super ab wie irgendwie gefühlt restliches YouTube.
Es funktioniert brauchbar, ja, brauchbar.
Aber nicht so flawless und best ever, wie man das überall sieht oder wie es dahingestellt wird.
Allein schon standardmäßig, dass standardmäßig eingeschaltet ist, dass 5G-fähige Geräte auf 5G gezwungen werden,
nicht 5G, 5 Gigahertz, nicht 5G.
Dass 5G, 5 Gigahertz-fähige Geräte auf 5 Gigahertz WLAN gezwungen werden, ist doch komplett für'n Arsch.
Warum ist sowas Default, Mann?
Es ist halt nun mal so, erwiesenermaßen, dass 2,4 Gigahertz WLAN weiter reicht als 5 Gigahertz WLAN in der Regel.
Ja, es macht durchaus Sinn, in 5 Gigahertz zu joinen, wenn 5 Gigahertz verfügbar ist.
Aber wenn ich an der Grenze bin, wo 5 Gigahertz zum Beispiel nicht mehr richtig funktioniert, aber 2,4 Gigahertz noch klappt,
warum sollte mich das mein nächstes Point verbieten?
Beziehungsweise, was auch immer es dann am Ende ist.
Das ist Default bei UniFi, das ist total bescheuert.
It's flawless.
Flawless, ja, haben wir schon gelernt.
Next thing down, I have my USW aggregation switch.
This has 8, 10 gigabit ports on it.
Siehste?
Da hätte er sich auch irgendeinen x-beliebigen MikroTik-Switch kaufen können.
Da hätte er für 100 paar gequetschte Euro einen fetten Switch bekommen.
Oder für, weiß nicht was, einen fetten Switch bekommen.
Mit 2x 10 Gigabit Uplink und 24 Gigabit Ports.
Easy, der bräuchte da gerade 3 Switche.
And then I have a USW24 PoE-Switch.
War blöde Frage.
Für was verwenden die meisten Leute eigentlich?
Also was sind so die Features von dieser,
also diese, diese, diese Tree Machine Geschichte oder so da oben.
Das ist ja quasi so die Security Firewall Routing Lösung von UniFi.
Was machen die meisten Leute eigentlich damit?
Dass man das überhaupt braucht.
Ich habe jetzt auch schon einige YouTube Videos auf Deutsch gesehen,
die das mega abfeiern.
Was machen die denn damit?
Was machen die damit, was man nicht mit einem 0815-Switch und,
also wenn es ja wirklich darum geht, dass es easy für den Heimatwender ist,
was machen die damit?
Das ist, also wenn man, okay, das Ding hat wahrscheinlich
einfache Revealern Setup als das MikroTik oder so.
Aber die meisten Leute kommen wahrscheinlich mit einem Switch
oder Fritzbox easy hin.
Fritzbox hat zu wenig Ports.
Aber die meisten Leute, wenn die sich einen 24-Port-Switch kaufen
ohne Fritzbox, haben sie wahrscheinlich was,
was in ihrer Know-How-Liga gut bedienbar ist
und was eigentlich auch soweit funktioniert,
ohne dass du groß was machen musst.
Wenn du natürlich ein bisschen advancedere Sachen machen willst,
sei es, dass du wirklich mal von Hand Firewall-Regeln einrichten willst,
dass du ein bisschen komplexeres WLAN-Setup bist.
Vielleicht möchtest du irgendwann auch mal IPSEC
oder irgendwas VPN-mäßiges machen, okay.
Aber dann würde ich es trotzdem nicht mit irgendeinem Unify-Router machen.
Fritzbox, ich sage ja, WLAN ist das Einzige, was mir so einfällt,
aber die meisten Leute wollen keinen WLAN daheim machen.
Die wissen doch nicht einmal, wozu man das überhaupt verwenden sollte.
Wenn du denen sagst, wie wäre es denn, wenn man euer Gäste-WLAN
vielleicht in den extra WLAN packt und sie sagen, was, habe ich doch.
Nein, nein, hast du nicht, du hast ein extra SSID,
aber du hast kein eigenes WLAN für Gäste- oder China-Geräte.
Was man auch nicht zwangsläufig braucht, ja.
Also wenn man einfach nur einen Gäste-WLAN hat in einem eigenen Netz
und das an irgendeinem Router ist mit Firewall dazwischen,
wo du blocken kannst, keinen Zugriff aufs interne Netz,
dann ist das auch absolut in Ordnung.
Sobald du dann aber in diesem WLAN-Netz
vielleicht noch ein paar kabelgebundene Geräte haben möchtest, ja,
dann wird es schon ein bisschen schwierig.
Dann musst du das irgendwie an dein Router-Port packen,
dann musst du gucken, dass du den eigenen Switch nur dafür holst,
weil du möchtest ja nicht, dass der Switch irgendwie mit beiden Ports
intern und extern dran gesteckt ist.
Sonst könntest du dir nämlich einfach hergehen
und auf deinem Client eine interne IP geben
und es wird trotzdem funktionieren.
Also spätestens dann brauchst du WLANs, ja.
Gäste-WLAN ist eigenes Subnet, ja, aber das reicht ja oftmals nicht.
Wie gesagt, spätestens bei dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe,
reicht das nicht.
Spätestens wenn du paar kabelgebundene Geräte haben willst,
zum Beispiel, dass du irgendwelche PoE-Kameras hast,
die du in deinen IoT-WLAN packen willst,
du kannst die zwar einstellen.
Ja, wenn du genug Ports an der Fritzbox hast, meinetwegen,
dann kannst du das machen.
Aber danach ist Schluss, ja.
Also wenn du, keine Ahnung, wenn du fünf PoE-Kameras hast
und die willst du in irgendeinen IoT-WLAN packen,
wo auch deine IoT-Geräte drin sind, dann wird das schwierig.
Dann brauchst du irgendeinen, fängt ja schon an,
dass du kein PoE über die Fritzbox machen kannst.
Ganz so einfach ist es dann doch nicht.
Und spätestens dann musst du es eigentlich in ein eigenes WLAN packen,
wenn du nicht einen komplett eigenen PoE-Switch
nur dafür verwenden willst.
Weil ansonsten hast du das Problem, dass du deinen Switch nimmst
und du hast einen 24-Port-Switch mit PoE, meinetwegen,
da steckst du deine Kameras da dran.
Die sollen allerdings in das IoT-WLAN rein
und dann musst du dir überlegen, wie du das machst.
Weil dann hast du letztendlich das Problem,
natürlich kannst du das IP-technisch voneinander trennen,
aber man darf nicht vergessen, dass der Switch trotzdem Zugang hat.
Wenn du dann auf einem dieser Geräte einfach deine IP änderst
von dem IoT-Subnet auf dein internes Subnet,
dann hast du Zugriff auf dein internes Netzwerk,
wenn das nicht in einem eigenen WLAN hängt.
Das ist der gleiche 24-Port-Switch, der für alles verwendet wird.
Du bist dann nicht gezwungen, irgendwie über die Firewall zu gehen,
weil dein Weg gar nicht da drüber geht.
Da bleibt dir nichts anderes übrig, als da für irgendwelche WLAN-Setups zu machen.
Ja, und da hört es natürlich bei einer Fritzbox auf.
Aber trotzdem, ich würde mir trotzdem kein UniFi-Zeug hinstellen.
Das ist ordentlich.
Ja, dazu brauchst du aber Geräte, die WLANs können.
Warum? Was?
Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht. Brauchen sei mal dahingestellt.
Äh, ich dachte, er ist per Fiber dran.
Das würde mich auch interessieren, was hat er da eigentlich drauf?
Ich habe die USW-Aggregation runter, oder vielleicht das 10-Gigabit-Port runter,
wie bei diesem hier.
Alles läuft immer noch ordentlich.
Es hat vielleicht nicht alles, was es vorher hatte,
aber es läuft immer noch ordentlich, wo ich es hinbekommen kann.
Das ist ja alles schön und gut, aber wozu?
Ich habe einen Generator da draußen.
Und dann gibt es auch all diese Schuhe, wie die US24-Port-PoE.
Sie sind mit Fiber verbunden mit den USW-Aggregationen.
Und dann habe ich die andere Kabel, die eigentlich in meinen Garage geht,
wo ich einen anderen Schuhe habe, der alle meine Abwechsläufe und andere Dinge so macht.
Und dann habe ich noch einen anderen Abwechsläufe hier im Server-Rack,
der mit den USW-Aggregationen verbunden ist.
Das finde ich immer geil.
So ungefähr hängt das Ding bei mir im Keller auch da.
Das ist mit dem USW-Aggregationen verbunden mit dem USW-Port-Switch.
Und das ist wirklich nur im Fall, dass der Garage-Switch runtergeht.
Ich werde immer noch einen WIFI-Axispunkt laufen.
Nur für diesen Redundanz-Faktor.
Aber egal, das wird es für dieses Video.
Wenn ihr mehr von diesen Servern oder Runden von jedem gerne hören möchtet,
dann schreibt es in die Kommentare oder klickt auf den Like-Button.
Oder wenn ihr Fragen habt, dann schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Vielen Dank, Leute!
Pog
Ich muss mal kurz hydraten, Leute.
So, haben wir noch irgendwas zum Angucken?
Ich glaube, ich mache jetzt gleich Schluss.
Und esse was.
Und dann machen wir noch ein bisschen Programmier-Stells.
Was kam jetzt eigentlich raus?
Wir haben ja noch irgendwelche WLAN-Geschichten hier.
Was dann Kameras als Untag-Gäste WLANen am Switch?
Es gibt bestimmt die unterschiedlichen Setups,
die in manchen Varianten funktionieren oder nicht.
Es ist auf jeden Fall hinderlich in vielen Szenarios,
dass die Fritzbox keinen WLANs kann.
Aber die meisten Leute brauchen das daheim ja auch nicht.
Bei dem Song habe ich meine Eltern kennengelernt.
Moment, Moment!
Ich dachte, die haben sich bei...
Ich dachte, die haben sich hier kennengelernt.
Coboll? Nein, wir programmieren keinen Coboll.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Auf gar keinen Fall.
Das werde ich mir nicht angucken.
Was hat die Fritzbox nicht?
Die Fritzbox hat vieles nicht,
was einen ordentlichen Router auszeichnet.
Aber die Fritzbox hat viele Funktionen,
was sie zu einem guten Multifunktionsgerät macht.
Also wir haben sie eben von WLAN-Support.
Die Fritzbox hat aber zum Beispiel, soweit ich weiß,
auch keine gescheiten Möglichkeiten,
ausgehende Firewall-Regeln zu machen.
Oder? Geht das mittlerweile?
Ja, VPN-Setup-Sachen sind auch recht rudimentär.
Gut, so Sachen wie Routing-Protokolle brauche ich niemand daheim.
Das lassen wir jetzt mal weg.
Fritzbox kommt ja mit WireGuard-Support.
Erlang? Da muss ich erstmal meine Klammern
auf der Tastatur austauschen,
die ich überlasse mit Erlang.
Erlang-Example-Code, passt mal auf.
Merk...
Die wenigsten können Rust programmieren vom EQ her.
Rust ist wirklich 150 EQ+.
Wir machen heute den Label-Champ weiter.
Passt mal auf, ich habe da einige schon eingebaut.
Ihr werdet begeistert sein, was der Label-Champ
jetzt champen kann schon.
Perl.
Hat jemand von euch mal Perl programmieren müssen
die letzten 10 Jahre?
Ich nicht.
Perl ist out.
Absolut räudig, ja das stimmt.
Rust geht voll klar.
Wenn du 150 EQ und mehr hast, bestimmt.
Rust ist nice, aber Rust...
Na gut, ohne es jetzt zu übertreiben.
Du brauchst natürlich keine 150 EQ-Punkte,
das ist klar.
Aber Rust ist wirklich erstmal
Hardcore-Gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Bis du dich dran gewöhnt hast,
dass der Borrow-Checker, heißt es ja bei Rust,
wie das tickt.
Also du musst dich bei Rust wirklich dran gewöhnen,
dass du dir schon während du programmierst
Gedanken zu machst,
wie lange ist die Variable gültig,
wann geht das aus dem Scope,
was weiß ich, wie lange läuft der Thread
oder ist das vielleicht dann irgendwie noch
zugänglich die Variable, obwohl das Objekt
schon aufgeräumt wird.
Da könnt ihr euch nämlich von ausgehen,
der lässt euch das einfach nicht kompilieren,
wenn da sowas drin ist.
Das ist ja auch gerade das Innovative
und das Coole an Rust.
Rust schafft das,
halbwegs memory-sicher zu sein,
nur mit Compile-Time-Checks.
Was heißt nur mit, das stimmt nicht.
Also es geht nicht alles, ja,
aber sag mal, zum größten Teil
safe zu sein ohne Runtime-Checks,
nur mit Compile-Time-Checks.
Das ist ja quasi gerade
der riesen Vorteil an Rust
und warum die mittlerweile auch in Firefox
so viel mit Rust machen,
was eigentlich eine gute Sache ist.
Ich mein, vor allem schützt dich das nicht.
Also wenn du jetzt eine Konsolen-Anwendung hast
und sagst, bitte geben sie eine Zahl ein
und du gibst fünf ein und du greifst
auf den fünften Index in deinem Array zu
und den gibt es nicht, dann,
und du bestehst auch drauf,
ich will da drauf zugreifen,
dann crash dir das auch, ja.
Aber das ist ja meistens gar nicht das Problem,
wenn es irgendwie crasht.
Problematisch sind die Sachen,
die nicht crashen und sich anders verhalten
als geplant, das ist ja meistens das Problem.
Einfach crashen ist oftmals nicht das Problem.
Was mir bei Rust, ich hab Rust,
gerade als das neu war,
war ich so, kurzzeitig auf so richtigen
Rust-Trips, das hört sich jetzt nach Drogen
nebenan oder so, aber ich hab da,
ich fand das richtig, richtig nice.
Aber ich hab da nach einer Weile aufgehört,
Sachen in Rust zu machen,
weil es mir zu anstrengend war.
Rust, aber was ich an Rust
immer noch ein bisschen Gewöhnungs...
ein bisschen Gewöhnungsbedürftig finde,
ist manch eines Sonntags, ja.
Allein schon, wenn man hier sowas sieht,
also...
Ja.
Und das wird noch schlimmer.
Gerade wenn du Struts hast und dann
Lifetime von Objekten kennzeichnen musst in Rust,
es ist schon anstrengend.
Dafür hat es den Vorteil, dass du die
meisten Sachen mit Compile-Time-Checks
abgefackelt hast.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen, Alter, Pearl.
Ach so, wir haben ja gesagt, wir wollen uns
das Video zu Julien Behrmann gucken.
Trotz 3FA, nicht nur...
Okay, letzte Abendshandlung heute,
dann gehe ich was essen.
So sind wir stehengeblieben.
Gehackt, trotz 3FA, wie konnte das passieren?
Lassen wir uns jetzt mal von einem
Profi-Hackerman erklären.
Was für ein Song?
Was?
Ja.
Da würde mich halt mal interessieren,
was hatte der denn für 3FA?
Wie kannst du bei YouTube überhaupt
3FA machen?
Lass mal überlegen.
Passwort login, dann irgendeine Form
von 2FA, wahrscheinlich SMS,
aber was?
Kann man sagen,
Ubiqui, das kannst du...
Geht das in Kombination?
Ja gut, für dein Passwort
könntest du das vielleicht machen.
Du könntest dein Passwort in irgendeinem
Key-Save speichern, den du mit deinem
Ubiqui anloggst oder so.
Oder geht das für Google-Login?
Okay, das weiß ich nicht, dass das geht.
Das ist gut.
Kann man da 3 Sachen einschalten?
Hab ich mir noch nie angeguckt.
Google-Login, can Ubiqui?
Ja, als zusätzlich zum Passwort
oder als quasi zum Einfügen des
Passworts oder als zusätzlichen Faktor.
Okay, ja das ist nice.
Dann machst du sowas
plus Passwort plus SMS
oder Authenticator-App oder so.
Aber das bringt dir alles nichts,
wenn einer deine Session-Cookies klaut
oder sowas.
Oder du irgendeinen Rootkit-Bag
oder sonst was hast,
der einfach deinen Browser verwendet.
Dann musst du ja nichts klauen in dem Sinn.
Dann wäre es natürlich sinnvoll zu sagen,
du kannst das mal neu einloggen.
Die Sache ist bloß die.
Da sind wir wieder beim Thema
Bequemlichkeit versus Bedienbarkeit.
Aber gucken wir erst mal sein Video weiter.
Aber was ist überhaupt passiert?
In der Nacht vom 18.04.2022
wurden mehrere Accounts eines großen YouTubers gehackt.
Die Profilbilder und die Namen wurden
in ARK Invest umbenannt.
Ja, sowas hatte der M-Core.
Sowas ähnliches hatte der M-Core ja auch
bei sich auf dem Channel.
Da haben wir irgendwelche Kryptos scammed.
Shit.
Dass bei einem YouTube-Kanal
mit weit über 5 Millionen Abonnenten
kein Verifizierungshaken mehr vorhanden ist,
deutet bereits darauf hin,
dass hier etwas nicht stimmt.
Dieser Haken zeigt nämlich nicht nur,
dass man viele Follower hat,
sondern auch, dass man sich von YouTube
hat verifizieren lassen.
Das heißt, man hat eine gewisse Anstrengung
unternommen, um nachzuweisen,
dass man der ist, der man zu sein vorgibt.
Und genau dieser Identitätsnachweis
spielt in der digitalen Welt
eine sehr wichtige Rolle.
Verlässt man sich nämlich beispielsweise
nur auf ein Passwort im Identitätsnachweis,
dann ist das ein sehr schwacher Schutz,
denn jeder, der dieses Passwort kennt,
kann sich für dich ausgeben.
Julien Bam hat in einem Tweet jedoch angedeutet,
dass er eine 3-Faktor-Authentisierung nutzt.
Was das ist und welche Rückschlüsse
man daraus auf das tatsächliche Gefahrenpotenzial
ziehen kann, klären wir gleich.
Zuvor schauen wir uns noch einmal an,
was die Hacker mit ARK Invest bezwecken wollten.
Nun, sie haben einen Livestream gestartet
und alle Follower...
Ja, das lief beim M-Core ja auch.
Irgendwelche, wie sagt man so?
Kryptobros.
Die Kanäle wurden dann entsprechend informiert,
in dem unter anderem Elon Musk zu sehen war.
Den Kerl haben sie gerne dabei.
Der wirkt für viele Leute halt so
nach Innovation und Kompetenz.
Und man macht den irgendwo rein,
womit er überhaupt nichts zu tun hat.
Und dann denkt man so, oh krasser Elon Musk,
dann machen wir das jetzt auch.
Dem es wohl darum ging, seine Bitcoins zu vermehren.
Man sollte seinen Krypto manieren,
eine bestimmte Adresse versenden
und es wurde versprochen, dass man das Doppelte
wieder zurückbekommt.
Das ist ja fast ein bisschen wie...
Fall da bitte, bitte nicht drauf rein.
Das ist Scam.
Diese Masche wurde in der Vergangenheit schon
mehrfach angewendet.
Ich weiß nicht, aber in letzter Zeit sind diese
Krypto-Scams...
Was hat der Typ erzählt bei Bitconnect?
Das war doch genau der gleiche Shit.
Ziemlich populär.
Wenn du so einen Kommentar bei mir auf dem Kanal
sehen solltest, bitte sofort melden.
Ich kümmere mich darum, dass die schnellst
möglichst entfernt werden.
Aber woher weiß man eigentlich, dass es sich bei dem
betroffenen Account um den von Julien Bam handelt?
Schließlich wurden alle Videos
auf dem Kanal gelöscht und nur der Livestream
mit mehr als 20.000 Zuschauern
um 5.05 Uhr... Wahrscheinlich wieder
wreckt das auch der alte Name noch.
... über 31.000 Likes hatte, war zu sehen.
Ganz einfach.
Klickt man sich ein bisschen durch die Taps und landet
bei Community, dann sieht man an den Inhalten,
das hier früher offenbar einmal Julien Bam
gepostet hat.
Hier waren die Scammer wohl nicht gründlich genug.
Scrollt man ein bisschen durch die abonnierten
Kanäle, stellt man fest, dass es einen weiteren
Kanal namens ARK Invest gibt,
der 1,85 Millionen Abonnenten
besitzt. Das war einmal Julien Bam's
Zweitkanal mit dem Namen
Boolean Jam, der ebenfalls übernommen wurde.
Dass gleich mehrere Kanäle von
ihm betroffen sind, wird bei der Problemanalyse
noch einmal wichtig.
Ja, deutsch wirklich darauf hin, dass er sich irgendwas eingefangen hat.
... YouTube-Support aufgenommen. Seine Kanäle,
Julien Bam und Boolean Jam,
gehören in allem Anschein nach wohl wieder ihm.
Zumindest tragen sie wieder ihren ursprünglichen
Namen. Die Inhalte sind...
Warum schreibt der Boolean
mit U und nicht
mit 2 O?
... noch nicht wieder hergestellt worden, was natürlich einen erheblichen
finanziellen Schaden verursacht...
... und ich habe während meiner YouTube-Pause
im März im Schnitt 200.000 Aufrufe
pro Monat auf meine Videos erhalten.
Obwohl ich nichts hochgeladen habe.
Welche Dimension das bei den beiden Kanälen
von Julien Bam hat, möchte ich mir gar nicht
ausmalen. Von daher wünsche ich dir,
Julien, dass die Videos so schnell
wie möglich hergestellt werden.
Wenn das eins nicht war, dann 30+.
Frag mal 30+, Leute, ob
die verstanden haben, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Ich werde sonst die Robbe machen. Nee, aber Spaß
beiseite. Ich wünsche dir wirklich alles Gute.
Kommen wir nun zu der eigentlichen Frage
dieses Videos. Wobei, nee, er hätte es eigentlich
so schreiben müssen. Boolean. Nichts.
Schreibt man ja gar nicht mit I. So hätte er es einschreiben
müssen. YouTube bzw.
Social Media Accounts, hier speziell von
Julien Bam, überhaupt gehackt werden.
Nun, in meinem Video, wie Hacker
Passwörter knacken, habe ich in der Vergangenheit
30... Poste das nachher in der Wendler Telegram
Gruppe.
Welche Angriffsmöglichkeiten ist für Passwörter?
Gibt es das überhaupt noch? Ich habe
gehört, Xavier Naidoo ist jetzt wieder
angeblich
geläutert zurück und
hat sich
wieder, wieder angeblich
auf den rechten
Fahrt zurückbewegt, habe ich gelesen.
Keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich ist ihm einfach
nur das Geld ausgegangen.
Kurz nach diesem Video ereignete sich im Frühjahr
2020 der berühmt berüchtigte
Mercedes-Hack, bei dem der Instagram
Account der Automarke von einem Hacker
namens Katz übernommen wurde.
Und dort unter anderem Bilder von Montana Black
gepostet wurden. Im Vergleich
zu diesem Video.
Warum ausgerechnet Montana Black
Bilder?
Ich meine, okay, immer noch besser als
Krypto-Scam. Dazu wurde bei der Übernahme
der YouTube-Kanäle von Julien Bam
hier in richtig großem Stil Scam
betrieben, nämlich den Livestream mit
mehreren tausend Zuschauern, der zu allem
übergespont... Der gleiche Scam lief bei
M-Core auch auf dem Channel. Dass sehr viele
wahrscheinlich gebotete Likes hatte und
Elon Musk zu sehen war, gibt es bestimmt
den ein oder anderen, der auf die dahinter steckende
Webseite war. Das stimmt. Dass Julien Bam
unvorsichtig bei der Sicherung seiner Social-Media-Kanäle
war, halte ich für sehr unwahrscheinlich,
da in seinem Tweet ein YouTube von
einer 3 Factor aussehen ist. Also ich denke
auch mal, dass er nach Möglichkeit das gemacht
hat, was er machen konnte, so als
ja vielleicht nicht so Ultra-Technik
affiner. Übrigens, auf der anderen
Seite ist es immer die Abwägung zwischen
Bequemlichkeit versus Sicherheit.
Ich glaube, die wenigsten
Leute werden es so
einstellen, dass beim Schließen
des Browsers quasi die
Cookies gelöscht werden bzw.
die Sachen gelöscht werden, dass beim nächsten
Öffnen des Browsers man sich wieder neu
einloggen muss und sowas. Das wäre
sinnvoll. Das sollte ich eigentlich
auch so machen, ja.
Ich glaube, ich mache das jetzt auch so.
Sicher ist sicher. Ich mache mir
einen extra Browser für YouTube und Social-Media,
der automatisch sich
klärt nach dem Schließen.
...
Eigentlich ein guter Anstoß
dafür.
Ich gebe dir eine Woche. Ja, ich weiß genau, ich werde es
wahrscheinlich nicht lange verwenden,
weil es ist halt einfach das, was ich eben
gesagt habe. Du musst abwägen zwischen
Bequemlichkeit und Sicherheit.
Und spätestens wenn es dich so abfuckt,
dann wirst du
leichtsinnig beim Eingeben der Passwörter
oder aber du schaltest es wieder aus.
...vielen von euch dürfte die
Drei-Faktor-Authentisierung ein Begriff sein.
Dabei wird zusätzlich zum Passwort
ein weiterer Mechanismus eingesetzt,
mit dem man seine Identität nachweisen kann.
... an dem ich mich anmelden möchte
und muss dann nach Vorforderung
dort draufklicken.
Eine Drei-Faktor-Authentisierung ergänzt
den Identitätsnachweis um einen weiteren
Faktor, der im Optimalfall aus der
dritten Kategorie stammt, also zum Beispiel
ein Fingerabdruck, ein Retina-Scan
oder irgendetwas anderes, was in die Kategorie
biologischer Authentifizierung fällt.
Das könnt ihr aber auch sehen.
Wisst ihr was witzig ist?
Zu Zeiten bevor das so angesagt war,
in den ganzen Filmen
haben die Leute immer
Scan gemacht, da wurden Augen gescannt
und was auch immer.
Niemand macht das heute so, außer im
Sonderfall. Das meiste ist
sowas wie
gerade wenn es um einfachen Gesichtserkennung
oder irgendwelche klassischen
Varianten.
Vielleicht auch noch Finger.
Aber
also die wenigsten haben so eine
Authentifizierung, wie sich das damals beispielsweise
Mission Impossible oder sowas vorgestellt
hat. Von Augenscannen
bis sonstige Dinger.
Da macht kaum einer.
Ist Local Storage
nicht sicherer gegen Angriffe
als Cookies? Das kommt im Prinzip
aufs Gleiche raus.
Das macht eigentlich, würde ich jetzt mal
sagen, macht pauschal gesehen keinen
großen Unterschied.
Ob du jetzt den Local Storage
verwendest oder Cookies.
Wenn jemand
irgendein Trojaner, Rootkit, was auch
immer auf deinem Rechner hat
und im Zweifelsfall
dein Rechner fernsteuern kann,
dann ist es eh egal.
Weil dann macht er einfach dein
Browser auf, sei es
im Hintergrund, oder zieht sich
das komplett ab inklusive
deinem kompletten Profil.
Oder macht im Zweifelsfall einfach deinen Browser auf
und geht auf die Seite.
Also...
Umgangen werden, müsste man nicht Zugriff
auf alle Geräte von Julien Bam haben
und diese Sicherheitsmarke... Einfach nur
hashes das Login in den Local Storage schreiben.
Ja, und was hast du dann davon, wenn du es nicht
überprüfen kannst?
Also, es ist ja nicht so, als
wird dann da
irgendwie nochmal neu autonifiziert
oder sowas.
Beim Login, ja, aber es ist ja nicht
so, dass du das Login-Passwort irgendwie speicherst.
Wenn du Passwörter übermittelst, dann
machst du das in der Regel ja nur mit einem Hasch.
Dann sagst du,
hey, ich nehme das Passwort
lokal am besten,
hasche das,
schicke den Hasch rüber,
beziehungsweise ich schicke
noch, falls das notwendig ist,
die Hasch-Methode mit.
Der Server macht das
gleiche, der nimmt die gleiche
Hasching-Methode,
nimmt das Passwort, hascht das
und guckt, ob es rauskommt.
Oder aber, was noch viel besser ist,
du hast auf der Server-Seite
nur den Hasch gespeichert.
So sollte man das eigentlich machen.
Also, du hast gar keine Passwörter auf Server-Seite.
Das machen leider zu wenige.
Mittlerweile dürfte es hoffentlich Standard
sein, aber es kommt oft genug irgendwelche
Datenleaks raus, wo dann
im Endeffekt rauskommt, ach nee, guck mal,
die haben trotzdem Passwörter im Klartext gespeichert.
Sollte Hasch am besten,
ja, wobei der Salt ja nicht secret ist.
Das muss man ja dabei sagen.
Damit das funktioniert, muss der Salt
bekannt sein, ja.
Der Salt ist einzig und allein aus dem Grund da,
dass du, dass das
vorberechnen schwieriger wird.
Salt muss public sein,
sonst funktioniert das nicht.
Aber du kannst halt nicht, nicht, nicht, nicht
vorberechnen.
Also der Salt macht es im Prinzip,
das Verfahren nicht sicherer.
Das sorgt nur dafür, dass du weniger Sachen
im Vorfeld vorberechnen kannst.
Ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht so genau.
Die fragen öfters mal bei
verdächtigen Aktivitäten nach.
Ich weiß nicht anhand, anhand
was die das feststellen,
was die da feststellen,
was die da feststellen.
Anhand was die das festmachen.
Vielleicht machen die das ja fest daran,
wie lange du schon eingeloggt bist,
wenn quasi deine Session schon
drei Tage läuft, dann nicht, aber wenn du dich
vor 15 Minuten erst eingeloggt hast, dann nicht,
keine Ahnung.
Maßnahmen zum Gehen? Nicht unbedingt.
Hier wäre interessant zu erfahren,
welche Faktoren Julien Bam für seine
drei Faktor-Authentisierungen nutzt
und ob er sie bei jeder Anmeldung neu
eingeben muss. Ich muss diese Schritte
beispielsweise nur dann noch einmal durchführen,
wenn ich eine neue IP-Adresse zugewiesen
bekommen habe oder mich von einem
anderen Rechner aus mit meinem Google-Konto
registrieren möchte. Und natürlich
auch dann, wenn ich mich auf meinem Rechner abmelde
und erneut anmelde.
Doch auch das kann man ausschalten.
Ich denke nicht, dass Julien Bam jedes Mal,
wenn er zum Beispiel ein Video hochlädt,
auf einen Kommentar antwortet oder Änderungen
an seinem Kanaldesign durchführt,
seine drei Faktor-Authentisierung durchführen
muss. Nee, aber ich meine,
was ja auch noch möglich wäre. Also ich weiß nicht,
wie das ist, wenn du Kanalnamen änderst und sowas.
Also das wäre natürlich sinnvoll, da prinzipiell
nochmal Passwort bzw.
Wobei Passwort haben die garantiert rausbekommen.
Passwort alleine reicht nicht.
Die müssten wirklich komplette
Triple-Faktor dann nochmal durchmachen.
Passwort alleine reicht nicht,
weil das Passwort von ihm haben die Typen
innerhalb der ersten 15 Minuten mitgelockt.
...
Das ist kein Ding. Die müssten
theoretisch nochmal komplett
alles neu abfragen,
wenn du Kanalnamen änderst und so.
Das wird es dann auf jeden Fall schwieriger machen.
...
Was was geht und was nicht geht auf julian bams rechner hätten was mithilfe eigentlich auch ein unding auf youtube oder sie sonst irgendwie
Und die typen die sich die videos dann probe angucken haben doch von tuten und blasen keine ahnung die wir session übernehmen konnten
würde das erklären wie sie den schutz der drei fakte authentisierung umgehen konnten
doch nicht nur die session sondern auch der browser könnte gehyper und eventuell gespeicherte passwörter automatisiert
ausgelesen also ich gehe davon aus ich habe keine ahnung davon
ich gehe davon aus der hat sich schlicht und ergreifend irgendwas eingefangen auf seinem rechner und
Weiß man nicht wie weit reichen das war von keylogger bis theoretisch komplett remote steuerung möglich
Und so wird das funktioniert haben wie ich in meinem video die passwörter in modernen web browsers gezeigt habe sind dafür noch nicht einmal
programmierkenntnisse erforderlich deshalb solltest du unbedingt die passwörter von allen deinen online accounts ändern
mit einem so genannten sim swapping angriff bei dem sich ein hacker der mobilfunknummer seines opfers wenn auch nur
kurzfristig bemächtigt kann er den schutz der beispielsweise durch den versand eines zeitlich begrenzten einmal codes an das smartphone des betroffenen entsteht
ausgehebelt werden jack dorsey der ceo von twitter wurde 2019 mit genau dieser technik gehackt
dass alle accounts von julie beim stürm ich erinnere mich wurden darauf hin
Wie genau sim swapping funktioniert werde ich dir ebenfalls zeitnah in einem video erklären
Es könnte auch sein dass es einen technischen fehler bei der implementierung der drei fakten auf seiten von youtube gibt oder die hacker ein
zero-day exploit ausgenutzt haben das glaube ich das halte ich aber für eher unwahrscheinlich
Sonst vermute ich mehrere accounts unterschiedlich das ist das letzte also ganz ehrlich das ist immer das letzte wovon ich ausgehen würde
Also quasi alle wo die accounts mal weg waren oder temporär weg waren haben immer gesagt so nach dem oder ich wurde gehackt ich habe hier was auch
Immer das das das an ich habe niemand mein password gesagt dass das das muss irgendwo ein fehler bei google sein das glaube ich nicht
Also weder facebook login noch google login noch microsoft login oder sonst was
würde ich pauschal davon ausgehen dass die grundlegende schwächen haben sonst hätte wenn hätten wir ganz andere probleme und ganz andere
Tragweite der der probleme
also und wenn einer jetzt mal ernsthaft wenn einer ein google
alternative oder google login zero day hat ich glaube da wird er nicht unbedingt
auf öffentlichkeitswirksam den account von julian bann
übernehmen
Also lieber julian hier sind meine tipps bitte überprüfe umgehend alle deine geräte auf malware
Es kann gut sein dass ich auf einem oder mehrer deiner geräte ein trojaner als ein spionage programm befindet
Wenn du magst unterstütze ich dich gerne dabei
Setze von einem anderen rechner der am besten noch gar nicht benutzt wurde alles neu auf
Ändere deine passwörter auf allen accounts die du aktuell im internet verwendest
Wenn sich auf deinem rechner ein trojaner befindet der beispielsweise durch solche engineering verbracht worden sein könnte
könnten diese zugangsdaten ebenfalls ausgespäht worden sein
informiere freunde und kontakte die in deinem adressbuch stehen dass sie nicht auf links
Das ist tatsächlich von deiner ja das ist tatsächlich wichtig gerade wenn du irgendwie
Dir was eingefangen hast was dann deine bekannten anspämmt oder so das ist tatsächlich wichtig weil du hast da so viele leute
Denken so klicken wir mal truff der max hat was geschickt so nach dem motto das ist tatsächlich wichtig und vor allem
der kerl hat halt fünf millionen abos oder so also
Allein schon da ist es halt riesig groß dass das missbrauchspotenzial
dass deine accounts verschickt werden zumindest solange bis die gefahr gebannt ist
Entferne alle berichte weil überlegt euch mal überlegt euch mal kass was ich twitter account von montana bleck wäre weg ja und er würde ein link posten
Was weiß ich was ist denn so typischer typischer aktiv digger und dann irgendein link dahinter
Da würden tausende leute auf den link klicken und wenn das dann halbwegs plausibel ist was man auf dem link sieht
Findest du die ein oder anderen leute die sich scammen lassen und der ganze kram hat sich schon gelohnt
Deswegen ist wichtig dass man wirklich dass da möglichkeit wenn man noch mögt wenn man noch gerade als influencer die möglichkeit hat irgendwie auf anderen plattform
Da was was kund zu tun dass die leute aufpassen sollen
Ja digger bestes casino genau
Haben und füge sie sofern du den quellen vertraust schrittweise wieder hinzu
Manchmal kann nämlich der hack einer drittanbieter app dafür sorgen dass sich das problem auf die damit verknüpften kanäle ausweitet
Ich beispielsweise gebe nur ganz ganz wenigen apps lesenden zugriff auf bestimmte bereiche meines youtube kanals und
Überhaupt gar keine app schreiben den zugriff
Ich auch nicht hin und wieder neu in deinem google konto an damit ein übernommen
Das stimmt ja zuviel schaden anrichtet es ist nicht verkehrt und das werde ich ab sofort auch machen wenn man sich so einmal täglich
Abmeldet ja gute vorsätze mal gucken
Ich habe so meine zweifel ob man das wirklich durchhält
Das beste wäre eigentlich du machst ein browser der komplett löscht
Beim schließen aber tja wer macht das schon
Und zum schluss aber das hast du ja bereits gelesen
Halte deine follower auf dem laufenden informiere sie darüber was passiert ist nicht gerade mit großer reichweite ist es wichtig für das internet zu steigern
Dann hast du von den übernommenen accounts bei julian bama. Ihr habt mir gerade geschrieben dass dass julian bama
Ein video hochgeladen hat zu dieser sache vor einer halben stunde wir schauen jetzt legit mein erstes da war es doch
Ich habe mir gerade geschrieben dass julian bama
Da war es doch
Juckt mich nicht ok ich habe noch nie in meinem leben ein julian bama video geguckt
Premiere 17 minuten alter
Ok so so so so so so test test test test
test weird champ warum hat er sein audio equipment nicht ordentlich eingerichtet als krasser influencer man
Boah ich weiß gar nicht wo ich anfangen soll aber
Fazit ich mag deutsche influencer nicht ich kriege anfälle wenn ich die sprechweise schon sehe man
Egal da muss ich jetzt durch leute
Vorweg das waren auf jeden fall die schlimmsten tage die schlimmste woche für uns alle hier und vor allem für mich
Das glaube ich die kanäle ja auch gegründet habe wer gerade das glaube ich eben wir das ist das ist mega belastend das kann ich mir vorstellen
Ja da geht er also da geht er wie sagen sie da geht er der arsch wirklich auf grundeis bei sowas ja und gehackt richtig
Mies gehackt
So viele negative konsequenzen für alles was wir hier auf dieser plattform gemacht haben und es war die hölle es war wirklich die
Das glaube ich ja
Richtig mies digger das glaube ich ihm da geht er wirklich der arsch auf grundeis
Da stürzen sie sich alle drauf wieder
Sonntag nachts der 17.4 ich komme hier nochmal rein wollte so in ruhe alleine
Noch ein paar da geht in der arsch auf grundeis ja weiter auf entspannten mein pc wurde auf einmal immer lauter und lauter und immer lauter und ich
dachte echt was
Arbeite auf entspannt
Alles klar los ein hubschrauber landet neben mir die lüfter am durchdrehen ich so voll panisch macht das
Am die typen noch irgendwelche bitcoins gemeint oder was guck erst mal was verbraucht denn hier meine komplette leistung und auf einmal mein pc so
Ganz leise wieder ich so okay chillig beängstigend aber auch chillig das ist ein ding ich finde das ich finde das tatsächlich gut dass er das gemerkt hat
weil
Das habe ich das habe ich auch schon mal das habe ich auch schon mal in dem video gesagt es hat seinen grund warum ich immer
einen process manager offen habe
Ich habe einen process manager offen und ich habe auch schon öfters in videos gesagt es ist nicht schlauchig
Zu wissen was oder standard wie soll man sagen so oder der standard workflow workload sonst was auf seinem rechner ist dass man
Abweichungen davon erkennt ich gebe zu das ist heutzutage relativ schwierig
Es ist normal dass ich jetzt hier mal der google updater startet es normal dass man das dotnet framework im hintergrund irgendwas macht
Es ist normal dass irgendwie mal irgendwie steam updates laufen oder sonst wo aber man sollte misstrauisch
werden gerade und die meisten können sich natürlich besser verstecken aber gerade wenn auf einmal
neue dinger in der task liste auftauchen so nach dem motto was ist das
bisschen dumm daran ist dass mittlerweile unter windows standardmäßig schon so viel shit läuft dass du gar nicht durchblickst
und dann irgendwelche dinger hast wie keine ahnung was zum teufel ist der moh
der was
ich hab vergessen hier der moh uso coreworker was ist das ich habe keine ahnung was ist der
was ist der
da hätte ich jetzt zum beispiel schon mal bedenken wenn ich dieses ding sehe was zum teufel ist das
für windows updates was geschiss alter ja das ist heute bisschen schwierig das rauszubekommen weil windows auch mal gerne im hintergrund
dinger starten von denen ihr nie was gesehen hat obvius was das ist ja ja aber es ist trotzdem nicht verkehrt es ist nicht verkehrt
und das ist gut dass ihm das gleich instinktiv aufgefallen ist das finde ich nice also das viele merken das nicht
ja wieder zu mein pc auf einmal wieder komplett am ausrasten ich dachte es explodiert gleich in mein gesicht werde neu geboren als two face macht task
was zum teufel
was zum teufel manager wieder auf suche diese scheiße die gerade hier mein pc meine lüfter so in in in nutzung hochtreibt
und nichts gefunden einfach als wäre da irgendetwas in meinem computer gewesen was aber nicht gefunden werden wollte
und smart oder auch eher das gegenteil unwissen wie ich nun mal bin in diesen ganzen computer gedöns habe ich halt einfach den task manager offen gelassen damit ich halt abarbeiten kann
ich mache mein stuff fertig habe beide auch nur in docks gearbeitet nichts am besten wäre jetzt tatsächlich gewesen einfach stecker raus
bc belastet und irgendwann computer aus homgegang pen am pennen am penden am pennen ich habe gepennt ein bisschen weitergepennt
und dann bin ich halt aufgewacht irgendwann montag montags ostermontag by the way guck auf mein handy erste nachricht die ich gesehen habe von sascha unsympathisch tv
und dann mir geschrieben wurde dein channel gehackt und ich so ist das jetzt irgendwie so ein prank oder das ist ja das schlimme dass du mittlerweile
in den influencer kreisen als erstes mal dran denken muss wenn ich den bekannter anruft fuck der prank mich challenge und warum schreibt ihr mir das um 5 ich hasse influencer
nicht influencer so dieses was soll ich sagen so dieses diese ganze influencer denkweise und sowas das ist so schlimm das erste stell dir mal vor wie kacke das ist
das schlimmste was du dir denken musst ist wenn ich den bekannter anruft prankt er mich jetzt was ein müll alter morgens guck mal wie kaputt ich schon mittlerweile bin
im kopf bin wie sensibilisiert ich für solche themen bin dass ich das gar nicht glaube am anfang und dann schreibt mir sowas gut das ist fast normal würde ich sagen
keiner würde keiner würde erst mal instinktiv sagen ja ja hier channel gehackt ja ja muss so sein dann würde ich sagen hä wie kann das sein
ich war doch gestern abend noch eingeloggt aber schlimm dass man als erstes an prank denkt das schon richtig klug auf einmal dasselbe genug schreibt mir
maxi schreibt mir immer mehr schreiben wir nicht so auf einmal das scheint so zu sein ich gehe sofort auf die kanäle und frag mich erst mal so was macht ilon mask auf
meinem channel irgend so ein weirder fremder stream läuft auf allen meinen channels julian bam boolean jam und auch mich nicht die video beschreibungen voll mit
konnte er sich noch einloggen das würde mich jetzt interessieren konnte er sich selbst noch einloggen oder nicht scammy links wer da drauf geklickt hat der tut mir wirklich leid weil er hat wahrscheinlich
eher geld verloren und alle unsere videos waren weg und ich so oh mein gott und dann gegen die scheiße erst richtig los es war klar irgendjemand hat sich in unsere youtube kanäle eingehackt ich
call thomas thomas wusste schon bescheid thomas war schon im haus er lockt sich ein bei youtube klappt jetzt geht aber schlage auf schlag hier dann parallel haben wir noch versucht youtube zu
erreichen war ein bisschen schwierig weil ich auch oster montag immer schwierig youtube zu erreicht und ich habe dann auch angefangen die passwörter zu ändern lock mich ein ich finde das ich finde das beruhigen das ist sogar für ihn schwierig
ist youtube zu erreichen aber so mein instagram profilbild wurde gerade gelöscht und ich so ruft zu thomas hoch macht sofort alle pc aus thomas perplex macht die ganzen pc aus ich koppel mich von allen geräten aus
im wlan raus komplett ja ja gut aber tatsächlich manchmal manchmal ist die beste feierwoll die zange gut man muss nicht die zange nehmen aber man kann einfach stecker rausziehen ja manchmal ist das tatsächlich wenn du
keine ahnung hast was sache ist ich mein schlimmer machst du es damit wahrscheinlich nicht weil mir eingefallen ist dass ich mich vor kurzer zeit auf irgendeinem rechner über den browser auf instagram angemeldet habe und da wurde mir bewusst
dass ich nicht über youtube eingehackt über ein unserer rechner deswegen hatte er auch zugriff auf instagram und das heißt der sieht ja jede änderung von jedem password weil er halt immer noch auf dem rechner ist erst mal mit mobile daten mails
gecheckt keine mehrfach authentifizierungs email kein kein fremdes gerät erkannt eine fremde ip oder whatsoever alles ganz normal deswegen hat auch eine dreifaktor authentifizierung gar nichts gebracht weil der typ das oder weil der hack das programm
ja dann ist es im prinzip so wie wir das vorhin vermutet haben sie haben sich irgendwas auf ihren rechner eingefangen wie gesagt wahrscheinlich nicht mal die session geklaut sondern wirklich irgendwas zum remote steuern vom rechner drauf gehabt dann ist er eh vorbei dann hast du eh gelitten
im seelenfrieden vom rechner aus quasi gemacht hat weil wir halt schon eingeloggt waren auf diversen webseiten und das normal ist weil man eine seite bei der man sich 50 mal am tag einloggt man da halt auch er eingeloggt bleibt für eine längere zeit ist normal
ja macht jeder so weil jetzt auch anders geregelt haben ok weiter gehts jemand anderes aus meinem team kommt macht pc an lässt wie gesagt die sind einfach der unterschied bequemlichkeit versus security und du wirst du hältst es nicht durch jedes mal nicht neu einzuloggen du flippst aus im kopf
program laufen 172 trojaner gefunden die hälfte davon am mann was einen also was was was mein point was das wird das halte ich jetzt aber sich mal am tag einloggt man da halt auch er eingeloggt bleibt für eine längere zeit ist normal obwohl wir das mittlerweile jetzt auch anders geregelt haben ok weiter gehts jemand anderes aus meinem team kommt macht pc an lässt malware program laufen 172 trojaner gefunden
die hälfte davon am mann also crypto mining das heißt die haben unsere kanäle nicht nur als werbefläche genutzt für ihren scam shit sondern auch unsere grafikarten um crypto zu meinen also wenn schon richtig ja wenn schon richtig und wobei man sagen muss das ist ganz schön dumm ehrlich gesagt crypto zu meinen weil was ist das
ziel ja möchtest du leute scammen überjis juhtube oder möchtest du entdeckt werden es ist jetzt nicht so als könntest du mit crypto min was sind nicht viel geld verdienen in den paar stunden bis tage bis du das merken also eigentlich
paar stunden bis tagen bis sie das merken also eigentlich ist crypto
meinung ziemlich dumm in dem fall jetzt gewesen weil das ist das was dann im
endeffekt auffällt ja wenn ein rechner so wirkt als als ist er am abheben wie der
hubschrauber oder er funktioniert immer richtig weil er zu 99 prozent crypto
meint dann werden die leute noch misstrauisch in der regel würde man
eigentlich von ausgehen dass er sich hätte verstecken wollen
vielleicht hat er vorher schon krypto meiner drauf gehabt ja habe mit krypto
schon seit antivirus programme noch heute sinnvoll oder reicht die winners
firewall aus der winners defender reicht genug
rest brauchen wir nicht in den monaten nichts mehr zu tun weil ich hodl ich
mache kein day trading ich investiere auch nicht in irgendwelche komischen
ich hodl einfach nur und das war so und das mache ich auch nicht von diesem
rechner hier aus und generell bin ich immer sehr sicher im internet unterwegs
ich meine ich mache das ganze hier hauptberuflich schon seit mehreren
mehreren jahren so ich gehe nicht auf irgendwelche klick nicht auf irgendwelche
werbe pop ups wo ich der eine millionste gewinner bin zu der zeit hatten wir
mittlerweile schon jemand von youtube erreicht der in england war und deswegen
auch nur mit begrenzten möglichkeiten am start war aber der hat uns auf jeden
fall schon ein bisschen geholfen und konnte uns auch sagen dass solche
hackerangriffe oftmals auf feiertage geplant werden weil da der support der
seite natürlich am geringsten ist habe ich gespürt habe sogar angefangen auf
lo also nachvollziehbare taktik ja klingt logisch twitter und auf instagram
parlava zu machen und irgendwen von jude zu erreichen weil es so schwierig war
es war ein ding der unmöglichkeit sowas mache ich gar nicht du bist schon echt
tief ins herz stechen dass ich solche leute tag aber dagegen spricht dass er
dann krypto meinen auf den rechnern ach hilfe rufe so und wenn sie nicht
entdeckt werden wollen auf jeden fall waren die einzigen die uns dann helfen
konnten die letztendlich auch so die die magischen regler haben in
anführungszeichen natürlich gesetzt youtube usa und die waren schwierig zu
erreichen denn aufgrund der zeitverschiebung waren die halt noch am
schlafen der ganze tag einfach die reinste magma hölle neuigkeiten keine
neuigkeiten hin und wieder her also dass das mittlerweile dass das mega belastend
für ihn ist will ich nicht bezweifeln das kann ich mir gut vorstellen kann ich
mich auch gut rein versetzt das abfakt dass da geht er wie gesagt der arsch
aufgrund als ja das verstehe wir auch unseren partner manager marco erreicht
der vieles in die wege geleitet hat der es auch geschafft dass sie richtigen
wichtigen informationen zu den richtigen wichtigen leuten kommt und die meinten
dann aber das ist ein unglaublich komplizierter case und ich so
scheiße so am abschließen mit dem kanal ich so wie wird mein vierter kanal
heißen müssen und war in den letzten acht jahre umsonst sind die ganzen videos
weg ich habe mich so motivationslos gefühlt wie noch nie ich da so an die
decke und so jeder frame ich hätte da gar keine zeit mich in dem in der
situation motivationslos dafür zu fühlen ich ich hätte eher würde mir
ausmalen fack was ist noch alles weg was kann noch alles passieren ja sei es
jetzt von online banking bis paypal bis amazon bis alles mögliche ich glaube
da hätte ich richtig panik bekommen ich glaube ich hätte nicht einen zweiten
youtube channel in dem gut er macht das hauptberuflich ja verstehe ich
trotzdem also ich habe wahrscheinlich andere dinger gedacht lebens war einfach
so ein so ein kitschiges tumblr bild einfach bei egal wo ich hingeschaut habe
du hättest da so einen blöden spruch drunter legen können so und es hätte
gepasst das kann durchaus sein dass das was größer geplant das war wenn das so
war aber wahrscheinlich alles mit der gleichen masche also war vielleicht hat
man sich ja koordiniert es kann ja durchaus sein dass er sich die dass er
sich ja irgendwie den trojaner schon drei vier tage vorher eingefangen hat
kann ja sein
dass man das geplant gemacht hat quasi dann überall zeitgleich sich zu
erkennen gegeben hat fack wo war ich denn jetzt mit dem video
ah ja nichts ging mehr mein körper war so schwach meine sehe das macht ich
fertig von seinem ursprung einfach dass ich würde es vielleicht anders
ausdrücken ja aber ich kann mir das das ist wirklich die ich kann sich anders
und die geht der arsch auf kund als jaja war einfach was und ich war wirklich
wirklich selten so es gab einen moment da habe ich wirklich ein paar tage
geweint damals das ist nicht mehr so weit hin und dann
passiert so etwas dass alle kanäle verschwinden krieg richtig ich zitter
innerlich wenn ich darüber rede weil das ich mich aber dran erinnere
bestimmt wollen viele wissen aber wie haben die jungs denn geschafft sich
172 trojaner zu gönnen ja alter ich weiß es nicht es ist wir
spekulieren hier ganz davon abgesehen wenn du einen trojaner hast ist der weg
zu 172 nicht weit logischerweise ja also wenn du einen hast kannst du sachen
nachinstallieren also wenn du den richtigen dir eingefangen hast da kannst
du sachen nachinstallieren also das ist egal einer reicht es macht
keinen unterschied ob einer oder 172 vielleicht ein paar ideen aber die sind
nicht fundiert es ist nicht based on irgendeine garantie hier dass das klar
ist dass es daher kommt wir wissen auch nicht wann das ganze passiert ist so wie
youtube ja gesagt hatte kann das auch schon viel früher passiert sein wir
könnten uns schon viel früher infiziert haben aber die haben das
gerade jetzt würde ich mir gedanken machen an seiner stelle was haben sie
wahrscheinlich auch was hast du denn noch oder was habt ihr noch auf diesen
rechnern gemacht wer war noch wo eingeloggt welche password manager habe
ich da drauf gehabt vielleicht und habe dinge aus dem ram abgegriffen bekommen
also sprich auf welche sachen hat man das noch bb monitor ich traue der
aktuellen youtube influencer geschichte alles zu aber in dem fall glaube ich
nicht zumal ein kollege von mir den ich ganz gut
kenne der m core auch krypto scam hack gehackt wurde auf seinem channel und
das ist niemand der sowas fake der hat mit youtube auch gar nicht mehr viel am
hut nee das ist kein fake das glaube ich in dem fall nicht zutrauen würde ich
den ganzen influencer dudes aber in dem fall nee das ist kein fake
ostan aktiviert weil wie gesagt da der support der plattform immer am
geringsten ist ja weiß ich nicht das hätte vielleicht ist letztes jahr
passiert vielleicht ist es ich würde mir jetzt echt gedanken machen an ihrer
stelle was habe ich noch alles mit diesen rechnern gemacht was hätte man
noch alles abgreifen können email account sind da
beispielsweise auch ein wunderbares angriff ziel weil wenn du den eine
wesentlichen viel benutzten email account zugriff hast kannst du bei ganz vielen
anderen diensten wieder password resets machen passiert wo ich am pc war wie und
warum auch immer ich weiß es nicht dass das nervt mich auch ein bisschen am
meisten weil ich würde gern wissen wo der fehler liegt ich würde gehen das
würde mich auch an seiner stelle interessieren sogar noch mal doppelt
drauf achten muss ich weiß es nicht parallel alle pcs
die
gemacht neu aufgesetzt weil wir halt auch ein bisschen schiss hatten dass ich
irgendwie so ein trojaner kack noch zwischen daten versteckt ja kann
durchaus sein und klar habe ich auch dokumenten videos fotos für die
ewigkeit verloren ich meine stellt euch warum ich sag euch ihr habt jetzt fünf
minuten zeit alles von zu hause mitzunehmen bevor gleich alles weg ist in
der eile werdet ihr auf jeden fall irgendwas vergessen und ihr werdet es
erst merken wenn es zu spät ist am selben tag haben wir bekommen dass
youtube usa gerade mit youtube asia und mit unserem partner manager von youtube
germany also marco zusammen in
in calls oder du hast doch nicht nur fünf minuten zeit kann sich stecker
rausziehen aus dem rechner und alles speichern was du willst
netzwerk stecker aus gut ist
der fack
neuen rechner kaufen zweifel zwar den alten stehen lassen in der ecke und
später sachen sichern
im fett oder oder anderen rechner man erkennt noch genug leute aber das ok
ja vielleicht
gerne hängen vielleicht ist der gedanken gang
anders gewesen er kann sein der case einfach so kompliziert ist und immer
mehr last fällt auf mein rücken und drück mich noch tiefer in den boden ich
war schon im boden ich wurde nur noch reingedrückt und kam
und wie er aus der stufe hat schwede und dann kam die kreise nachricht er war
nicht
nur alle videos sind weg sondern es wurden gerade sogar zwei kanäle von uns
komplett gelöscht und ich nur so
ja gut es war eigentlich das war jetzt irgendwo youtube autodetection die
festgestellt hat kripto scam oder sowas
und der grund warum die gelöscht wurden war ganz einfach weil wir einfach die
richtlinien der kommunikation das dachte ich mir haben weil dieser dieser
hektos käme der dieses streams hochgeladen hat so scammy links in die
video beschreibung gepackt genau das war klar das war in autodetection also es
waren wir ja nicht mal und trotzdem war das hatten verstoß für das system von
youtube und deswegen wurden die kanäle einfach aus dem system rausgenommen und
wir so poch alter das war wirklich ein das war ein massaker ein maschinengewehr
von bestrafungen das wirklich auf ja ich kann sich aufgenommen ich kann mich da
wirklich ich kann mich da reinfühlen ja also ich hatte auch schon dinger
und natürlich nicht in diesem ausmaß ja und zum glück bei mir nicht mit
youtube nur mit anderen accounts wo ich auch dachte ach du scheiße alter ja ist
also das ist das ist kacke dauerfeuer war es macht dich halt auch so fertig
weil das unvorbereitet kommt du rechnest ja damit nicht
wie gesagt also eines der härtesten dinger war weiß ich noch wo wo ich mal
in einem mmo gebannt wurde das kannst du jetzt nicht wirklich mit als 5
millionen sub youtube account vergleichen ok aber ich meine in meinem
alter damals ich habe da tausende stunden spielzeitrenne gehabt wurde gebannt
weil ich angeblich leute beleidigt habe im chat und ich habe das hätte ich
hätte durchaus damals leute beleidigen können im chat ja aber ich habe das
nicht geschrieben und das da bin ich dann damals drauf gekommen dass ich habe
meinen account geschert damals das war nicht das problem muss ich sagen ich
habe nicht dass das sondern derjenige mit dem ich den account geschert habe
und eines war nicht der friseur derjenige hat sich wohl irgendeinen
scheiß auf seinem rechner eingefangen
also sprich es ist nicht so als hätte der mich gescampt
sondern der war selbst so unfähig sein rechner zu also der typ damals dem ich
den account geschert habe sicher zu halten da habe ich also da habe ich auch
mir echt fast in die host gemacht so übertrieben gesagt weil das war das war
ein account damals für mich das war so damals zu der mmo zeit war das mit mein
wichtigster lebensinhalt ja ich habe gekreidet kreiseln kann ich hat
tausende spielstunden und dann ist der account einfach weg da
haben wir noch über 50.000 abos gemacht auf allen kanälen zusammen und das ist
halt ja es ist halt schon schade weil das sind letztendlich dann auch sehr dass da
bist du nicht der einzige da so was schon gemacht hat hier ich habe mal einen
random typen PSN also ich habe das nicht gemacht aber ich ich kenne leute das
gemacht haben ja ich habe mal einen random typen PSN password gegeben dass
er mich mw2 auf prestige 9 hackt ich habe es nie gemacht wahrscheinlich war ich
schon einfach zu alt auch zu dieser mw2 aber ich kenne leute die so was
gemacht haben und nicht nur darin es gibt auch die es gibt auch die china
chinesen gold scammer so nach dem motto wir pushen dein account auf sonst was
kennen genug leute die haben das gemacht gerade noch aus der mmo zeit und fast
alle haben irgendwie probleme damit gehabt ich
meine du musst dir überlegen die leute die irgendwie so super shady sachen
machen und schon anbieten warum sollten die vertrauenswürdig sein
deine account nicht irgendwie zu scare ist bescheuert
der aktive zuschauer und fans unserer projekte gewesen die dann doch so aktiv
waren dass die den abo feed noch aktiv hatten und dann gesehen haben erst mal
in mask macht kripto sam habe ich denn da abonniert ne das habe ich nicht
abonniert de abonnieren also die dann quasi manuell sich entschieden haben
unsere kanäle zu abonnieren weil auf einmal so ein scam video da gesehen haben
und das ist halt schade weil natürlich erreichen mit diesem video auch nicht
diese menschen auch alle wieder und klar die kriegen das trotzdem empfohlen und
die sehen als wieder da also also ich gehe davon aus dass wird sich relativ
schnell erholen wird mich wundern wenn ich aber die meisten und leute das wäre
wieder moment gewesen wo ich hätte weinen können aber aber dieses andere
weinen dieses vor glückwein war einfach wie viele menschen aber tausende von
menschen täglich mir geschrieben haben wie können wir dir helfen ich sag mal
ganz ehrlich mit mich hätte genervt die leute können ja da eh nix ändern
es ist es ist es ist schön zu sehen dass man irgendwie support hat aber in dem
moment hast du ganz andere sorgen
und wahrscheinlich hätte es mich genervt aber das ist bestimmt ein stelle wahrscheinlich
hätte es mich genervt wenn mich noch zusätzlich gott und die welt anschreiben
ich muss jeden um 50 mal erklären ja hier sonst wie was passiert ich hatte
einfach nur im kopf gehabt fack ich will meinen account wieder haben die restliche
welt soll mich mal in ruhe lassen ihre hilfe angeboten haben gesagt haben
machen neuen kanal wir abonnieren sofort die teilweise mitgefiebert haben dass
diese videos irgendwie wieder online kommt die geweint haben teilweise ist
bei den leuten weißt du nicht bescheiden tausende von mails in jeden verteiler
also die leute wirklich lost ganz viele leute die irgendwie in verbindung mit mir
zusammen waren haben mails bekommen ich habe sogar bei tinder ein match bekommen
die gesagt hat ich wünsche euch viel glück rein mit den haufen
da wird erstmal auf tinder weiter gewischt bis julian bärm kommt um ihm
dann zu schreiben hoffentlich kriegst du dein channel wieder also wenn das nicht
die krasseste so mal geschichte aller zeiten ist dann weiß ich auch nicht
über eine halbe millionen story views auf jeder instagram story für so eine
lange zeit und das war einfach krass zu sehen wie viele menschen einfach so bei
uns war muss er sich nicht auch menschen dass das funktioniert hat er in der zeit
noch mal neben bei tinder mädels gescrollt habe ich diese community irgendwie noch nie gefühlt
oder in dieser art habe ich die kommunikation nie gefühlt deswegen wollte ich an der stelle
auch einfach mal meine countess wäre erstmal tinder auf ja kommen wir noch mal zurück zum
thema und den auch darauf folgenden tagen das einzige was uns übrig geblieben war war der
julian bärm kanal ohne ein einziges video halt und ohne profilbild ohne banner ohne jegliche
funktion von youtube aber mit über fünf millionen abonnenten ein toter kanal mit über fünf ja
youtube kann den kram ja zum glück geklappt oder ohne adsense konto und ihr müsst wissen diese
firma finanziert sich durch natürlich werbedeals aber halt auch werbeeinnahmen die durch die
videos generiert werden und das geht nur wenn es ein konto gibt aber das wurde komplett von uns
abgekoppelt es wurde weg von uns ist weg abgekapselt worden war ja auch gegen die richtigen
wer ist das chat wer ist es von euch haben und nein wer ist es auch kein adsense konto weil
diese kanäle wurden ja gelöscht das heißt eine unendliche lehre umkreiste mich die letzten tage
und wer ist es von euch ich war was ist mit kugeln aus für youtube usa so hijacking bezogene
formulare ausfüllen damit wir den garantieren können dass wir nicht selber diese scams streams
hochgeladen haben auf unseren kanälen oder diese scam links in die video beschreibung gepackt
hatten unter den stream ich glaube mein browser ist nicht gemacht haben aber ich glaube es noch
mal einfach eine rechtliche sache okay ich glaube ich glaube mein browser ist mein browser ist
richtig f mein browser ist richtig f okay geht wieder alles da oder so ich glaube den rest vom
video müssen wir nicht gucken oder meine hat seine account wieder und alles gut außer der
schock der schock ist bestimmt noch da und ich bin mir sicher der wird sich jetzt an vielen
stellen doppelt gedanken machen bei solchen security themen da bin ich da bin ich mir sicher die
frage ist und wie lange es hält das geht schon negativ beispiel screenshot wieder
das ist wohl wichtig wohl richtig richtig und wichtig wie ich diese rede wendung hasse alter
so leute ich gehe jetzt was essen vier stunden ich wollte heute abend ja eigentlich label
champ weiter streamen du bist übrigens die die vorschrift an im label champ mittlerweile
ich weiß es waren einige fragen und so noch im chat übrig leider habe ich mein browser
neu gestartet weil er abgekackt ist und habt ihr jetzt nicht mehr ich könnte moment ich
gucke mal in mein ha wir haben doch hier das streamer dashboard das ist doch für so was da
schauen wir mal in das streamer dashboard
et wo bloß
der fahrstuhl ne der fahrstuhl ist nicht mehr da
ok ich scroll mal kurz schnell durch
gut das bezieht sich jetzt auf das video
antivirus programme noch sinnvoll naja solange den window windows defender hast
jetzt wird jetzt wird auch noch reacted hier so muss das machen der hat das youtube game
langsam war das drauf wo haben wir denn hier stehen geblieben heute abend stream ja nach
mittag wahrscheinlich wieder noch mal mal gucken das hat sich alles aufs video bezogen
glaube ich habe nix nix übersehen ok leute da gehe ich jetzt was essen wir sehen uns
bis denn ja wenn der kieler junge mal am start mit dem möchte tatsächlich was aufnehmen wir
sehen uns bis denn seo